the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
it was another intense day of rapid
chess at the super bet rapid and blitz
in beautiful warsaw poland with crucial
tour points up for grabs players bought
tooth and nail for any advantage they
could get after another dazzling
performance the tiger from madras
vishwanathan anand galvanized his place
as the leader of the event but richard
rapport was not ready to crown him just
yet pulling off a hat trick winning all
three of his games to come within two
points of the veteran
will the hungarian catch the tiger or
will the legend reign supreme day three
of exciting chess coming up next
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
welcome back everybody to day three of
the superbad rapidem blitz held here in
warsaw poland we start the day in front
of the royal castle home of ancient
kings of the past while we have the
kings of the chessboard ready to battle
it all out in the final day of rapid
chess let's go to the studio and start
the action with yasser peter and
alejandra
wonderful views of the polish capital as
we welcome you to day three of the super
bed rabbit and blitzen warsaw the second
stop on the 2022 grand chess tour
good morning i'm peter swiddler and with
me is yasa sarawan good morning peter
always a pleasure to be with you and
alejandro here in studio in st louis
hello everybody and welcome to our show
or should i call it the vishwanathan
anon show as vichy has been leading the
tournament from start to
oh day three
peter do the honors where do we stand in
our current standings
it has been uh very much a one-man show
so far even though as you can see on
your screen richard rapport tried to
sort of crash the party a little bit
yesterday
winning all three games but vishy so far
drew only one out of his first six games
and that was a game to behold i strongly
recommend those of you who have missed
yesterday's action to
re-watch the amanda do the game from
round six uh wesley and youngsters to do
the round out the people who are about
50 in our field and then there is a very
tightly uh packed bunch of uh players uh
awaiting the
last day of rapid today and then
18 rounds of blitz well let's go forward
the format tell us about the format
peter
the rabbit and blitz tournaments in the
gct are basically three round robins
wrapped into into one
today is the last day of the rapid one
with a time control of 25 plus 10 and
tomorrow and the day after tomorrow
there will be two separate round robins
of five plus two withdrawal for our
drawers are not allowed and as you can
see on your screen uh the rapid games
come double so it's very important to
start uh really well and the vishy
has been done yes he has and are very
much on top of that
as you were mentioning our schedule yeah
the schedule is uh
today is the last last day of rapid play
three more rounds today and then we will
get uh nine rounds of blitz on sunday
and nine rounds of blitz on uh monday
with colors reversed and on monday if
people are tied for first there will be
playoffs excellent and alejandro boy
have we've been treated to a large
number of decisive games good morning my
friend good morning yasser good morning
peter pleasure to be with you here
bright and early in st louis of course
here in the studio we've had a great
event so far but four people that have
stood out from the rest of the field or
the people with a positive score so far
in this tournament let's start with
wesley so who in the grand chess to
remember he's the grand chess tour
defending champion started very well off
in bucharest and romania started with
the win against shakur madiyarov but
wasn't able to finish off the tournament
properly had the event in his hands in
the tiebreak against mvl wasn't able to
finish off his opponent ended up sharing
first and didn't win the tiebreak here a
little bit of a topsy-turvy approach he
drew his first round lost the second one
the third hasn't really been able to
string all of those victories together
but remember he is a big blitz
specialist he has been doing very well
in this rapid and blitzes meanwhile the
local hero jan shishtov duda has done a
good job of bouncing back from his
losses he had a loss on round two and he
lost on round five and strung together
three wins and that game against vichy
in round six was just
dazzling meanwhile rika rapport has been
amazing in this event yeah he had a bad
event in bucharest but he comes back had
a 50 score on day one and on day two
he's just hat trick
three uh three out of three on day two
and he is
within striking distance of our leader
vichy anand who has just been
magnificent throughout the event
really great chess not just the results
but the way that he got there has been
very impressive with opening ideas
punishing mistakes taking opponents
materials finding interesting things to
do on the board and putting the pressure
vichy has just been all over his
opponents in warsaw and currently has a
great lead but still we have one more
day of rapid for him and 18 rounds of
blitz starting tomorrow let's see what's
in store with him with our key pairings
of the day let's go to warsaw with
anastasia and christian to take a look
at that
thank you alejandro and welcome back
everybody to day three of the super bad
rapid and blitz from location here in
warsaw poland to call all the action and
give you all the live updates i am your
host grand master christian carrillo
alongside my brilliant co-host woman
grandmaster anastasia carlovich
anastasia this is it the final day of
rapid just as we are getting ready for
the action to become even more fast and
more furious but in round number seven
what is the game that you have your eyes
set on hello everyone hello christian
pleasure to be here and have chance to
follow the games right near the plane
hall and uh have a chance to chat with
the players after the games of course i
will keep my eyes on the game between
richard robert and radoslav
richard had a great tournament yesterday
he won three games and he has chances to
catch up with the leader visha anand and
um radoslav doesn't have that great
tournament so far but he just came from
the polish championship which he won
actually so he's a current polish
champion and probably he's a little bit
third but still it's the last day and
everything can happen uh they have
played already two times and two games
richard won um i think really radik is
trying to do his best today to fight for
for for for the win maybe in this round
so we'll see it's not going to be an
easy walk for sure that is such a big uh
matchup anastasia the one that i'm
having my eyes on is the big clash
between the young romanian newcomer to
the grand chester david gavrilescu
against the dominant leader of the event
so far the five-time world champion
vichyanan and of course these players
have never met each other in the last
two rounds david actually scored two
draws so that's quite encouraging for
the young romanian but of course the
tiger of madras is still roaring this
one is going to be an exciting one guys
what games do you have your eyes set on
for round number seven well thank you
anastasia thank you christian indeed
let's take a look at all the pairings
peter so we can settle
honestly as usual in the gct there is uh
hard to pick a favorite
impossible impossible to say this is not
a great game leonardo's white against
anton koribov who's had a quiet event so
far but always entertaining extremely
entertaining and a very interesting
player a youngster of dude is white
against the other ukrainians in the
field the the yankee roshenko uh
gabrieles khan and we've just
heard about uh there's an all-american
clash there which would be a marquee
match up in virtually any tournament in
that absolutely yeah fabi white against
wesley and then the game between uh
richard rapport and uh radek wojteshek
which i also am very very curious about
because if richard continues his three
yeah sizzling hall form from yesterday
he will be
a force to be reckoned with in this
tournament and it's it's nice to see him
playing well after the
bitter disappointments of
bucharest and all of and here as we take
a look at the playing all just getting
ready for uh start of this the seventh
round uh
who's gonna stop fishy and then and if
nobody is you just gotta run faster
that's richard's attitude i think so
yeah and uh
there's still 18 rounds of blitz to look
forward to of course and uh there's the
match-up that anastasia is mentioning
and we were in the
in the run-up to today's show we were
discussing bish's numerous illustrious
achievements uh
in the studio here uh off air and
somewhat surprisingly he is not as far
as i understand won the world blitz yeah
that was the thing that was
extraordinary for me uh nine times world
championship titles nine world
championship titles of these one five
what you might call adult or feed a
world champions
championships but only one rapid and
three junior titles how he never won a
blitz title is yeah it's impossible it
really is very difficult to understand
considering how much of a
monster he i think still is and
definitely was in right specifically in
the blitz uh in in his younger years
absolutely i remember my first ever
experience of playing blitz against
fisher was in the chesapeake and
chesapeake that was way before chesapeal
existed right in chesapeake's offices in
hamburg yeah i thought i was a good
blitz player i was like 20 something and
felt i had this thing under control and
i think i kind of barely scraped like a
point and a half out of ten
and the feeling was he he wasn't even in
gear like he he could have done more
painful things to me if he wanted but he
was kind of friendly
he was keeping your friend yeah i
remember my blitz experiencing as vishy
yes it was at the olympiad of 2004. i
played classical he played blitz
so you were three minutes behind on time
by that's why he reached the critical
position by the time i reached a
critical position i was lost
and in the game uh between uh david and
uh vishy we have a scotch
which you know if nepa was in the
tournament i would i would understand
who was the culprit uh
uh the scotch what do we feel about the
scotch as a coach that actually works on
chess i feel the scotch is just played
out right it's just not very good
or not very good even like not very good
for an advantage or number not very good
for an advantage i mean you can still
equalize a lot of positions and a lot of
are very dynamic specifically this one's
i think can get very interesting
right but when they get interesting i
think they tend to kind of become more
interesting for black then for black
therefore that's what i i always who's
getting it
always felt yeah yeah
bishop d3 is a lot is a lot quieter
quieter yeah of course e5 is the main
line and also the sharper line of the
position but nothing wrong with the move
bishop d3 yeah in the main lines after
e5 my feeling as well is that uh
[Music]
if black knows what they're doing
these days white will be faced with a
choice of going for lines which are kind
of well known to be a draw
or if you want to try to mix it up you
will be taking risks but potentially
significant risks
uh yeah and h4 these days i think is the
you know
yeah
but
so many choices and they're very very
sharp as you said bishop d3 this ending
the so-called scotch ending i've seen it
numerous
numerous numerous times where castles
and uh bishop comes to g5 and it seems
like again that's one of those endings
that feels like it's been played
this is slightly different though
because i think when they do it in this
move order instead of sort of the
classical four knights yeah this and the
gorillas immediately shows what the
point is yeah you you use the fact that
you haven't actually played knight c3
yet that's right to challenge the center
with c4 knight c3
but it shouldn't really be uh you know
anything much at all i think black is
generally extremely comfortable in these
positions and yeah vishy will not be
concerned all right very good well we'll
just
take a quick gander at the game between
uh fabi and wesley as wow uh
they they moved quite
quickly
they're playing one of the more topical
lines of the the uh angie berlin with
it's the rui anti-berlin yeah d2d3 i
don't even know what you call it yeah
you also get positions like this from
the italian occasionally like
there's a lot of sort of
cross-pollination of ideas at the very
least and often they even transpose
uh into each other uh black generally is
doing quite okay in this position these
days i think which is kind of funny
because i just wanted to ask you about
that like if white's knight were on g3
and black were to play bishop c7 the
position would be
absolutely absolutely symmetrical but
with the knight on g6 how did black win
that race i mean somehow he got his
knight to
the preferred square i'd say white did a
lot of shuffling i mean this this bishop
took a long time to get to situ right he
went to
the major issue in these types of
positions is uh who gets to play uh
either g3d4 or e65 first and of course
white would very much like to be the
first one to occupy the occupy the
center more solidly
and then and then behind the pawns on e4
and d4 if you get to let's say your
knight to g3 you play bish p3 queen g2
or kd1 you do actually stand quite well
simply on on on the basis of your bigger
presence in the center okay but
obviously black has ways of of dealing
with this the the most
clear-cut way to to equalize these types
of positions is
uh involves pushing the 65 in response
you you do have to time it properly and
you do have to calculate your your way
out of those types of complications it's
not easy so it doesn't guarantee your
equality if you don't if you don't do it
right but that would be the
the way to absolutely solve all of your
problems i'm not sure it works right now
for instance i think it still needs to
be prepared a little bit
uh
but you can you can throw in let's say
h7 h6 wait for night of one to happen
and play g5 then
as one idea first yeah i was thinking
that white
maybe would try to root
reroute the knight maybe to the 94
bishop c7 as well yeah but now uh on e3
it kind of gets in the way yeah this is
one way of yeah this is something that
magnus does quite a bit yeah uh
it feels like you probably need to have
a bit of a larger presence on the queen
side with the pawns on a2 and b so i
don't think this is much if let's say
your pawn was already on a5
yeah yeah yeah you would enjoy it you
would enjoy it a lot right right this is
definitely something that people do
quite a lot these days
because
people started realizing that these very
very symmetrical positions actually
favor wise a little bit if you get a
foothold in particular if you get a
foothold on the queen side
and let's take a look at the lifetime
record between these two in rapid chess
and they played a lot of games that is
wow
a very dominating performance by wesley
yeah wesley's ahead uh even though it is
significant yeah whenever we get to i
don't know if you can call it a
storyline but whenever we get to these
figures
i get the feeling that it is probably
like if you if you took the last five
years or the last three years
you will probably be a lot closer
because i think uh they probably started
yeah because i think bobby he's never
been you know this this this whole
narrative of fabi you know if i be not
good at rapid chess fabian not good at
blitz it was never true right but it had
some relation to reality you know it was
somewhat adjacent to reality let's say i
don't know in 2015 or whatever
it is sort of completely completely
delusional right now there's like no
basis for it whatsoever anymore right uh
so i feel like whenever i see fabian a
large minus against
his sort of direct competition
my initial reaction is this must be
because they were killed yeah because
they were playing uh they were playing a
lot right and that is probably carry
over from from that period when he
perhaps wasn't paying as much attention
to that facet of the game i want to turn
our attention to the game of richard and
uh
um raditch
people are just having trouble and
they're not embracing the open sicilian
as white whenever i see this move d6
everybody seems to be playing bishop b5
jack or knight c3 or bishop c4
you know they're sidestepping the stuff
yeah wow
neither
i think in particular in in in rapture
people aren't really willing to uh you
know discuss the main lines and so
people want to have fun and bishop d3 is
a kind of a new
new way of uh
you know being somewhat somewhat
unserious about things
i think in this particular game it
basically transposed to bishop too yeah
c3 bishop specifically like this is this
is a position which is very very well
known bishop b5
uh i'm a bit surprised by queenie two
but yeah that was also i thought you
were supposed to take on the seven goru
ki one and d4 right but queenie two
clearly they're both playing very
quickly and uh radek uh knows his stuff
and as does as does richard
by this particular sequence i don't
think i've ever seen this before i've
just been told queen c6 is in fact a
novelty as far as our databases go i
mean okay it has a sense you you're
hitting the pawn on
on e4 because you are stepping on and
the follow-up i think is the explanation
for why he's done this because i guess
if white plays d3 you want to play c5 c4
here breaking up the structure straight
away so very understandably uh uh
richard played rookie one so that he's
ki i mean he's been winding up for d2 d4
for some time exactly yeah
and uh one day i promise i will i will
play it and that was instantly met by
queen a6 continuing to challenge uh the
white queen on itsu these end games are
going to be completely fine for black
which is i think very understandably
even if the knights offside i think
still yeah because uh without d4 it's
very unclear why you should be worse and
if you do push d4 the knight on e6 isn't
that stupid because it will jump to
before in many positions
it's one of those things again i gotta
prepare prep it i'll go i'll castle i'll
put i'll play b5 before i will i will
claim that the knight on a6 actually
does so that's what i'm trying to do in
this whole thing is try to claim that
the knights a little offsides
it's not inspiring now that we've traded
a queen in the light square bishop so
i'm assuming therefore that richard's
going to because he
split queen juan queen d1
too sophisticated for me he's played
queen j1 he does want to play d4 if you
play g3 you're really not generating an
idea of d4 anyway so he's played queen
g1 the interesting bit for me here is to
ask whether we can play knight c6
and uh
claim that we are ready to meet default
by taking taking and playing knight
before here
i mean it's legal i don't know if it's
any good you can definitely go you can
definitely do this you probably get to
win the bishop on c1 i mean win by uh
by win i mean trey train trade for a
night yeah but the thing is i'm not
entirely sure this is so great right
rookie so i guess because rookie three
probably would cost you an exchange
there
just watch out for those lurking bishops
and then and then we castle here but
white does have a pretty pretty little
center there
45 might even be playable here with some
sharpening up of the position we'll
definitely keep an eye on this one as we
turn our attention to alejandro
alejandra what have you been keeping
your eye on
well we're taking a look at this game
between duda and chefchenko going into
some kind of theory but take a look at
the times chefchaenko seems to be very
familiar
with the variation that we have on the
board and do that not so much because he
is burning time in what is a very
heavily theoretical position uh we have
a chabanenko or a6 sloth
in this game
and after the move knight e5 knight bd7
queen b3 queen c7 we start a mess that
is more or less forced this has actually
been seen quite a few times in the
recent past as players try to outright
refute these a6 slot you see the black
is not very well developed and you try
to put as much pressure on the queen
side including with the knight on e5
before black finishes off the
development with the move e6 so cd
knight takes d5 is known to be bad
knight takes e5 as force d takes a
knight takes d5 here is force there's
two moves here bishop c4 is one of them
knight takes d5 c takes d5 bishop d2 is
the other this is still very heavy
theoretical duels there's a famous game
between wesley and carlson dingley red
played this against shanklin i believe
that ended in a draw queen takes e5 is
one way of playing queen d7 i know the
engine thinks it's not so bad but queen
e5 is the main line of this position
still a lot of theory to go down the
board on this one usually white ends up
either one pawn down they could take on
b7 it is also playable
but sometimes they just gift the pawn
they go bishop e2 on castle and just put
the pressure on here because they're
taking advantage of the fact that e6
sometimes cuts the bishop out of the
queen side so it's still a fascinating
duel here queen takes e5 already played
shivchenko very well aware of the
nuances of this sharp variation duda is
the one that
what's burning some clock getting in
here and we've also seen him do i mean
not exactly the same and it's too early
to call but he's done something
potentially similar in spirit yesterday
right
absolutely when he went for a very very
topical line against wesley and then
spent ten minutes played a5 and did
something that you're not supposed to do
yeah do you want to yeah and
ended up losing
uh i don't think white runs very many
risks in this line in general but
still uh he's already burned through
eight minutes on the clock reaching a
position even i have heard of and i
don't play the sloth
[Laughter]
so
bad sign perhaps not yeah that's uh
potentially not great peter i gotta tell
you i didn't think i'd see it in my
lifetime
but at last i've seen a bishop c4 grand
prix attack or whatever it's called
against a sicilian where white's
actually got a good position i mean
lavon has been getting terrible
positions as we saw in bucharest with
this bishop c4 line i don't know why
it's become a pet opening for him but
now we'll find out exactly why as the
players have reached the position as i
was saying that i actually light white's
position right after this move knight c4
but i i will say that uh anton i think
for for this game chose a very very uh
sort of a quiet uh approach to
uh meeting the bishop c4 line uh the the
positions we didn't like for white
pretty much every single time involved
black developing the bishop to g4
and uh
with upon obviously steel on e7
something like knight c6 and then bishop
g4 h5
which
very heavily incentivizes white to play
h3 g4 and go for those types of
structures right which are incredibly
double-aged
and those could backfire even though in
this tournament we have seen uh
rickard grapport get a winning position
against one on the white side of this so
it's not like uh it has been uh
struggling every single time but
uh these are sharp right whereas what
anton has done
he just said okay i don't care i'm
playing i'm gonna set up my sicilian
like i'm playing my moves on my half of
the board whenever i'm doing the off
right exactly and then bishop c4 is you
know as good a move as any honestly it
develops a piece it allows you to uh to
get these types of setups and yeah this
is a very nice nice little edge i would
assume for white i would assume so too i
like these especially
you know
somehow in this exact uh pawn structure
this bishop on
c8 really never ends up having a good
life sometimes if you put your bishop
here you'll you'll be met by f2 f3 down
the level yeah and
yeah and white just seems to be enjoying
uh
the the the tidings it's not it's not
really horrible for anything but yeah
you definitely take this as an outcome
of the opening when you play uh bishop
c4 move three uh agreed wholeheartedly
and alejandro what do you have for us
well let's take a look back at this game
between favi and wesley a classic
matchup between two of the top players
in the country and we got this position
we left it off here more or less after
the moves a4 and h6 and fire went knight
f1 you guys were mentioning the
rerouting the night wesley took this as
his chance the knight is not in the
center anymore let me go ahead and
exploit that fact by counter-attacking
in the center you got d4 i got d5 let's
see how we pair up here my knight is
already on g6 yours is not on g3 so
perhaps this battle in the center will
favor black and indeed after pawn takes
d5
e4 was either missed or underestimated
by favi with the knight on g3 you can't
play that because knight takes e4 but
with the knight on f1 you have the
chance to play e4 attack the knight on
f3 if the knight moves you take back the
pawn with your own pawn creating a
strong structure i don't know why he
thought that the move d6 was a powerful
inter mat so it's not really because
after queen takes d6 it's true you
cannot take on d5 and reinforce this
pawn but this is only relevant if you
can keep attacking the pawn until you
win it so after d6 he went knight 3d2
attacking the pawn and wesley simply
defended the pawn said bishop f5 no
problems and now how do you continue ask
what you can't move this knight to e3
because queen h2 right this knight is
stuck on f1 if you go to g3 with the
knight you run into e3 again knight
takes queen h2 is an issue you don't
have time to do that and the pawn is
overloaded defending e3 and defending
the diagonal if you go to knight f1 pawn
takes f2 is going to destroy you don't
even think about it so you can't play
knight g3
i was thinking why not knight c4 knight
e3 that let's destroys the battery the
bishop comes out but the engine was just
throwing the move queen e6 on my face
and if knight e3 bishop takes h3
you don't have enough defenders here
pawn takes queen takes h3 and because
you're threading both knight h4 and ig4
ideas depending on how white decides to
defend against the main thread which is
knight h4
you are just lost i mean is the engine
saying minus seven the curious yeah
sorry the curious part about this whole
thing and i agree with everything that
you're saying is that i actually got
mated in a very similar fashion against
fabi himself in one of the online
tournaments i think last year so he must
be very aware how dangerous
this is for white because he's he's gone
for some kind of a structure like this
against me in a blink of an eye he knew
it was very good for black and yeah i
also like i started thinking i have this
wonderful e3 e3 square for my pieces i
will be able to somehow maneuver my way
around this you get mated very quickly
yeah and
this is one of those cases what is white
playing you see favi burning time right
perhaps because he is realizing that he
doesn't have the time to maneuver his
pieces around
in this position he doesn't want to play
f3 and weaken all of the dark squares
but it is a top engine move to just give
up the hopes of attacking e4 play f3 get
some breathing room for your pieces but
playing f3 when there's a bishop on c7
and a queen on d6
barreling down on this diagonal i mean
that's that's not that's not very human
no not a happy camper yeah the issue is
if you don't do it now you might never
never get like you know if what gets 96
h4 in
you're complete like you're completely
stuck none of your pieces go anywhere
and black just calmly eventually creates
one thread and that one threat will be
enough yeah uh including some positions
where even maybe in the maybe not right
now but uh
our experience with uh
similar positions from the white side
for instance
informs us that even ideas of like
bishop takes h3gh and then let's say
queen d7
sometimes yeah sometimes work out so
yeah white is in desperate desperate
trouble in these types of positions if
you're behind on
behind on developing your own play and
you you seem like you're very much
behind on developing your own play in
this position yeah well maybe fabby is
uh recalling his game against you peter
and say wait a minute i actually want
this on the right side
uh i was i mean it's not my first choice
but that whole line i think this is
something like that
i played something like rookie three
queenie two trying to attack the the
pawn on e4 and it just never worked it
just never i was trying to never end h3
because the the lines that alejandro was
showing where i go queen knights e4
queen e6 and i get victimized uh by the
sacrifice here i was hoping that
i mean i could i'm trying to win the
pawn i mean the
true confessions right i mean i'm trying
to win the pawn i
i whoa
i mean rookie three was a good movie
okay
it's like way too early i've been
waiting too early in saint louis for
power to be playing gg
i mean i'm a pawn grabber right i i mean
obviously his hope is to drive the
bishop away so that he can win the pawn
on e4 yeah some kind of even i
you know would not i'd be very hesitant
uh what about you peter to play such a
move yeah
i just wanted to look up what yeah this
is this is this is this is what i did
it's it's actually very very simple it's
better than what he got
but i still got made it in like the 10
10 furthermore you can't see what's on
my screen but i just wanted to remind
myself it's very very similar uh g4 i i
don't know exactly how it loses but i
would assume it just loses it it
shouldn't work well i don't have enough
defenders uh again it's too early in the
morning
to make the sacrifice it means
marshall's sacrifice i appreciate it oh
yes you see your training's working out
okay but this is what i accept this is
some martial sacrifice you do i'm very
vicious
i mean this is fantastic for black but i
want more you want more okay i want more
i want to play i want to play something
like
uh
knight h i don't know i don't know why
it works and i'm not going to put it on
the computer so it's up to you guys e3
works go go on
e3 or e3 right away works and i don't
know why
okay well first of all i mean uh
there's so many that i mean this bishop
i would like to play gf i think
everything else i kind of understand why
i'm in desperate trouble i would like to
play gf and hope i don't get mated but
yes i assume i i do get mated somehow
like ef king of two and then something
bad happens to me queen of
four check doesn't look right because
knight f3 is a good move
so why do we get mated here i don't know
dang this is very confusing
dang machines are strong
we can throw in a guest rook e8 rookie
one rookie
yeah i'm not sure about that actually
queen takes c1 if you play rookie 8 i
will quite happy to give up that queen
to limit the number of attackers
rookie eight i'll take on the a take on
g6 in a split second there just to limit
the the number of pieces that are
currently giving made to my king correct
uh
yeah no idea why this is so great for
black should i
should i be looking at this
but once like i go
i'm not even sure i guess right now i'm
not even sure if this threat has oh here
i'm getting rookies
takes a four exists right bishop takes
f4 does exist so sorry let me let me
take a pawn with a slurp yeah
now let me tell you now let me see if i
can't
i still don't know what i'm finagling by
the way yeah n95 exists queen h4 exists
spanish for rookie to check i don't like
very much but 95 looks playable yeah
we're we're we're struggling we're
struggling uh alejandro why does e3 work
you take on f5 and then you just take on
d2
oh okay don't don't think too hard
no fair and then and just put put on
an h4
it all collapses quincy five yeah
everything comes in yeah i can i can
believe that you know
yeah we were well weight is strangely
stuck isn't it yeah yeah we're we're
being a bit too romantic right yes
sometimes brutal efficiency just you
know boom boom boom hit him where it
hurts f3 is where it hurts i think
that's the hardest part of calculating
e3 is that realizing that just taking on
d2 is so good for what for black instead
of going down those variations where
you're trying to make your opponent
that's the tricky part i think from a
human point of view to look at the movie
three otherwise it's a very
it's a very fancy move and it's one that
you want to make because it opens up so
many diagonals exactly nothing wrong
with just going bishop e6 though
yeah but i mean in this position it's
sort of like you want to punch you want
to punish yes
for making such a move as a g to g4 wow
well we'll keep our eye on that again i
just want to return to vichy's game for
a moment because a lot of things
took place after the move c4 castles
takes on d5
bishop e4 c7 c6 bishop d2 yeah and i
thought this move queen c2 was really
cute because i was wondering what this
she was going to do about the double
attack
and he answered the question very simply
yeah nothing
nothing
i'm
nothing
absolutely nothing i'm going to return
the favor by uh tickling b2 that
provoked bishop
c3 and this is kind of a sad concession
right
i will happily
grab that bishop and i'll get
my marshall
two bishops
everything yeah yeah it's two bishops
and it's not even a pawn sacrifice
these are greenfield bishops come on oh
excuse me these are examples
and uh yeah you you get the feeling that
it's maybe still within the margins but
you're not enjoying yourself with white
hair yeah
i'm kind of
about to agree with you i it all depends
upon this
close your eyes peter
as a grunfeld player you're going to
love your two bishops but at least you
do not have queen b6 i would have very
seriously considered bishop takes six
just to have something to suffer for
yeah i guess black just goes b6 for now
exactly i'm pretty sure it is white
who's fighting for equality but i assume
white actually equalizes it can go rook
81 i and also it gives you the fantastic
square on d5 for your pieces which i
very much need yeah if you play queen b6
bishop d5 for queen b6 95 even stronger
yeah try to swap some swap some pieces
of the board exactly
yeah i'm curious why why he didn't do
that what has he done instead oh he has
i mean he's still thinking yeah okay
yeah sorry for some for some reason i
thought
something played something was played
yeah yeah otherwise my second best move
in this mission i think is rook ac one
or maybe even the immediate b3 because
the pawn needs to be on b3 if we're not
taking on c6 we absolutely must ensure
that the pawn gets to b3 without any
material lost because uh
that the bishop six will continue being
very strong but it will be shooting
somewhat you know into the language into
the void yeah yeah whereas with the palm
b2 black has a very very uh
clear target for attack and he does go
rook ac one
um
i wish he can still play bishop b6 but
it once again invites the idea of bishop
take c6
and
let's just take a break here in studio
and turn turn it over to warsaw what do
you have for us anastasia and christian
thank you uh yes sir while we were just
uh walking around the playing hall and
trying to gauge the interest of the
public as well as the players anastasia
what can you tell us about that yeah
first of all i would like to say that we
have very good tradition here in poland
um before the rounds people are
uploading you know like greeting the
players and at the end of the rounds
they do the same too i think it's really
nice i feel this really nice atmosphere
chess atmosphere here in the plain venue
and of course it's also nice to see many
people gathering next to the plane when
you and play in chess all the time i've
seen maybe about 100 people yesterday
and they were expecting more people
today also some ukrainian refugee kids
will come to play in the tournament so
actually the organizers are doing great
job with all these side events and
inviting many people to the ground so i
mean it's really nice to be here
absolutely and what i do like about the
announcers and the announcements is that
they call the names of the players and
then immediately the public is
applauding it's almost like a face-off
during the fighting spirit the fighting
games so that's quite cool now i want to
uh point uh uh one thing for you guys in
the studio i was looking at the games of
the two young players in the tournament
the 19 year olds uh kiril chefchenko and
david gavrilasko and i was looking at
their time management and i have to say
they've made a lot of improvement
compared to the first day for example if
you look like at david's game he has 13
minutes and vishy annan who's a very
speedy player has 14 minutes not a big
difference also if you look at the game
of duda versus chef chenckel chef chenko
is the one who has almost double the
amount of time that duda has 18 minutes
against nine minutes for duda that is a
very encouraging sign for the two
youngsters so i'm going to have my eyes
peeled to those games
thank you
christian and anastasia
bishop d7 yeah
he back down did wesley uh so
you still pick black here in the
heartbeat i think white is uh
but in this case after bishop d7 the
bishop e6 i understood you know you kind
of go knight h4 and bishop d5 you
challenge for the f3 square with the
bishop on d7 i still want to play knight
h4 right yeah you you have an f5 thread
here uh potentially and but the bigger
question is exactly how are we supposed
to develop any of our pieces with white
um with the with the king side
completely ruined uh the extra pawn not
really being failed at all with the
bishop on c1 okay
let me go in marshall style
f7f5 i can also play h5 uh
h5 is not uh
all together ridiculous queen g3 maybe i
i assume your idea was to play queen j
it was actually it was i wanted to play
bishop d2 and queen g3 right away yes
because g5 exists here though h5 h5
allows bishop g5 thank you thank you
i'll take it why didn't we like f5 yeah
let's go with five yeah right i don't
know why i was going to take and which i
assumed bishop takes and i was going to
play bishop d2 but when you see check
probably wins material right you've
a lot of them but there's been
seven
bishop g queen g6 wins a lot of material
h6 wins like all of the material yeah
good morning st louise
i need more coffee uh knight h4 just
okay yeah
my issue with white here is that i i
don't quite understand how we are
supposed to deal with development yeah
black is clearly much better the
question is whether you know it's
already decisive or
whether the engine with its usual
precipitation
somehow holds this together it doesn't
yeah it just looks horrible
wow just looks absolutely horrible
tomorrow okay fabi not making
it out of the opening i just wanted to
okay this was
i was wondering how uh duda was going to
solve this issue
of course if you're white you're
dreaming you know you just get your king
out of the center put your bishop on c3
you've got great play as white but the
problem is the d2 bishop is hanging how
are you solving it
seems logical yeah we can play queen a3
we can play queen b6 i quite like queen
a3 queen a3 yeah because you know white
if white is ever to be better here the
the outside passer on the a file will
have something to say about it
and it actually makes a ton of sense to
block it on a2 it's surprisingly
difficult to shift those types of
bishops like you get the bishop to a3
yeah and you ask why to physically move
it from there
it's not it's not as easy as it sounds
yeah so i like i like queen a3 better
than i like queen b6 something needs to
be done with the threat of rugby one
correct the reason i'm saying
you know i'm only naming queen moves in
this position is because you don't want
to be alone rupee one with a tempo
exactly and i love the move queen a3
because i'm kind of like i want to play
queen c7
i want to move my queen i want to play
rook to c7 but rook to c7 is kind of an
empty yeah well maybe on a good day you
just take it and play rook a-8 yeah
absolutely i think black is completely
fine blick is okay look has a very solid
central structure the bishops on even if
they don't go to a3 the bishops on d7
and d6 will provide enough coveral for
the potential advances on
on the a file and honestly in many cases
i can very easily imagine the a2 pawn
actually being a weakness
strength if black doubles up on the
a-file with their rooks
later in the game i get that as well and
as we say black has no weaknesses i mean
it's
intriguing uh again quick gander
at vici's game queen a5 yeah she's fine
the question is whether he is better or
not i don't think so i think we can play
i keep on trying to play b3 because if
you take on six i think the the larger
issue is not maybe even bishop b6 it's
bishop f5 but fife is kind of awkward to
meet
is a2 hanging in this particular case
though peter i think it like these types
of positions kind of i think they very
often just end up with everything
getting traded but i don't
immediately i hope i don't i hope i
don't get my hand stuck in the cookie
jar over on the queen side but yeah but
very often it ends up with everything
coming coming off the board and even
here let's say i can consider at least
playing rook a1 you will take on v3 with
the queen i assume
i want to take rook takes doesn't make
any
stakes and take on a7 put the rook on c7
i think i mean
david has made an interesting decision
he played knight a i think he's
channeling you he just wants to get in
b2b three yeah but when he does it i
wanted to do it without playing uh
playing knight a4 and that doesn't
really belong on a4 and it also it kind
of completely gives up control over the
g4 square right so
if black can somehow say go c65 straight
away right because i currently can do
this you don't have a convenient but now
b3 and might take c5 next right b3 c4
though ah b3c this is what yeah this is
very cute oh no this is very cute i get
skewered
i get scared and vishy
on the spot
yeah i assumed that david was intending
to play b3 here because this is why you
play knight a4 precisely and yes
we can take with the pawn right
but then that
rick takes c4 yeah rugby four looks very
very uh i i'm getting my i'm getting my
pieces all messed up i'm not a happier
she can't be here no this is kind of
horrible no this this went south on me
and this is why i wanted to play b3 with
a knight steal on c3 and try to perhaps
like my ideal setup in my in my mind was
b3 and then perhaps bishop f394
something like this
this knight needs to be in the center it
doesn't it doesn't i would like to i
would like to keep it on some reasonably
central squares even this position as a
greenfield player i play bishop d4 here
i play cc5 i take black with a
oh very very comfortably but uh well
here's the chance
c4 is a huge move for
okay and again vishy is running away
with our shows so far so far in this
tournament
when you win five games in a row and uh
yeah yeah you you're
you're you you get top billing yeah so
far in this time he hasn't missed those
little tactics uh at all and this is
something i expect him to get right away
oh yeah richard of course again he's not
standing still either richard is really
at least putting a lot of pressure on
the she but for vichy i mean wow uh just
spectacular i mean
you have these dreams sometimes you know
like you'll go to a tournament and
you'll perform very very well but this
is this is certainly off the chart with
his wonderful streak uh turning it over
to you alejandro you've got a very
confusing looking position over there
we just saw it actually it was the game
between duda and chevchenko but instead
of queen a3 chef checker play the move
bishop b4 i like this move as well it's
typical for this variation where the
queen kind of jumps back and forth
between b2 and e5 and it's just
important that it has the e5 square
because after rook c2 any other queen
move loses but queen e5 allows you to be
able to take on b4 and then return the
rook to b8 in case of an eighth ranked
check so queen a check can be made by
either rook b8 or queen b8 that's why
it's important the queen goes to e5 not
to f6 or anywhere else and the engine's
liking black's position thinking they're
absolutely fine bishop takes can be
played rook takes and then black is
ready to castle and start actually
putting more pressure on white's king
than white is going to do with the past
pawn remember keeping the king the
queens on the board means that we're
really far away from an end game these
queens might not be in danger of being
exchanged at any time soon wesley played
a curious way in a curious way in this
position because after uh the take on e4
we did consider the move f5 which the
engines thought was strong but they also
like this move bishop e6 f5 can also be
played in the next move but it is
preparing bishop d5 it looks like a
waste of a tempo compared to the lines
we were looking at but still very strong
what does y do in the meantime so very
big strong advantages here for black let
me see if she has pance of course he
found c4 yes yeah c4 on the board and
that's a huge move rook d1 the engine's
saying bishop e6
plus
five what
five for black
why
because if you're a gruntfeld player you
would understand that it's a i'm in the
position the queen side is just
collapsing i guess so even if you take i
guess rook b4 just starts winning
materials yeah you just start losing you
just start losing everything heavy
pieces yeah and then you just start
losing everything down this and it's
played it at this game it's just going
to be at this yeah this is this is wow
this is a powerpoint pretty much over
yeah yeah
so yeah it looks it looks reasonably
safe and then like three moves which
weren't all that great and the game is
over i think that this is one greenfield
is a strong opening
especially when you start with the
chessable of course if you get peter's
chest
you know grimfield is even better when
it's a scotch right here
or something if you don't mind uh
alejandra i needed to ask you a question
about the duda game against kiro because
i have no problems with the move bishop
before either but i did have a real
problem with the move queen a3 i didn't
find
any way
peter suggested queen a3 i didn't find
anyone you mean queen a3 for black and
gold yes yes perfectly fine as well but
just give me the the computer's move
against queen a3 because i i didn't come
up with anything at all uh could a3 in
this position exactly yes uh well you
can't play something like rook b1 the
queen is defender right yes you can be
one and fight for the file before black
finishes development or you can be a
real computer and play the move rook c6
nice it's not going to happen right
but
that looks like
but rupee one is a very human move right
you and then like a rookie and then you
rocade and then i don't trade you can't
that was where i stopped according to
the engine if you take it's equal
only yeah but you can't play the move
queen beside when you don't actually
force the trade of the queens so easily
because you don't want to give up the
eighth rank right you don't want to play
q87 takes takes rook b8 check no that
was not the intent so you want to start
with bishop d6 right but after rook hc1
you're still you're still not really
ready to play queen a7 because takes
takes rook b6 is still annoying so white
has to do black has to do the same thing
white did here king e7 and put the rook
on b8 and it just says equal it doesn't
say that there's an advantage because
for example rook c7 you cannot take
because bishop b4 that's awkward and you
start hitting the bishop it says it's
equal but the variations kind of go on
uh more than one way to play for both
sides but queen a3 certainly possible
instead we have this position on the
board also an interesting one black here
is turning to castle the moment
newcastle this king is just worse than
dear's opponent this pawn on a2 we
mentioned could be a target eventually
black just needs to coordinate his our
major pieces again so white isn't a
little bit of a clock not just because
he has 5 minutes and 30 seconds left but
also on the board to generate something
while the king is in the center whether
it's to harass the major pieces to push
the a pawn to make a throat against
something he needs to do something while
the king's on e8 and black has not fully
coordinated his pieces
thank you for that alejandra by the way
in a lot of the birds eye view of the
players that i've been seeing duda in
particular he always seems to have that
kind of frustrated like
like he's not uh happy with a lot of the
positions that he's it's not flowing as
freely as he uh he often makes it look
uh in this tournament you see that
little shake of the head i i said yeah i
see this
coming from him
uh very much so a game that we kind of
lost track of is the game between anton
and levon and after anton's last move
bishop takes e4 i think it's safe to say
the game just blew blew up on us peter
has this been missed
by levon well levon's last move was he
he he wanted to try to tickle this rook
uh which is protecting the bishop so he
played the move bishop g3
uh in order to essay bishop b8 and and
said well wait a minute i mean that
bishop is not defended
along the third rank let me take it but
there should be a four of knight b-2
exactly
what am i missing
it should be eight now you'd like to
return the favor to the knight but as
you said peter knight b2 will fork a lot
of units yeah
i'm not even losing an exchange here
yeah we're losing more than the exchange
because i was thinking maybe you just go
bishop d5 take on a7 take on c4 you play
compensation but you just played knight
b2 anyway
ah compensation
yeah nightmare wins a real it's a rook
i mean you don't get any compensation
for that
wait what am i what are we missing we
should be we must be missing something
right
you would like to play rook b7 but the
rook on b6 isn't hanging so white will
just take the bishop there
ah and their production you just said
bishop e4 is a blunder
i like that we have this like intense
grandmaster discussions and then the
production team's like what are you guys
talking about it's a blogger stop stop
talking to me just put us out of our
miseries we're sitting there trying to
sacrifice
rook a4 and bishop d5 and do we have
enough peter yeah this doesn't work
it just doesn't work i mean he had other
moves in this position after the move
bishop g3 because well you are
threatening bishop b8 main threat of the
position but you can move the bishop
back to 8 or c8 whether this is
comfortable for black or not we can
argue that later it doesn't matter
because bishop e4 straight up loses
material
knight b2 to begin with is actually a
funny way of refuting this
because the rook needs to stay on the
third rank right and if you move to e3
then bishop f2 so that already wins
material but this one wins more material
bishop b8 hits the rook the engine says
there's no better move rook a4 knight b2
hits everybody
and that's quite the party and now i
guess the idea is to go here take some
rook d2 can't move the knight because i
take on g2 even then i'm up a piece
right yeah conversion is very hard a lot
of counter play computer says actually
blocks fine but you do have rook b1
right defensive knight it's awkward it's
awkward as heck for a few moves because
this pin very annoying this bishop kind
of trapped after e5 so you have to
finagle your way back into the position
but you will because you're up a piece
and the rooks are not coordinated just
yet the bishop also can't really
participate so you will one day the edge
is saying it's a winning position for
white even though it might take forever
to actually get your position back into
coordination but a piece is a piece and
i don't really quite get it because
bishop v8 looks
excellent excellent yes yeah just simply
excellent and there it is wow the bishop
b8 is going to be a good one and usually
this is a bad sign when your opponent
plays a move like bishop takes e4 you go
oh my gosh is that playable and then you
go wait a minute i got bishop b8 and
then he's frozen
you're the one that's putting all your
pieces on three anton come on sorry well
i wanted to say that it's mystifying
because it's impossible to miss bishop
that was the the threat was
created by the bishop g3 and try you
know it's it's not like he didn't know
this was coming so
i didn't notice it right yeah yeah yeah
bishop g3 came with the telegraph signed
delivered by lemon
the the the
horns were blowing uh yeah i'm i'm a bit
confused as to exactly what he could
have
possibly missed when he'd look on e4 so
they should be hey we'll keep an eye on
this one i just want to quickly check on
vichy's game i think it's probably
bishop d5 not bits i think he thought
okay if the bishop d5 display seven
bishop c4 he is not doing that poorly
yeah it might be true yeah why is he
getting that position yeah but why you
even have to rush to lose an exchange
that's also a good question because like
black wasn't actually worse exactly
you're rushing to lose an exchange until
like you say peter okay i get it you
missed knight b2 but
was this position required that i mean
you have other moves here it's a bit
annoying but yeah you can play bishop c8
uh bishop bishop
rook rook d7 uh
knight b2 very quickly
rook a2
and again this is the
at least an exchange sacrifice uh
you're likely a piece of sacrifice i
think sacrifice on e4 yeah exactly
exactly not just bishop d3 i can imagine
not winning for white but
what
really yeah i can imagine sometimes but
i mean sometimes knight d3 bishop d3 you
know
like if i get c4 and d5 in i'm not yeah
b6 is an important thing yeah but here i
take take i play c4 i play 65
you know it's not that easy
no this is this is a tricky conversion
if i get the pawn to h4
it's the problem i don't get if i if i
get the h5 h4 and i would suggest maybe
i'm not even doing that poorly at all
and the rook only one is very very
restricted yeah that's unfortunately
true yeah but okay the the in that case
it is the peace sacrifice you take on e4
you get your doubled rooks on the second
rank
and whether it's with e5
c4 yeah i think i think you need to cut
off the bishop on v8
yeah and now the hope is to somehow play
c5 c4
i go i don't know i'm choosing between
e6 and the 8 is difficult for me this
early in the morning let's say let's say
e6
e6 yeah
and i've got to get my and my hope here
is to play c4 and bishop c5 check and
then maybe the bishop gets to some good
squares somehow even then i don't really
understand what my threats are i feel
like i'm playing g4 and i'm shuffling my
king yeah somehow you know
you are i'm making a b line towards the
knight i mean it's a kind of a strange
thing and
there's a certain case if i could get my
king to see one i understand yeah the
problem for black also in many lines is
that c4 helps
e5 on the board by the way yeah but c4
will help white bring the bishop yeah it
allows me if if i'm allowing bishop a7
i'm not playing c4 i think in most cases
i i would like to play c4 under
conditions which don't allow white to
play whichever
response in that case yes i mean we're
we we're all in agreement we should
probably watch something else because
this looks like all right uh
i want to i want to turn our attention
back to our tournament leader vichy
dominating yeah this is this game is
over oh this is over and we are watching
it because we are vultures of the
chessboard exactly
and you can resign yeah the the sea pawn
just wins basically it's just you're
pawn up and you're also crushing
cpan express i agree with you every
single piece is stronger than it's uh
it's counterparty well these bishops are
just raking
um
you've heard it here folks you you've
heard it here first folks uh the
grunfeld strong strong
like the benko gambit it is strongest
when reached from another opening right
right the transpositions are so good yes
all right well we'll just
kind of wait for the hand shaker
probably i think bishop i think we can
wait for bishop f5 handshake right right
yeah that's what happened queen b3 c2
without even trading the queens by the
way
one of the things i've always
uh
i like it's not that i'm a stat guy as
as to statistics but i always liked
you know outstanding performances in
terms of tpr
a tournament performance rating like
what have been you know the most
outstanding 2 900 results 23 000 results
who's got them bobby fisher gary casparo
if fishy wins this game
he's on a 3 000 performance clip i mean
it's unbelievable i think it's higher i
think it's higher and it's sort of in
terms of those conversations it's very
important that he already made the draw
because until you make a draw those
figures yeah yeah reading like they they
look they look absurd right yeah yeah
he's gonna take on a four isn't he no
he's not no no no
he
traded i just yeah
and he just said by the way what you
doing by the way
your night
hi yeah yeah hi knight
that hurt yeah for the people that are
wondering about peter's comment the
specifically the performance rating
formula
handshake the performance rating formula
depends on at least one result
being less than
perfect yeah or
more than zero otherwise the formula
just breaks it actually doesn't work
right i once had a performance uh
rating uh midway through the tournament
of like 3350
and then i made a draw and it said
and then you made it yeah and then it
like started resembling something real
yeah i i think novgorod opened
95.
i started with four out of four in a
very strong open right and yeah and they
actually had it
in those days it was a printout on the
wall somewhere yeah
for some reason it included the tpr
right and it was legit like above 3 300
for sure how did you finish
i didn't even win the tournament
so you had like a 2700 rating per tpr
it was it was still a good tournament
yeah but i i started making draws and
then i lost a very painful game to simon
droires who
yeah yeah is a legend of soviet chess
for right
um
but peter when you when you do think
about historical great tpr events uh
which is like something
i guess right yeah that's the one that
comes to mind seven and a half one and
we were when when we were doing the
streak when we were calling the streak
we started looking up those things by
the way
it was uh anatoly karpov
yeah that linares must where
he went like plus six uh over the course
like the before yeah the first half for
for
the first
i think i'm sorry i'm i'm blanking there
but there he is our tournament for what
a performance he's got six wins one draw
for this man yeah i just wanted to say
about that
karpov event
second
in the tournament was gary casparo gary
kasparov was the world champion
highest rated player in the world
and
he gained rating
it was like a point out of her gary did
not have a bad event
it was pretty funny i i mean i laughed
one of the greatest tprs ever was by a
lady
by a lady one of the greatest tprs ever
by a lady player of stumping our panel
i'll stump our viewers i'll tell you the
answer but i want to give you one of the
greatest tprs in the history of chess
was by a lady player
yeah i don't know blanking blanking
blanking you're thinking of course of
judith polgar who had wonderful results
roam open yeah correct yeah okay you got
it you got it but you had to get past
judith who stands there eight out of
nine i think yeah
yeah and a glorious she has like 3 100.
really yeah eight out of nine will do
that
it's pretty good
it's really good
uh just something to tease you
i just wanted to bring our game bring
our attention to richard's game vichy
has won
by the way and he
this was a very very exciting end game
at one point yeah we're we're not really
now we're on screen uh yeah and this
looks like it should be very close to
equality but it really isn't because of
how awkward the black pieces are and
yeah
whoa yeah when you're forced to play at
uh
uh bishop d4 there you're not very happy
yeah no no that's it
that's it and he just resigned and
that is amazing we will be talking about
this man and this man alone normally he
has a crushing score when you think
about it it's just that vicious in the
tournament right yeah by the way uh in
many of the post-game interviews i see
rich richie coming in i'm not playing
very well oh it's all gone it's really
really bad there he cracked the smile i
swear i swear he
i mean he liked that four in a row by
the way turning quickly
he runs to b1 right yeah the rook on b6
will provide provide the end the end of
checks yeah and he is threatening mate
and one on the other side of the board
meaning that black cannot
play something like rook g2 checking a
fine and put the rook back on a2
creating two threats of mate on both
sides now
so in this position
as peter is mentioning rook b6
to b8
mate is unstoppable so we should be
watching the all-american pair i think
that's yes that's the interesting
position left
stabilized to a uh
they have been playing very slowly we've
been seeing numerous end games
uh sorry but peter you were saying that
it doesn't look as as lost as it used to
look it still looks kind of horrible for
white like you you can see what fabio
had to do to stable he went
back like and then he doomed it himself
by playing three yeah like oh my god
right the the length he had to go to
to kind of not get mated immediately are
quite remarkable but he seems to be
still kind of borderline borderline
alive that's the thing about them right
they're almost dead
yeah yeah don't die they get fighting
you stab in the heart five times and you
might as well make it a sense yeah it's
a very yeah it's a very sad idea of
playing queen g556 queen h4 and then
potentially back to f2
but you still do have that extra pawn
which allows you some kind of a you know
leeway if you if you have to give up
some material that's all that's all you
ask our needs
yeah just hang on to the ponds hang on
to the pond defense
yeah well it's not that victor coachnoy
that was his formula yeah yeah i mean he
walked through the gobi desert for a
pond barefoot
and i mean what suffering this is this
is clearly horrible for white yeah but
you still don't really see a decision
you just know you just know you're doing
really well with black but okay it's
certain there's no immediate conversion
that that i can support at least
i think everybody has fallen for this is
you fall in love with your position i
mean wesley said they're going got a
great position got a great position and
you let it slip away
uh peter uh
where
where do you go here if you're wesley f6
on the board
you need to start creating
actual threats and uh
i mean it is bishop c4
definitely
yeah
definitely on the menu g5 just drives it
all the way back to uh to f2 that unless
there's a refu that feels helpful
doesn't it for white not really it also
kind of cements the knight on f4 right
true it's well protected
yeah why doesn't going to have any
account to play on the king side we
don't have to worry about
is it time to play moves like c5 in some
positions yeah yeah
if you can open up the queen side here
bishops in the center it probably leads
to collapses bishops before we go rookie
93 no hang on i i will take on e8 twice
right
maybe we can play rookie one question
well rocky one
i like your naive one i mean yeah yeah i
like your night knight d3 a lot yes i
mean you will literally end this yes
yeah no i mean it's not trapped i'll
play queen e3 but know
actually it's not that bad for white
because queen e3 hits the queen on eight
and then i will
i try to take the on e3 and bishop b3
this looks pretty bad
i mean compared to everything else we've
been watching
bishop
i go knight g4
and i claim that i have counter play on
the other side of the board and it's not
even as ridiculous a claim as
uh it might appear it might have been in
some other positions maybe you do throw
it yeah he has played he has played
rookie one yeah you can include hghg i
think in from the very start maybe
even it's not a very easy move to make
something like king of seven i think
wesley is wesley is being a little bit
too
too feisty no
is a threat now right so we need to take
on the 8 queen e8 and b4 let's say
before and move he's gone
bishop c1 he's gone bishop c1 which
looks like a blund
blue knight d3 takes takes takes takes
queen e3 at the end
is no longer a check this blunders in
exchange no oh he wants to be queen c2
maybe
he wants to play quincy too
what a tricky guy wily wily little foxy
yeah look at that yeah
93 quincy two that's a nice cheat that's
an easy cheap that is a very nice
cheaper tool to miss yeah and suddenly
the game is over in the direction we did
not
really anticipate yeah right
okay but bishop c1
uh double bishop d5 played by wesley
bishop d5 this is improving for white
you you you start seeing the outlines of
how you actually come out of the corner
here i can take only eight twice played
knight e3 i liked your taking on h4 yeah
take twice on an e8 and take on h5 or
take on h5 actually and start luring the
pieces away from from my king yeah on a
very good day after
after taking everything you can you can
definitely start seeing how yeah he goes
queen c2 he actually uh yeah once wants
the maximum before he starts trading
actually has the threat yeah he might
actually in the game he might actually
get to play knight g3 next and put it on
f5 and like this position is like it's
blowing up i don't know
i know it's bad recognizable from from
what we've seen a moment ago yeah yeah
this is uh definitely three months
better yeah much much better than it is
yeah yeah
wesley
did not did not land the blow and now
yeah i think if he goes king j7 we just
take only a twice we call knight e3 he
went king
king of fate yeah i like this because
neither five check will not be a check
yeah there will be no check but i still
do the same i think i take on e8 twice i
go knight e3
i agree because i need like i'm
attacking the bishop on d5 i i would
like yeah i would like to start
challenging those pieces yeah and he's
going for it i think twerk they can
already twist e3 it looks very sensible
yeah we're not really potential
potentially we're not threatening knight
takes d5 yet because of queen e1 check
but we can play something like bishop g2
or king f1 or
something
and the bigger issue we've stabilized we
can play queen f5 and create you know a
thread finally hg honestly
it's a very useful inclusion for wesley
especially while you cannot take with
the f
exactly yeah
black probably is still completely fine
but we're now actually discussing if
black is fine which was unthinkable
unthinkable earlier yeah yeah
well i mean
wesley has a great night but he's had a
great night for him
it's starting to get to the point where
wesley's only compensation is the great
knight right
which is which he's been holding on to
for a while yeah but he hasn't
improved whereas we can definitely see
if queenie one is too dangerous i would
maybe like to play queen h2 like the
king g7 is a bit identity it's not the
best square on the school on the board
exactly
i had this very confusing idea that this
bishop could have been pinned like you
know
you want to go queen h2 and somehow
dislodge this knight but no queen after
so yeah very solid
very solid covers by the way he had
played queen h2 king g7 queen f2
and it turns out you know four moves
later that the king is worse off on g7
uh then on
oh queen e6 you're kind of what are the
clock times by the way i'm feeling like
30.
35 seconds for fabi a minute 23 for
wesley i i see some nervousness between
these two players it's still easier to
play with black uh but um
last move queen e6 introduces idea
penetrating on the green side this is
why i kind of wanted queen b3 to maybe
get the light square somewhat under
control but
yeah it's just difficult to play yeah he
goes neither five
aiming to you know offload some of the
pressure but yeah black is back to being
better but you you get the feeling that
it's holdable if you take on a five
twice which i think you do and yeah it's
done i think you'll take on f4 right
i would really yeah i mean it's ugly but
you have to
he took an f4 that was the intention
but
uh maybe i'd like to take with a
precapture with the bishop
if the queen lands only four white holds
but queen takes queen takes
and i think you do go queenie too here
bishop d3 is another option yeah one of
the things that was remarkable about
wesley's success from bucharest is he
won two games with queens of opposite
color bishops on the board i mean is he
going for a trifecta here peter
it's annoying for why the king the king
on g1 is very very unsafe it's very
annoying uh you lose this despite equal
material and no immediate threats you
lose these positions quite a bit with
white on on a low time in particular
because
it's just so much easier to slightly
somewhat improve your position and not
blunder or anything you play space three
here with white with go let's say wesley
goes f6 f5
right and and uh
as far as the bishop is concerned right
and yeah
you you
with the bishop on with the king on
juwon you never really generate a single
threat i'm surprised he allowed bishop
b6
finally the bishop actually has a
life you know i i think we need sex here
yeah or even queen is six actually
what i i was loath
loath to allow queen g3 check but maybe
we can go bishop
but i didn't understand why we didn't
play bishop e6 yeah i really wanted that
bishop out of the chain yeah like right
i'm back i'm back on f6 why yeah this is
very a very strange sequence
time time control time pressure pardon
me
is good it's it's a major factor now the
sequence is is weird to me yeah king
james
back to g1
we have oh you said it yourself very
well it's very hard to hold these
positions as well yeah but i think
instinctively you need this bishop like
i'm i'm very worried about let's say if
black allows if you allow fca five king
of six the bishop on h3 might never
return so that's my fear as well uh to
the game sorry i i we're talking about
black getting in those two i think the
reason the reason hasn't been played yet
is that wesley is trying to gauge
whether a five allows queen e6 and i
don't know managed to check against two
picks up the yeah and he goes c65 which
is also understandable but it sort of
opens up some diagonals for white as
well even if it wins the pawn on a4 i
would much rather just kill off the
pieces first like five king of six
looked like a
in particular in severe time trouble
looked like a much more annoying idea to
face by the way wesley playing very
swiftly these last few moves once he
once he set his mind on the move c5 then
it went bang bang bang and again
you have to play important time and
there goes the pond yeah but now it
gives us it gives us a tempo to play
something like queen e6 i've got queen
d1 check i'm going to do one yeah queen
do you want chocolate strong yeah queen
d2 this is a good move by the way this
is a very good move yeah because there's
like an f4 but i've got queen
cease question six we go queen d3 it's a
huge improvement we get to play whisper
five but before then we will probably
hold that honestly yeah if i think i
think in practical change you probably
want to play queen h4 here and ask the
question
whether you want to play the queen
ending
the queen ending is probably okay
because of how active the queen on d6 is
but nobody really likes playing queen
endings on 15 seconds
um
you usually it's all about kinks and
d5
so essentially wesley has the same
type of position as he had a moment ago
but with an extra opponent with an x
yeah precisely
but with an extra pawn
yeah and there was a brief glimpse there
of one one other remaining game in the
round where uh yeah young schistoph is
playing rook and bishop against rook
against the the young ukrainian kiril
shivchenko
this might go unfortunately this might
deserve at least one rook of bishop
versus rook we had a rook and night i
think that kind of covers it yeah
i don't know
good night nah you just never get any
anywhere and with that uh
i
here in saint louis we had a u.s
championship uh a ladies
uh
it was uh
anna zatonski versus uh yeah queen h2
now
yeah finished with the idea of bishop g3
and the king of h6 is surprisingly safe
surprisingly it's very very difficult to
give a single check i think you kind of
have to go all the way and check with
the five
or queen d4 yeah what if our
yeah you need you need to get the queen
to d8 or c8 and start threatening checks
from from the the black rank right
before you've gotten mated because yeah
if you allow bishop g3 you probably
never generate any counterplay anymore
in this game
and this move queen d4 does have a nasty
sting to it give me the pawn on yeah and
you can play king g7 but then you don't
actually you can play king g7 and you
should probably play king g7 can i take
on b7 yeah but i guess we take on b6 and
after bishop g3 there's currently not a
threat on on the board right yay
so we go i don't know bishop f5 but five
actually maybe drops the f3 pawn with
check which you probably don't want to
be doing sure yeah
so it's not that easy to make a maybe
you just give a check from a seven
and uh
he's gone king james
g6 that's very fancy yeah whoa
quickly queen e4 check quickly king g7
all right and again there is this queen
b7 yeah check of check from b7 and go
queen ca26 oh that was nice by wesley
just played the move bishop c7 stopping
blocking the check but defending b6 as
well yeah quincy six isn't pretty he's
gone all the way to e4 also understand
before yeah
oh that's a huge improvement obviously
if the queen got driven back from h2 we
can go king it soon now yeah i think
yeah just start getting the king out of
the corner so that there's no
threats
yeah one day the bishop will land on f5
and e4 and i think i think not only the
worst yeah i think the worst is behind
you i think i think yeah white survived
the worst from this position now that we
have king d3 as a reply to any checks
yeah we just hold this i think you can
do three immediately yeah you can go you
can cooking e3 now you can also go queen
e6 just to improve or queen f5 might be
an immediate draw actually i think
everything is okay now now that the king
has gotten out of that corner the bishop
is active white got everything he wanted
yeah queen f5 i don't know ideas of
queen d7 check
uh any queen trade will be an instant
draw
pretty much
pretty much king d1 also also fine yeah
just get the king over to see two and
claim that you know you're not we are
now we are now the side with the attack
yeah yeah
the initiative
your extra pond is firmly blockaded on
the fbi squares well
okay he's got a point
absolutely i mean yeah why not right why
why does wind like one and one out of
ten in these types of positions you just
kind of overpress and like the best way
to make it draw
is play for a win yes yeah i very much
endorse this
wow
uh
still i have the
echoes of uh
bent larson story where he told me he
was playing
uh in a scandinavian tournament where
his opponent went into one of these
bishops of opposite color and games upon
up
and ben nearly got a draw but ben
thought he was lost before his opponent
allowed this and he said
it was all
old grandmaster from sweden i forgot his
name for just a second and he said but
why did you allow me this chance and the
guy answered
young man don't you realize i never lose
such positions
i mean this is sort of the old school
right like right that's that famous
famous aphorism i
i will now misattribute it to
the the one of the pair of bandarevsky
first you find the draw yes and then
having secured the drawers right you
start looking for an advantage that's
right that was pal benko is that first
you secure the drop then you play for
your advantage
this this type of an approach
thank you
we will now make a draw yes yeah this is
awesome let's get the king over to e4
and
yeah yeah
you kind of want to play b3 and c4 just
to make sure that some kind of a weird
you don't blunt her yeah like if you if
your pawn gets fixated the fix is fixed
on beetsu and then you somehow blunder
bishop c1 at the wrong moment and you
lose
that would be suboptimal but
correct
but you still have time you don't have
to do it immediately
uh as we now expect this game to be
drawn let's just jump back to the duda
game for a moment because this is the
famous rook of bishop versus rook the
ball is still alive which in a way i
think hurts black because you're
maybe first of all your 50 move rule is
uh is not in yeah it's going to get
restarted and and secondly
uh i mean after rook h6 is not like what
i was trying to say is no longer
relevant but
there definitely are some positions in
which the the stronger side can just
ignore the pawn is there and try to give
made right uh anyway because the pawn is
very well controlled and
as a defender there
you get kind of slightly distracted by
this idea that maybe i can hold on for
it for a bit longer and do you think
it's practically better to just chuck it
yes yeah yeah i've seen people just play
h4h3 in this types of positions
definitely definitely so that your brain
kind of completely switches yeah yeah
and it's an entirely psychological thing
right you immediately are able to focus
into just defense instead of defense and
now you know what the pawn is also
yeah yeah i should hold on to my ex
no no let it die let it
yeah if it dies it dies so
because you mentioned the germans uh
the uh i had an adjournment i had the
the weaker side if you will against
israel
zilber in a hastings tournament
and
it was in a german
and i was staying at this like yelton
hotel
and the crazy part was the in the
hotel's library they actually had a book
with that position and i studied it all
night and i achieved what was the zen
position and it's spelt s-z-e-n
and he shows this way and after learning
thanks to the adjournment
i always got the maximum result in the
rook and bishop versus rook so you won
every single time with one every single
time with the with the better side
and every single time a draw with a
weaker side except i was won upped by
ikaru nakamura
he won with the weaker side
against magnus carlsen
that is impressive
magnus
flagged one of those tournaments in oslo
where you don't get increments
magnus was not a happy camper by the way
but hey them's the rules
absolutely yeah the pawn is still on the
board and uh yeah the let's the next
round is basically on hold now because
yeah exactly exactly as we witnessed
this game by the way fabi was he still
going
i'll be darn
there's wow as far as i can see there's
nothing to be playing for over here yeah
the point here is that this this
specific setup that fabi has established
with the king on d3 and bishop on g2 it
sets up superior sets up a perimeter
where he doesn't have to move anything
anymore exactly it covers all of the
potential entry squares from the black
king exactly uh so we just go bishop f3
forever right uh and uh yeah you can
even play king c2 if you want but you
don't have to uh and uh
yeah black can play b5 before but that
just limits them on the number of uh
remaining
amount of material that's right
and allows for
uh
even even more of the
i i don't dispute anything that uh he's
got his fortress the crazy part is he's
even achieved more than i thought he did
he could be good
the five before is a little bit tricky
exactly it's a little bit tricky uh
because i i think this is the only way
you can potentially lose if black plays
let's say before c takes before yeah you
do this right well you do you're not a
good gay you get in b3 check and with
the bishop specifically on g7 it's not
that easy to trade the pawn on b2 for
the pawn on a4 precisely in order to do
that you would need to play king b1 k2
and then we play bishop and once again
you are kind of stuck
and you can never play b3 yeah and in
the meantime the king
you know goes is going to attempt
attempts to get to e3
is i'm i'm interested in in in how
exactly how fabi is planning to draw
this because i think he should probably
not have allowed this
if
he had a chance yeah and this is why i
was talking about playing
i just don't know how he got in f5 and
g4 yeah i'm not sure i'm not sure why we
allowed the pawn to cross from f6 to f5
and exactly yeah i'm i'm coming here we
go
how easy overdraw is this i don't see it
at all i don't see it either i i mean
but the the only annoying thing for
wesley is that once you play the move
king d4 you're not hitting b2 that is
true
king d2 d2 i think
or you're saying b3 but we can maybe
cross so like i can play bishop d4 here
right and go c5 d6504 e3 well he's
played because he's 24. allowing king d2
but also allowing your b3
maybe
no b3 wasn't no b3 is not very good a3
b3 a3 bishop f8 and must win we must win
yeah that wins
and so he's had to
now here's the moment
is kingitsu withdrawal can you take c5
yes oh no no you're breaking into here
oh i think that's a huge mistake no no
no no it's not not not at all hold on i
i i i have to disagree just a second
bishop c1
bishop c6 bishop c6 no no you can't
allow
it
the bishop had to stay on the long
diagonal that was that is all oh
my goodness
king c5 can you see five we go king of
three bishop c1 we take and we go to
page three
and you're way faster and we get oh now
he's allowed bishop c6 yeah now now we
go bishop c6 no then he goes king c5
yeah this is a clever move
but
this is a clever move but i think we can
go
uh king f1
i know what you want you want your king
on you yeah no that's right you are you
are getting it i like your king f1 a lot
king c4 bishop c6 king b3
uh and then jazz and then
we're in time here
he's played king of three bishop of two
and i guess king g4 is the idea i don't
like it on g4 yeah bishop h3 is the way
to go and now we just go bishop d7 king
b3 king ji2 and it's only a very easy
draw yeah yes what we've just saw yeah
yeah this is this is the way to go yeah
just king jutu and we passed forever
i mean he made it hard on himself didn't
he oh yeah
i mean i have a feeling this was lost
for a second there yeah i asked the
engine i've always drawn
always
okay that's good because i hear what
you're saying right here when we saw the
move king d2 bishop h6 did feel like a
mistake but maybe king d4 yeah
the annoying thing if you can get to the
yasser's board in this position is that
despite the huge open
diagonal you can't cross to the kingdom
but this was my plan i wanted to go
bishop d4 here yes this was my this one
i i
yeah and at some point i go b4
ah that holds yeah okay be four
wow you probably probably do it the
other way
how about this one i mean you probably
want me to play king e5 king of four
even something like that yeah you get
you get yourself to be to f4 or
something and when the time is right i
go
and then i can force the train and then
you force the trade oh yeah okay wow
okay we're back to our sole remaining
game uh we've had a number of victories
three out of four
with duda trying to keep
trying to keep pace with these leaders
they
nobody's stopping
every game yeah winning every game it's
hard to keep track right
you forget this is actually round one of
the day
exactly
yeah so uh by the way the zen position
which is actually kind of funny we're
going to get to it if what if the rook
goes rook to e1
the king goes to e8 right yeah and
whenever you go with your king to break
the pin to the other side you go to i
was told it's a crane you know you're
all right well still this is a cochran
defense yeah you go to the opposite side
that i had yes exactly yeah the opposite
side and he's done it
yeah and this is
sort of weirdly more intuitive than the
second rank defense i thought this was
way easier than the second rank defense
i've seen people lose the sense the
second rank defense i feel people
blunder it all the time right and this
one i yes it's just easy go the other
way go the other way pin the bishop go
the other way that's all you need to
remember
it's much easier than the other one
and we're all about easily we're all
about the lazy grand master that's it
that's it yeah
yeah
eagles are all about efficiency correct
and 20 moves have been played so far of
the 50
uh
move rule and there goes the the second
ranked defense well well sorry that's
not quite yeah
this is the best version of the second
rank
you're right
yeah let's uh acquaint ourselves with
the numbers here the numbers are
uh
[Music]
picked up
on move 77
so we're we need to go 127 is the cutoff
127. 127 is a cut-off where currently i
moved from 96 so there's a way oh where
where far
ways to go yet and by the way i mean
carol mm-hmm
all
right very nice that's all very nice
walking into a discover check that does
nothing
yeah easier to calculate those when you
have nothing to lose
[Laughter]
with your own chains right
um
[Music]
time is not a factor peter
well it's very very much very much so
right you'll have 30 seconds per move
yeah it very much is but uh
no not 30 it's time no no no no no no no
no no no oh it's 10 gee it's 10.
no this is half a minute against half a
minute with not a very large increment
if at any point it becomes tricky it
becomes very tricky but so far
i understand the move i understand you
can't plunder something
but yeah i'm not pushing it don't put
things on lights
right i'm not playing no way
this is this is young people yeah yeah
i'm very very tempted to say i don't
blunder your fishes
sick yes eddie's has to move it to f
three and look look at this look at this
guy
now that was deserved that was the look
of disgust that was quite deserved like
yeah he's like he has a square he's
lucky he has a square yeah because like
he has a square actually yeah
[Music]
a quick feel okay just to make sure
look at the camera
like
i've discussed it with myself oh man it
would have been a funny way to end that
game yeah rugby 8 would have been would
have been quite something he's laughing
he's like yeah emily
was good that was good yeah but he
didn't release the piece so everything
is fine but yeah it was kind of a
and the dance continues and it's so it
is
all right
and he finally got
the move he wanted rickhead in
and now he's doing the second ranked
defense on the third rank
right yeah yes which doesn't work
because it's not a stalemate
also
[Laughter]
a little nervy there on that one yeah
because here you go bishop v6 i think
that's e6
yeah
but now you can go
all the way across the board right no we
didn't want to go all the way across the
board
rook h4 i think would have been my
choice in that exact
moment of course
for illegal yeah
i am okay i am glorious
i am glitching hard right now because i
wanted to say isn't rook j for me
for
was somehow attacking the king on f6 and
it has no squares i mean
there is like what is the name of the
piece the elephant yes elephant g4 would
be amazing
i am glitching glitching really really
hard right now oh my god this is not the
way you should start the day is this
actually right
good morning
saint louis but guess what guys only 18
moose
the point
that
uh
i
would play a number of quick checks here
in a row like
if i'm black
and then i just ask the arbiter you i'm
making a claim i mean you they have the
and they're going to say it's not right
they have the notation next to them
right yeah they have the board they have
the board very visible
as well that doesn't withstand unless
they know what the pre what you can look
up you can play h3o you can't just
scroll down
number on the screen no no but but when
you when when you are playing h4 h3 and
putting it in praise at this point you
look up and you memorize
mental and you make a mental note okay
that's fair i think i think that's the
way to do it of course you can't scroll
but you do you do have both the board
and the notation there in front of you
right here you go once again king g5
yeah king
i'm not sure how i feel about taking
this away from my voice
he did so many things for end games give
him something the cochrane-gambrit but
no i mean
that's fine that's fine
because you go rook g1 king h4 h5 and
then we have a familiar position right
and there we go h5 technique very good
and now whichever way you go if you go
king e4 you'll go king h6 if you go king
and e4
yes
15 15-ish moved moves to go from here
and he looks like he's he's getting
there quite safely but yeah
and by this point i think even if he
blunders into the philidor he doesn't
lose because there's just not enough not
enough time to uh yeah
by this point as long as he keeps some
kind of a track and honestly like if you
if you misplay it badly enough to feel
like maybe you're losing you do actually
stop the clock and ask right yes yes at
some point you have to even even if
you've lost track and you don't know how
many moves it is you you like the moment
it becomes dangerous you actually
like resort to
to asking the arbiter
rook a1 but yeah whatever does that
we go rook c5 here yes yes that's okay
and the kings go marching away from the
kingdom
yeah
this is also fine also fine it's also
funny yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i remember we were i wasn't a member of
the uh rules committee for the very
first gary kasparov
versus deep
deep
blue match where they were
what happens when we reach a table base
instantly the game is stopped and you
say whatever the result is because
gary's
point it was very very well made that uh
the computer has the table base yeah
playing against actual perfect play is
not much fun no
no it's not
again there you see the clocks 58
seconds versus
14 minutes
yes
with three seconds uh
plenty of time you played it with plenty
of time
i like the process in this game
right they're using that hole
i don't know what they're thinking about
in those ten seconds exactly
exactly
there you go
four seconds yeah we were there earlier
yeah he's gunking g4 in a previous spot
like this now again uh
i don't mind awarding my opponent the
two minutes
uh by making the claim and saying i have
a feeling he actually knows the number
yeah i mean i think i don't feel he's in
any danger i feel like those kind of
tricks you put out there when you fill
your position is in danger or something
here beautiful move yes this is then
the zen position because i i think king
h4 is already losing right probably
pronounced shen by the way i have a
feeling i'm i'm afraid you could be
right
one of those beautiful things that you
know like i've always enjoyed this i i'm
getting the zen of the position you know
really
[Laughter]
nice
i have a feeling
i've seen that yeah it's almost like a
scribe yeah it's always kind of like a
three-fold repetition but it's not you
know
the same idea that they've probably
reached the zen position a number of
times but from different angles of the
board
yeah and we are now like five moves away
so at some point yeah you you could
actually just legitimately leave your
work on free stop
no i mean you don't you don't blunder
your rook in ten moves
you blunder a row can you stop the clock
yeah that was that yeah that's sort of
one of the rare cases of you know bm
potential in chess yeah the end
potential yes yeah
being potential very important and we
are all about to be yeah and the yeah
says yeah let's let's not and i think no
i think the uh uh the arbiter
no you though i've been told the arbiter
can interfere after seven after seventy
five but i think they both saw it's one
two
so i think they looked up they realized
it's 127 and there
there will now be a small consultation i
understand there's going to be a 10
minute break between uh now and the next
round remember we've got three rounds of
rapid to go folks
as a very appreciative audience uh
applauding the players and i i want to
say nice to see young players
clearly be very very at home with this
end game because yes it's so he he made
it uncomfortable yeah he made it look
very he made it look like it was a rook
at night versus stroke yeah yeah
exactly very very very nicely done as we
go on break uh peter we've got a very
nice handsome
board there it is it's a tell all the
good people what they're they can afford
first i want to take a good look at it
myself it's a premium 20 20 inch window
roll up board featuring the official gct
logo as you can see there at the bottom
yeah it's a burgundy and cream uh
two and a quarter inch squares
uh perfect for your
traveling needs and uh
rolls up rolls up nicely and uh as for
with many other things we are promoting
here available at
cubitiquestl.com so go take a look
indeed and we'll take a short break and
we'll see on the other side of the brain
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay hello and welcome back to day three
of the warsaw super bit wrapping blitz
we are one round in to today's action
and it feels like two or perhaps three
yes that last round peter really did
take the wind out of our sails a bit as
uh our leaders however
are doing what they do yes uh
very much very much full full speed
ahead uh vicious continues winning and
rehearsal
14. very very very very hot stale yeah
and they've
separated themselves from the rest of
the field there's a five-point
difference guys fishing has a five-point
difference over wesley
that's an incredible performance the
fact that richard is just putting some
pressure on him is keeping this
tournament interesting and let's take a
look at the pairings uh after this very
lengthy round seven this
pairings for round eight peter they're
look very important don't they yeah
nicely so raffle right yeah but west
versus richie is very interesting and
yeah vishy vishy playing against fabi
who's been quiet so far but
i think so slightly you know playing
himself into some kind of form
and dude lavon just winning a game he's
on the outside looking in
and by the way this is our last day
let's remind any everybody who uh hasn't
been following this is our last day
of uh rapids where the games are worth
two points and then peter yeah as you
can see uh starting from tomorrow we we
get to watch people play blitz it's
going to be a lot of excitement yeah and
this is why we shouldn't really oversell
wishes lately i mean
it's a huge lead yeah but there's still
18 games 18 games to go start exactly
from tomorrow so there is still plenty
of time for people to catch up
uh we'll have in the blitz it's all
about the streaks too you know sometimes
the people go in
uh into the spin cycle or they get on
the hot
this is incredibly incredibly impressive
considering uh he hasn't really played
chess in a bit yes what was his last
tournament what's that
memorial in baku he said five months ago
five months sounds like takashima
memorial in baku yeah in december yeah
he he does a lot of a lot of work uh
now he does a lot of
very very good things for chess in india
works with youngsters yeah so he never
obviously never lost touch with with the
game he still works on chess very
diligently uh
we all know that but still when you take
such a long uh
layoff uh it's it's not
not easy normally yeah to come back and
and perform but seemingly for him we
just recharged him properly exactly he's
just blasting through the field so very
natural player and
not only all of his good work that he
does but he's also the author of one of
my very
most favorite quotes
uh vichy was asked by an indian
journalist
mr anand mr inaudible said the
journalist what does it feel like to be
world chess champion
and vishy said every day
i feel like an athlete
some days i feel like a scientist some
days i feel like an artist and some days
i feel like an idiot
but every day i feel like
an athlete i love missions
people people who i i've been you know
lucky enough to uh to have been around
vichy for a very very long time we play
for the same club in the bundesliga i've
worked visibly with vishy on a couple of
occasions and
people i think severely underestimate
how funny he is yeah yeah he is one of
the quickest quickest with surrounding
yeah people people don't see that side
very often i think he is quite buttoned
up during press conferences in general
but this is his opponent once again for
this round look at this wow 14 14 19.
this could be the tie breaker that's a
good one that's a fun match that is it
this has always been a good pairing for
me it's like a generational clash right
and you mentioned here in the sinkfill
cup an amazing game uh alejandro we were
calling i'm trying to remember the year
yeah maybe the audience can help us out
there it was fabi with the black pieces
i believe it was an english opening in
which fishy just
demolished fabiano caruana brilliant
sacrifices
and by the way we're talking about blitz
and none of us could understand why
vishy never won the world blitz
championship but we played in interzonal
in manila gosh it was maybe
i want to say early 90s
but
we were like on the same floor and we
just played a lot of blitz as a kind of
a training
for i mean in those days the databases
weren't you know great and so forth and
so on but you know we wanted to get in
shape
by playing a lot of blitz and
i was really upset
that somehow
vishy was even
out there
and i mean i didn't understand why this
young punk
from india who was giving me such a hard
time in our blitz sessions well i found
out as he qualified
from the end
and they're off into a petrov yeah an
old friend here an old friend
from abby fabi's world championship man
and it's remarkable that bishop f5 has
become the go-to
everybody used to play knight c6 and
bishop e7 bishop f5
it's the
and i'm told it's a sink field but which
year
27 yeah that sounds right i've been yeah
i've been uh
scrolling through the games they've
played and uh yeah there it is i guess
yeah it's a lot of games
by the way uh in the match-up key
match-up between wesley and richard
richard came to this event saying i'm
going to have fun
and he's not back down from the king's
indian
and he's gone also not for the
conventional oops excuse me not for the
conventional knight c6 but after
castle's knight a6 a movie
already he has also played this against
antoine garbo yes precisely
a little difference though because a
little twist with knight g4
and f5 now here
yeah they'll normally play uh
i think in this positions you would like
to play knight g5 the question is yeah
whether whether it's any good in this
particular setup when you feel like
you're underdeveloped yeah compared to
most of them right
and the knighton a6 is very useful here
to stop c4 c5 threats which sometimes
happen in these types of positions
yeah probably probably not 95 because
yeah i don't see the follow-up let's say
after 9-6 and at least not not any kind
of an immediate uh i'm
also
it's always kind of interesting to look
at these positions where sometimes this
follow-up here knight g5 uh i can
sometimes win the e4 square
i think the line gets
dropped back to f6 pretty much straight
away exactly exactly i'm kind of
thinking
of
my goodness i mean
it's so rare a bird these days the
king's indian it's like gary kasparov
played it and
nobody else uh really did at the very
highest levels uh it's considered too
risky but i i've seen so many of these
types of lines too that uh kind of get
all jumbled yeah we'll we'll uh give
wesley time to to consider a very kind
of a old friend
is on the board but this for me the line
that i've
wow
look how fast they go
so very heavily theoretical line of the
petrov obviously so not not such a
shocker
yeah
vishy one of the few
top top flight grand masters very
happily
parts were their bishops for the knights
he's
i mean everybody loves the two bishops
and everybody's very good at handling
the two bishops but she's pretty good
with the cavalry yeah i think you can
understand why in this particular
structure because the bishop of like
generally the dark square bishop here if
you're not doing what fabi or fabi was
doing against uh shahriar in their game
in bucharest where you try to win
force the trade of the bishop on e7 for
the knight on g5 and then perhaps if you
provoke g7 g6 as we've seen in that game
the dark square squares might become
weak but in general the dark square
bishop is the least important of the
white light pieces in this structure
and this dark square bishop on also not
the d6 doesn't do a lot it looks very
nice with the structure black has going
with the bonsai six and d5 it has a very
nice porch on d6 but uh
you you get some pressure you want to
play knight three knight of five i
suppose if black stops knight five by
playing g6 maybe it goes to g4
i kind of feel like i gotta start that
with h4h5 well
i kind of need a little space over there
if i could get you to play h6 now i'm
all over all excited you know let's put
my knight on f5
but
uh it's it's the fact that i have uh the
perfect control over the e file for the
moment
i put a knight on f5 peter it looks good
but then how do i leverage it once again
yeah i'm not sure if if i'm entirely
honest i get the feeling that maybe
vichy uh
for the first time in this tournament
she says okay is is saying i like my
tournament situation right so i'm okay
with a very very minuscule plus class
and if it leads to nothing it leads to
nothing i am playing against somebody
who i respect greatly i don't have to
win every single world in this thing
their record of 14 14 and 29 draws uh
speaks for itself you know yeah if he if
he were 100 maybe the idea of nine out
of nine would have been attractive but
he's already made one draw so yeah uh
you get the feeling that perhaps you
know he he he is playing this in the
spirit of you know
if if if he does something wrong and he
gets a sniff of course he will press but
exactly he doesn't he doesn't need to
uh
you know do anything uh outlandish here
again here i'd be kind of thumping the
table to get in
h4h5
uh one day yes i'm going to need c3 but
like peter saying it's it really has a
lot it comes down to
can i
leverage the control of
f5 into something
or not that's basically it let me take a
look around the horn for a quick a sec
because the game between levon and duda
is one of those games
that while maybe the the position itself
isn't that interesting it's the outcome
the result yeah it's a very very
relevant game for the tournament very
much so yeah and and looks like a game
between two beginners
[Laughter]
i'm so glad you said that peter i mean
i think we all caught it
nobody wanted to say it
and i i mean it in the nicest possible
way
you do get positions like this when you
just learn how to play chess scholastics
yeah you develop knights to the most
obvious natural squares you play bishop
c4 it gets traded on b3 because
you don't prevent knight a5 because you
were told to prevent light a5
and black on the other hand did not play
h6 so now there is the spin on the
knight on f6 but this has become a lot
more like people are doing a lot more of
these things these days it used to be
uh it used to be considered to be
completely safe for black and if the
bishop wasn't on before i think if the
bishop is on some kind of a better
square where in particular if it's
already on a7 uh stylistically i would
actually prefer black i don't think it's
correct i think white is completely fine
of course and there are some lines like
this where white actually tries to claim
they have some kind of a bubble
yeah
but i'm picking i'm picking black there
every day of the week but with the
bishop on before which still needs to
somehow return to big squares okay so
let me challenge you just for a moment
though peter
uh
your turn is black are you playing g5
yes no
probably yeah of course you know what
i'm asking we can prepare it for one
more move yeah but that's weird for one
moment you don't
i mean even with something
it's unnecessary even when i know that
this is good for me as black i still
don't like playing against these and
these kinds of things and instead of h3
by the way uh levon played king h1 which
is
uh he is one of the uh
you know i'm very used to him doing this
on on the black side of all kinds of
spanish structures
but he is
sort of the spiritual
leader of the movement of king h89 g8
and spanish exactly and he's sort of
doing the same thing here i'm pretty
sure the intention is actually to play
either knight g1 or h3 knights h2 okay
rookie 8 he replied to with h3 beautiful
thing about that movement of levon is
entirely based on the dark squared
bishop that's on the a7 attacking f2 and
he traded it off here
he does it with the bishop only seven as
well he does it okay in all kinds of
anti-marshals and no he
he is very very much about about just
freeing up the f-pawn and
pushing it forward but i feel your eggs
where's my bishop every time i look at
this like where's white's bishop where
did he go what happened to it the bishop
is not pinning the f2 pawn you don't
have to preface your look at this he's
done h2h3 as well you mentioned yourself
uh peter that you don't have to play h6
right away you you could play a move
like rookie h no i meant if if we want
to play h6 g5 we play h6
and then i mean rook 8 is already
slightly off topic but i want to say if
you play king h7 king h7 actually
prepares g5 because you you give
yourself access to rook g8 g6
immediately
ah prior to playing g5 so once the
sacrifice happens we immediately go rg8
attacking the so just to put that in
perspective
i understand that it's not our pieces
but we're ready to sacrifice them right
what does happen if i just go g5 i think
that you you take twice
i wanted to go king h7 but i wasn't sure
f4 f4
yeah you can definitely play like this
but i mean game sort of continues right
we play
i understand but i have two bishops
um i mean if three we need one maybe
yeah the game continues it's just a
weird weird position i i just didn't
know how to evaluate it
quincy two is wealth creating a threat
of five yeah but queenie i like i like
queenie one yeah queenie won maybe yes
well i wasn't i just wanted to i wanted
to take the pawn but would you think
some kind of soul is that wrong
this first game really killed us right
this first round the last round was so
long destroy the commentators today oh
my god
i was going to take the pawn guys
oh come on
that has become a meme here on set uh
for those of you who were watching the
bucharest uh coverage you'll know
exactly what we were talking about shaq
mamidarov had some marvelous marvelous
so those were there was a stunning press
conferences just killed interviews
because he had these positions that were
just mind-boggling
and it appeared that he was winning you
just visually i'm winning against duda
the kings in the middle i've got all of
these wins
and he was very dissatisfied that he
made it the quote actually came
when he thought he was completely fine
throughout and that was explained to him
that he was getting made in three moves
and he was like come on come on
everything he was saying was essentially
wrong yeah
and man that was bobby oh come on that
was really really that was beautiful uh
what do we have this is what i wanted to
talk about yeah this is this is the line
of the night or which i used to play a
ton uh with white specifically the two
with king hvac it should be too with
king h1
passage it's a useful thing yeah exactly
it's a use it's the dumbest thing
you need to pass it's a useful passing
move because black isn't zug's one cause
you can't play b5
because you can you can but you need to
know a lot and after a4 surprisingly
this doesn't hold up so well for
this doesn't equalize as easily as you
would like as you would like yeah
okay and an additional point of king h1
i can talk here i can i can
talk about this position quite a bit
like if you go i see
we don't want to cost you your chessable
no
audience yeah that has been known for so
many years already yeah my six we go
four and also after b6 we go four and
compared to
uh compared to the position uh like you
can play a four without king h1 of
course but there is some kind of a
difference here and importantly like
maybe the most the major importance is
this yeah if you play queen c7 here king
h1 is hugely beneficial for us because
we instantly go f5 and g4
and we very much like the idea that the
g-file that the g-file is open for our
rook if we need it if we need it later
and the king is away from checks
so this is like the biggest payoff you
can get i think from king h1 and nobody
really allows this this is a little bit
too risky uh but yeah plenty of moves
here 96 being i i always thought it was
probably the
the most direct response i understand
why queen e1 you liked uh lavon to play
queenie one i think
you've got a history i stopped playing
this line with white when they
discovered that even b5 equalized like
when they were supposed to because b5
was supposed to be the bad move and yeah
king h1 king h1 but they even equalized
that and at that point i was like i'm
done with this variation yeah
man even when they fall for you
that's what that's what it's bad right
when they fall for your tricks and you
still get nothing why did you play this
line at all like yeah yeah but this
looks perfectly fine for black honestly
we go rook c8 for k8 i think yeah you
know if i have to pick i'm picking up
i'm wondering if black can be better
i think there's a yeah there is a
weakness
i didn't like queenie one yeah as you
were saying as well
i thought that was your
go-to weapon no
i'm not sure what are the structures
yeah i think maybe 95 actually i kind of
liked what you mentioned a moment ago is
it i'm reluctant to play five here but
maybe actually like my memory of what
you're supposed to do with black in this
positions actually says that after
bishop three knight a5 is or at least
you know when i last studied this which
was 25 years ago or whatever
knight a5 was supposedly the move to
make in this position immediately trying
for some counterplay because we're not
sure we won the bishop on b7 in many of
these positions it's fine on e6 right
for the king's side yeah so so going
knight day 5 and asking the question is
good maybe a 405 is playable i just
really really don't like queenie one
specifically because of knight g4 i
think it's a very good reaction rookie a
rookie bishop of fate it's probably
actually more urgent to play rookie
buffet than it is to play rook c8
um because the pawn on e4 needs to be
challenged i'm not happy here with white
i mean
i've got two two pawns on the fourth
rank that's just about it everything
else seems to be more or less fish or
random
you know like a little bit i mean you
know like you put the bishop on i don't
know b1 and wouldn't you say yeah that
came from official random
yeah
i mean uh
i don't know
it's very ugly yeah we're looking for
equality here i'm not sure where it is
exactly exactly well we'll keep an eye
on that one again we'll just uh quickly
check in on the wesley this is a very
very sharp king's indian though uh
we left it
f5 a3 i like it three okay
f4
and yeah richie immediately commits to
uh the sharpest possible continuation i
very much liked dcbc before because
having played the fourth i think richie
was very happy to play 65 next movie if
it was allowed so yeah and to close
things to close things down and now uh
it very much resembles positions uh you
know like this would be my king's indian
position when i played the king's indian
like i didn't really play knight a6 very
much but generally these types of
structures were
sort of the dream and i still think
black hasn't equalized i feel it's not i
think it's i think queen a4 you kind of
like start
i mean i don't think g5 g4 is
ever
fast enough compared to compared to what
white is doing yeah i
yeah q4 is on the board it's a very
annoying move to face because if you
play if you play bishop d7 you get hit
by queen a5 maybe even immediately
uh and then rook fd1 c4 c5 will become a
threat and you
you would like to start your
quote-unquote mating attack on the
king's side but what you're actually
doing here is burying threats every move
and uh and yeah how happy are you about
all these things and you never really go
very far because after something like
this
um
tables could get turned let's just put
it like that you have to start throwing
things and
we'll keep an eye on this because it's
such an important game for our
tournament leaders i just wanted to get
to vichy's game
uh
well we talked about the f5 square five
is completely fine yeah it's completely
not really fine
great game nice patch of open e file
what else do we have i think that's
about it i'm not even sure this whole
night escapade
93 again i i was uh going for the whole
h4 h5 trying to get some sense
of uh squares um
yeah no nothing to talk nothing to talk
about here
again i'm just going to check in this is
this one we have to talk about yeah this
got very sharp what happened
the typical idea we saw that in wesley
against fabio right one side gets d5 in
but the other side gets d4 in and now
you have this counter in the center
everything's hanging and you have to
calculate it at all a lot because
context d4 i can take with the queen i
cannot think of the queen because rookie
four i can take either one of the
knights i can play e5 i can take on d5
what's going on here peter
uh
well the youngsters have clearly feels
that the pollen f6 will get picked up 24
rookie four is very strong here i think
he is right windy for rook even rookie
four protects the bishop on b4 and also
kicks the queen away from the g4 square
meaning that the opponent of six fights
i was dreaming i was dreaming i i i had
a dream that my queen would one day land
on h4
and i'd be a very happy camper so far it
feels to me that young christopher is
correct and here's a variation of this
position because if you take on default
with the knight
of that one now any fd4 maybe yeah
that's probably the way to go yeah well
then but no i wanted to be able to play
e4 e5 alejandro well then do it that way
go e5 first
okay
g4 g g5 g5 sorry yeah you need to have
g4 now yeah no
or even or move the bishop back and what
the engine really likes to do is move
the bishop back to g3 okay knight e4 and
now you go knight f takes d4 not knight
e dxd4 knight f takes d4 so you have to
move f4 to throw in and this just about
works out for white
black has lifted his kimono there on the
king side uh pawn shields forward
should get punished
i mean you have the bishops you have a
pretty
i mean the thing that actually hurts
black a tremendous amount here is the
fact that he had to spend well in
headers or maybe a strong word did spend
the tempo on b7 b5 i'm guessing to
prepare bishop before c5 so that he
didn't have to worry like if we should
show the viewers how we got here yeah
yeah it was way back here
h3 do the play b5 here i'm assuming with
the intention of playing bishop c5 so
that he doesn't have to worry about
knight a4 because the bishop on before
needs to be brought back into the fold
somehow and the immediate as your
mention yeah you have to at least think
about that before it's annoying
but now after white gets white gets this
very very important tempo because
whenever you recapture on d4 with a
knight in the current position
uh whenever the white knight lands on
on default black has to spend the tempo
thinking how to protect c6 exactly and
and that tempo is that's the uh downside
of people
yeah and and that the tempo probably is
quite quite important in positions like
this because it's a very very
situation he did not after takes and
and of course of great importance to
these two players
as their gct standing and you've got to
pick one of the rapid blitz events to go
along everybody on tour has to play in
the two classical events you get one of
these and look at uh how tight it is
yeah it is
we've only had one event but yeah rihard
as we've spoken about earlier has had a
bit of a nightmare in bucharest but uh
all the rest of the full tour
participants had a decent event fabi uh
ended up
tied for fourth and both wesley and one
uh were in that die at the very top of
the
uh
leaderboard
um
intriguing no e5
just immediately uh taking the pawn yeah
once again 96 is a big threat huge you
do
sort of deprive yourself of immediately
45 next move but there is no
particularly comfortable way of
protecting c6 that you kind of instantly
like because if you play bishop g7 you i
don't like the the going into this
isolator exactly you get yourself this
structure which you a little bit ugly
move i'm not 26 i was wondering if i can
play e5 i think e5 just yeah something
right oh no i don't know if it wins
anything but because i have queen e4
queen five queenie two right but yeah
but the resulting position i think is
much better for white they go nice with
six and nine taking 96 queenie two
nights simply that takes before then
agreed
and this is gonna end in a nice
repetition as
fishy has sacrificed
a piece i think the perpetual
rook currently yeah sorry yeah it's
gonna it's gonna end the draw in a
moment
well for uh vichy it's
it's been a wonderful
tournament and he uh
says i want to go into the blitz portion
of the event with a comfortable lead
everybody forgive me for
uh shutting this game down yeah he
played us very safe he uh i'm sure if
fabi
would have done something something
wrong in the opening the game would have
continued but i think he had sort of one
eye on these types of outcomes right
and yeah f6 knight takes g6 there is a
very nice kind of a wink-wink nudge kind
of a sequence because you're not obliged
to play f6 here no you can go knight g7
and the game will also be completely
equal but there is no immediate draw
exactly and if you play f6 you you are
kind of saying yeah there is what you
like there is this combo which ends the
game on the spot would you like a draw
sir exactly yeah we'll ask our producers
what what are some of those great grand
tpr performances and i agree with you
that uh fabi's 7-0 win streak certainly
one of the best karpov's lunares uh we
mentioned uh already uh
in 2005 obviously the uh
he it was slightly you know it went it
went down in the second half
louise yeah he scored like six and a
half out of seven he started
seven candidates that wasn't bad that
was really good though yeah but the
going then he drew everything
but let's uh jump across uh the atlantic
to warsaw
thank you yasser actually i just want to
give you a funny story about the richie
report i was having dinner with him
actually last night and we were
discussing about his selection of
openings for this event and i was saying
look i'm very impressed about the way
you're handling the opening because
you're always up on time you're always
surprising your opponent and what he was
saying is that well this openings that
he's playing in this tournament they
usually don't work for classical chess
he had this repertoire back when he was
like 12 13 14 and he told me that he has
a lot of these type of weapons so this
is exactly why we're seeing richie
reports surprising most of his opponents
in the opening let's uh remember the
first game from today he played e4
c5 knight to f3 d6 and now he played the
move that i actually haven't seen
maybe ever bishop to d3 followed by c3
and then bishop to b5 some complete
nonsense of course now tell us a bit
about this game anastasia because you
were analyzing with some people in the
skittles room yes we we are spending
time sometimes during the games we're
talking with guests like now natalia and
alexander onychuk and dalina
kashlinskaya were in the
in this room for the players and we
discussed uh this position a little bit
and they said that i like somehow
white's position and girls immediately
replied but black has such a nice plan
with g5 h5 g4 you know and probably
richie
will try to give a checkmate to wesley
and but then alexander o'neil said i
know that in these positions this
checkmate is not working this attack is
not working you know i don't want really
to break all your hopes girls but i
don't think it's it's going to be
working and then rich immediately played
rook d8 you know like leaving those
hopes for the attack on the king's side
so it was interesting discussion and in
general actually all players when they
come back to this room they keep talking
about the games and it's really nice to
hear them talking about that if you want
actually to see more information about
it you can always go to the official
accounts of grand chester in in
instagram we are publishing the stories
and you can follow them as well and
another uh quite interesting story is
about this game between chefchenko and
gabriele well this is a big one for the
standings but also a battle of
domination between the two youngest and
most fresh competitors in this event
gary lesko and chef chenko and this one
well it's quite an interesting affair
because
chefchenko started off with this king's
indian attack uh i think richie rapport
actually essayed this against gaffrey
lesk who surprised him got a winning
position and actually went on to win
quite an easy game but in this one gary
lesko came much better prepared also he
played much faster and right now we see
he has 19 minutes on his clock against
10 minutes for chefchenko and the game
is heating up because at some point
we're going to see some sort of a
sacrifice coming on h6 a lot of very
exciting games guys back to you in the
studio
thank you anastasia and thank you
christian indeed i always like
these events where you know you really
do have a heavy heavyweights
and these two players are snuck in as
wild cards and they get to
sharpen their blades you know in this
great competitions and then they
suddenly face each other peter
they look across the board and they say
you're not vishy or not
you know
you're not magnus carlson you're my
target
oh no no no you're my target
and uh they've got quite the donny brook
uh going uh between them themselves as
well here as and uh christian it's
interesting to to hear the the opinions
of uh the people's of onsite about the
very very sharp kings indian that's the
richer game yeah they're being played
between wesley and richard and like we
were saying that it never like the black
attack never materializes and why it is
clearly much better and
things may have changed i'm not sure
richard has done this in the most
optimal way possible but while we were
listening to uh to our friends from
warsaw i briefly checked what the the
onboard engine is saying okay and uh the
engines really thought richard was much
much better
wow and
specifically in the position you have on
your board right now the engines were
throwing in g4
which probably is more precise instead
of for knight g4 here i think if you
include g4
you play 94 here okay the engines were
saying this is very very strong i'm
taking two and now we go knight b3 and
the difference between this position and
the position that they got in the game i
assume is that wesley will be able to
establish a lot of
control over the light square
white squares even though white in the
game as if we returned to what they have
on the board richie played 94 straight
away without including g4 so
very quickly
on the board wesley very quickly took on
h5 and played blade queen a6 please take
my rook it's going to be much harder for
uh for richard here to open the king
side because the g-file probably never
really gets opened anymore
in fact he played after
knight b3 queen a6 rook b8
that puts a strong threat on the board
yeah we'll be 666 is a bit of a threat
yes
uh do we i think we can
play c5 bishop 7 doesn't stop rugby six
right i understand uh i was going to
sacrifice my queen in a well sacrifice
is a strong word yeah like here
kind of in a funky way yeah i don't
think this works because we don't have
enough attackers i will just take on a6
take on before
you only have two pieces for for the
queen and i don't think you have a
mating attack because you're just not
quite
i don't have yeah i've got some nice
it's like you're missing a queen
[Laughter]
the insights i mean you
he gets paid good money at the st louis
university to teach us
students
very nice um okay c5 i agree uh give c5
give me some room yeah but now i guess
we start picking up material if we take
on g2
let's say i take yeah we take on
c5 c5 probably uh okay here i pause for
just a second because i do
have
there's a number of options but i am
planning to play bishop e6 next what
what he played rugby too wow so he's
just giving up that queen yeah he's just
saying yes i don't have a choice the
queen needs to be parted parted with you
know okay rook b2 first of all he's got
a pawn
on the king side and as you said some
good light squares
now he's got a rook and a knight so
materially speaking
even stevens it's not that bad actually
oh particularly which b6b speed too
simply and then right
we try to play before b5 i assume try to
establish some kind of control over the
g5 square the king side is very safe if
we need to we will play after f3 later
put the knight on g4
but for the moment it's that the knight
on f7 the bishop on g7 they're a little
hobbled it's not what you call very
active yeah
in terms of purely purely in terms of
material we're not really behind yeah no
we're not i was i was thinking about
that before the producer ruined all my
fun but can i take on b4
yeah now so it's probably a better move
it's actually a good move right because
rook b6 is threatening again yes i don't
know when knight c5 is a threat yeah so
i assume bishop seven we go back to the
idea of i think bishop website you just
take one f7
oh you give it you give away decent this
is not giving away rugby six will
continue being a threat
thank
i think it's pretty good even here yeah
okay but queen f7 first yeah we the
issue here is as alejandro correctly
points out is that the threat of root b6
doesn't really go away that is true and
we can cash it in pretty much at any
point and i think when i take on c4 it's
just a hugely different thing
yeah he's actually gone c5 shedding both
b4 and the c pawn
knight takes c5 on the board queen e2 on
the board clearly things have gone wrong
for white probably you have some
compensation because d6 is weak bishop
f7 is a thread rook takes of course b4
is a threat but is it enough
and by the way
i mean
you know vishy is still on the show
there's no question about that but but
if bishi hadn't stole the show yeah we
heard this
richard
doing a darn good job he's uh
five five
five and oh uh or five wins in a row i
should have said if he wins this one
yeah
wasn't what you know what i wanted yeah
i wanted the big
the i i could play a5 if i was a good
move just climb down on that side start
preparing for moves like rook b8 play it
slow i won
96 94 i really want to get my knight
like i'm jumping up and down all of
these are good ideas but the work is
hanging you don't want to develop white
species start with the move a5 yeah i
mean the issue the issue with making a
move like a5 is that you are giving up
the pawn on d6 right bishop several v6
actually wins that pawn you have to
assess it correctly you have to convince
yourself that your extra pawn is not as
important as perhaps getting rid of that
black square light square and bishop
it's not immediately obvious no i mean i
understand why it's good if you like now
that i've been told it's good i can
i can explain why i assume it's actually
rook d4 in the end there like a5 bishop
f7 queen f7 rogue d6 and we get we get
hit by ritchie a5 on the board wow look
before g4
he's been playing some real boss chess
yeah yeah absolutely in this uh and
their head matchups not that much
not that many games i wanted to say i
don't remember that win
six five draws one win for wesley so
wesley still has the upper hand in rapid
chess
a5 not not in the current game yeah this
this has been going quite well for for
rickard yeah and
if bishop f7 is not great then you have
to make some kind of a quietish move
perhaps knight f3
uh to keep you know some control over
the d4 square reestablish the idea of
taking on f7 and either gs g5 or d6
but black has ways of of stabilizing
here bishop d7 and cx for instance
protects many things
i just like in general you would like
your knight there mm-hmm you you would
prefer to play knight e6 of course but
yeah but bishop b6 followed by perhaps
bishop f6 king g7 just solidify
everything i mean i feel that wesley is
worse full stop but worse than being
upon down as well
kind of makes me think that okay uh i
should take while the getting is good
i think what kind of wins you know rook
d4 just kind of wins
we got that's the issue yeah i think
this is good
knight b3
b3 is kind of strong yeah and mb3 just
attacks too many things
wow that's a lot of units hanging yes
yeah
there's just no defense to rook default
rook d4 before that clear
it's a lot it's a lot stronger than it
than it looks yeah it looks strong at
first and then yeah
the impact is kind of like yeah asteroid
like wow okay uh oops
i'm not doing that then i guess i'm
going night and wester is also if i
understand that's not right let's take
apartments and throw it over to
alejandro and we do have bishop g6 by
the way alejandro sorry to interrupt but
i kind of
kind of like that oops no a5 bishop g6
sorry it does have a threat peter
well
h6 still exists so king g8 even to be
honest i'm not sure what the threat is
well
i would then i mean if you let me play a
move i don't know play a move i'll i'll
go over here and
see what i can uh drum up right
i mean i'm kind of looking for tricks
yeah no they are yeah
i like the move because it introduces
like a new a new dimension to the
position why did not really have much in
the way of counterplay if the queen
lands on h5 it's always slightly
uncomfortable to allow and it can't
really be comfortably stopped so you you
the question is how you react to it you
can't really stop it all together but
let's stop ourselves and turn it over to
alejandro jump right in what's going
over there uh alejandro it's a fun game
so let's update it it's not the most
relevant for the standings between
korabov and voytashik but it's still a
good one this neither doesn't look too
much like a knight anymore but a little
bit uh now it's clearly in black's
control black has the good queen the
structure is not very good yes you have
an isolated pawn but look at white's
development just almost non-existent the
bishop coming to c5 i'm hitting your
queen no surprise this is a winning
position for black queen d2 was played
and then the threats keep kept piling on
bishop c5 king went to h1 and very
clever bishop c5 and then bishop d6 now
attacking the putter on f4 korvo decided
to defend it with the knight on d3
didn't want to weaken himself with the
move g3
but was hit with this beautiful move
yowza knight g5 can't take on g5 because
queen h2 is checkmate because of the
action of the queen and the point is
that you could either take on e4 or
knight e4 both of them are huge threats
in this position black's pieces keep
piling up on the board this queen
doesn't have a good square to go to but
this bishop on c1 is not participating
and while it's not participating i'm
gonna bring everybody on the e-file and
just win the game with my pair of
bishops and extra activity the moment
this bishop gets released onto the g2
pawn which is not too far away from now
it's just going to watch is going to die
and this is i think is going to happen
to korboff's position currently down to
six minutes against voyatashex14 i think
this is radic's game yeah it looks
really really nice for black there he's
i love that move knight
so that's a visual i want to go to the
junior matchup because this is like you
know this is where
they really take a measure of one
another and here we have a king's indian
attack
uh pawns on h5 and in a previous game
it's almost like you wanted to play g4
g5 these sacrifices we discussed them on
that broadcast peter and you're just
said i'm shutting it down my queen will
this is the setup we were discussing
even during the uh rapper
game that uh bish buffet 2897 uh
basically put spade to the classical
sacrificial attacks you uh you try to
generate
on the king's side so yeah richard
eventually uh broke through by removing
that from g4 and going g4 g5 right and
you might have to do here this is here
as well
but black is much much further that uh
progressed on the queen side yes you
play bishop c6 you play three rupees too
and at this point white is so distracted
by uh what is happening on the queen
side that you your mating attack kind of
gets puts put on hold is white kind of
all in here peter
i mean at some point can you pull back
and say okay i i i'm not correct well
the queen side the queen side hasn't
been ruined it's just that black has has
the initiative there i don't think
you're entirely all in but yeah
obviously a lot of energy has been
expelled on the king's side trying to
generate a threat exactly and this setup
has has been at some point figured out i
think maybe in the last 10 years i think
some games of linear dominguez in
particular i remember
the the king's indian attack became kind
of popular
around
maybe the turn of the 2010s though
and and then it started getting played
at the higher levels
and then i saw a number again
specifically by linear who i think had
it figured out he was
probably not the first one to to to
establish the setup but he
in game of the game very clearly
demonstrated just how solid this is how
difficult it is to create a single
thread for white in these types of
positions
and uh yeah i remember i was very
impressed by specifically linear's
treatment of this with the black pieces
good to know as we can use lanier as a
guide for defending these kings indian
attacks uh that would be terrible news
uh for the lazy man's guide to how to
play against a french sicilian you know
yeah if the king's indian attack isn't
bringing us goods the results oh dear oh
dear okay we'll keep an eye on that
and uh let's jump back to the game of
wesley so uh because again that's
such an important game for our standings
bishop g6 okay the queen's coming to h5
and you're not stopping it
so he went knight h6 and prep
preparation for queen h5 the queen h
five showed up on the doorstep okay
knight b3 let me see stopping room bg2
mainly i think and also perhaps it might
still go to d4 but it's another way of
getting there and by the way don't
forget
night comes with and i think she won as
a threat yeah and rook dropped back
so wesley has sort of stabilized on the
queen side and i guess he wants to play
knight g4 get rid of the oh neither
thing that takes g5 is maybe also a very
strong threat he wants to play mission
bay 3.
that's a good move and he's done it very
quickly yeah
knight d4 i thought was great
not only is it visually very attractive
for for black but it also does
slam the brakes on knight
f3
rook
c4 control has been
somewhat lost here by by rick hardy i
suspect he is still doing quite quite
okay but actually no
i i took a brief glance at
uh
at the at the machine at the machine and
then the machine is remorseful and the
machine says control has been lost
entirely and uh actually likes why it's
positioned here despite being wow
despite being upon down and i mean black
and player takes a4 here and there's no
immediate refutation that i can see but
simply that the queen and h5 is just
extremely annoying
i'm assuming it's it's going to be based
on some yeah
like you can you're welcome to snack on
the bishop i'm not sure how much you can
this still doesn't generate i think
enough of a threat i'm i i suspect you
probably did he snack on him he's
knacked on it
like hey i don't have to ask me twice
okay sorry uh peter yeah i'm guessing
you probably make one more move in
preparation somehow and then you you do
have to go in
okay let's just uh let's not take away
our pieces or at least not give away all
of our pieces
here at least i can see that i ca i am
sorry threatening
bishop takes d4 because then i don't
know mother three continues being the
main thing that works that's what we're
all about yeah yeah of course
that's what we're all about yeah these
are these are very difficult to navigate
for black uh i just want to briefly take
a look at the clocks richard steele is
in sort of in control on the clock he
has 11 against seven and
a half but just as you're saying if i
can induce you to play a move like c5
which isn't a bad move
now you start to see that there are some
seriousness obviously
the entire inside is gone but if we if
we actually
launch a very serious attack on the king
side it might not matter
and uh rook takes a it's uh anastasia
was invited to uh
it was looking at the game of richard
and he was explaining to us like all the
women's grandmasters were like okay
black's gonna check nate white
and the old
veteran alex only shook no ladies sorry
to disappoint you yeah and isn't it
ironic that it's white who's going
knight takes deep fortnite after knight
takes g5 it all started with that very
very clever move bishop g6 and i wonder
what the proper response to it was
because i think at that time the uh the
position must have been quite good for
black but
without really committing any kind of
obvious griev grievous errors against
against uh bishop's logic
and he's done the bishop b2 variation
he's
wesley is just hoping
that c5 is a lot will allow knight f3
sorry i don't think i'll get to the
bottom of this but rook d3 was
almost borderline winning according to
the engine instead of knight takes
defense knight d4 pawn takes and then
defend the bishop with rook d3 keep the
b file keep the b file open keep rook b7
on i think it's specifically rugby i
think maybe it is specifically rook b7
wow he really hates the move bishop b2
wow
the rook landing on b7 peter that's what
it was all about
i mean
i mean bishop b2 is such a natural move
i i'm not gonna it's it's both i think
bishop bishop looks very natural also
rook g3 looks like you're putting yet
more pieces on very precarious positions
but like black can play c5 c4 and like
wherever you put it next right rook g3
rook d3 is really not a particularly
intuitive move to make we should do a
lot a lot more
uh recognizable as something exactly
that shouldn't be okay but yeah
apparently disagrees violently with this
assessment well the machines are so good
in the tactics but like you're saying
rook d3 seems to invite c5 c4 and if you
lose the game
you know in it like just in a horrible
fashion to c5 c4 and people come up to
you how could you have played rook t
today
where were you what was that
why are all your pieces on pre yeah yeah
i mean why didn't you play bishop b2
like a normal person and threaten to
play bishop takes d4 and win backstab
yeah
and a
very very
critical decision
now for
richard well you have to play c5 you
can't you can't draw okay
what's what's the follow-up after knight
f3 i haven't checked with an engine but
i'm not really sure what the generation
of threats is like if i just save my
pawn and go g can i go g4 yes i can
right g4
g5 i'm threatening knight
g8 i guess maybe
[Music]
uh bishop c1 in order to play rook b7
and also f4 is hanging out
i didn't want to tell you about that i
just wanted you to focus on rupees
uh
yeah there's still issues i mean
like in a blitz game you just take white
here without the second thought because
right it's just so many threats that
you've got to deal with but i assume
something like rook before bishop before
rook f8 might be might be okay i think
the bigger issue here is that the b file
the b file is going to be i don't think
why you're doing you can take on a 4
without actually oh without oh sorry
giving me connected passers i i also
originally thought before was
necessary but it's not okay and yeah i
think we maybe we covered our king side
here and the queen side with the rook on
before is just going to be completely
safe for the rest of the game but still
yeah it's now pretty close to material
equality and we're going right into the
yes and perhaps our big mistake was to
actually put the king on g8
go for go rook fade since you're going
to go yeah we yeah that makes a lot of
sense yeah g4 and g5
the moment i i started to make the
threat of
rook of fate and then rook before next
move and then we will start and he's
done it yeah played
and yeah
you get the feeling he he he will not
waste the tampon king g8 agreed
and uh currently we are two down with
white the b file will get
comprehensively close with through
before and my point there if let's say
if you go bishop c1 will before bishop
a3 i have a feeling we just never move
it
i have a feeling we're quite happy
allowing bishop takes before there
really like players play three yeah i
just couldn't queen e5 or something
i just want to i just want to play
something like maybe g h g h q a for
queen e5 from the tigran patrol yeah
i'm just leaving it on before nothing
like three connected past pawns peter
that's true happiness right
there yeah
yeah that's giving you the real zen of
the position okay uh let's just take a
quick uh walk around the horn i want to
check in on the anton game that was a
game we thought that white was
toast yes yeah still still toast
still toast less toasty but still less
tasty okay but yeah that's yeah that's a
lot of extra points from
yeah yeah and you assume this is
convertible you go
rg5h5 or something yeah and you start h6
yeah you start walking the king towards
the bishop that happens to land on your
doorstep
uh bishop c3 but yet this is too many
two pawns too many yeah um the church
between h6 and h5 i think very much
depends on whether you believe you will
win the end game after rookie five
but i think you will so i think you
don't have to prevent rookie five here i
mean prevent the rook trade after i
understand uh h6 was one of those yeah
and i don't have to think about it yeah
yeah yeah i think it's like
culturally so to speak a better move
than than h5 but i think surely yeah
yeah it's funny i wouldn't bring myself
to play h5 yeah i just kind of allow
that rook train it's not about the rook
trade it's that i feel that at some
point i'm going to get blockaded on the
dark squares and i'm going to be
wondering why did i put everything on
the dark screw on the lights i think
it's unnecessary put your pawns on dark
squares and roll them that way and then
it's sort of like yeah if my pawn were
on h6 i wouldn't have been forced to
play g
for whatever okay uh politically
is it was it a good move politically
culturally yes politically um
jury's out age sexism uh the junior play
uh by the way uh
i mean the juniors are are following uh
the games that the
g5 move the knight play for g5
and this is really quite the donny brook
uh who's going to land
on the queen side first or the king side
well uh
without looking at black's moves what
were like white's last few moves uh
knight g4 h2 and then g3 g4 g5 so he's
all in oh yeah yeah he needs to be he
absolutely needs to be he's absolutely
he's played he's played g5 and uh
sort of the
xe4 might be strong but you could also
maybe not even waste tempe on the scale
because i have a rook take c4 here what
rook c4 rook c4 works here ah
this was this was sort of the entirety
of my board
yeah
i i thought i was recapturing with the
tempo good morning saint louis yeah that
was my excuse
but you you might have stronger options
but yeah d64 is a very understandable
move which he also played uh quite
quickly
uh two minutes against five here and
again this is the junior game between
kira and gh i think we i think we ignore
even though it's it's not that easy to
and like i think she takes d3 is strong
enough for us to be
uh okay with allowing hg7 in general i
of course this is what white wants but
and he has captured on c4 has black
um you know it's funny again we're
talking about being all in with white
here
i don't like the fact that the rook
across the fourth rank is doing so much
uh could i just throw a bone and hope
you uh
it gives so many schools like i know i
think
or neither five first i don't know it
just looks
gh i am
what
oh my god
that is
wow what now this position is just so it
looks so dangerous yeah yeah i mean i'm
even thinking like if rook b1 wins
immediately rook b1 that is that that is
a cute move yeah that could be one
couldn't be one night of four not at
four knight f5 like
oh boy okay but we do have
g5 uh captures on c4 and carol is
thinking he's also down to a minute here
it's not a yeah perhaps we should
maximize the the the player camera
because
uh that's where and we have the actual
guess what he's played
i mean i love
your your idea there yeah 95 rugby one
is beautiful yeah beautiful and doesn't
work
oh dear that's the best things in
chelsea right beautiful i mean it
doesn't work for for kind of an amazing
reason okay please share knight d5
yeah rook b1 you take on b1 correct
f4 and knight g5 somehow wins the house
oh no i don't understand eight on eight
seven nine
yeah baby oh
let me show you my puzzle rush tactic oh
you're welcome to snack
and you can take on g2 with you you're
welcome
no you take on eats and then you take on
eating because you don't want to allow
25 check actually it's very important
not to allow q5 and
due to h7 check knight takes f7 not to
mention green h7 is made mate that's
kind of grows this tactic oh that's
beautiful that is that is really nice ah
oh man i
okay so now we understand why
carol made this uh
boss move d3d i'm not sure he saw any of
this
what else to do you you need to see
rugby one to even start calculating this
because right simply exactly what you
said he didn't really really hated the
idea of the rukon before participating
in the defense by long before playing
along the fourth rank so he's blocking
it out and he's got a minute and he's
also got a minute yeah versus four yeah
rugby one immediately so he's a happy
sorry sir he's got a whole minute whole
minute i mean he's been living on uh 30
seconds yeah yeah that's what i mean you
know a minute might be a luxury
oh my yeah and uh
very exciting and again
it's three and a half but i i hardly
know what's going on in the other games
levon aronian's game
that looks
it looks like white is up upon but it's
definitely not pressing right he's
actually getting pressed
hang on a second why did we take on
default with the rook
ah that's very clever because if you
take with the bishop you get hit by
rookie one check on queen c7 check and
you don't have a good reply
at all you might lose rookie one you
can't go to f2 and now after q7 check
you can't go queen g3 because of rook h1
check
g3 b4 is not much better
g4 is such a clever move by the one
because it looks like you know this is
the square that is the best defender
square the best defended square on the
board he goes d5
rogue we need to and you have to find a
draw now with white i'm not sure it's
such an easy such easy draw to find
maybe uh but there are there are some
weaknesses there can i go down and
hopefully uh angle for queen g set i'll
take one three and go rookie two oh
that's the other yeah okay and maybe
bishop d4 still holds maybe this is what
you have to do actually bishop d4 now
and uh allowing bishop takes f6 gives
white a lot of counterplay and otherwise
i will place you threesome holds i'm
sorry holds for who yeah
i don't know who's holding four b5
okay we will keep an eye on that one too
because there's some real
i mean
great struggles and again the wesley sow
richard uh rapport game is blowed up
yeah he played knight h7 here i'm not
actually
yeah i guess the idea is just to return
to g5 if there will somewhere are you
right
but yeah richard says don't really have
to defend it goes gh bishop g4 25 and
just spends you know spends a quiet
tempo taking the knight rook on d1 is
still hanging
we have all these pawns for the exchange
uh hg will also become you know
something to consider i quite like what
he's doing i don't know if the machine
likes what he's doing but
i very much like it
it's very very uh nice to be capturing
all of these bonds i'm sure wesley is
feeling the heat at the moment
queen d5 i can't leverage that into
three minutes against four and a half as
well i mean i mean i'm desperately you
know looking at sacrifices on the d4
square but not even close right not even
close uh rook d3 is a as a step
no he's reaching for his bishop
he wants to go with this bishop and
bishop
and rook b7 i guess with like rook h7
mate exactly as and he's thinking look i
got no choice i've got no choice he took
back quickly with the pawn
he has bishop e6 i think this is what he
won this question marco no i don't know
i gotta play rook
b7 have eleven
he's done it maybe he just wants to play
bishop takes d1 and say i have yeah a
bunch of pieces you have but you have a
gaggle of pieces and a queen simply
queen is six whoa that's clever queen g5
is there a threat
h7 check queen e6 clever move lost the
game no
yeah there's queen g5 rook h7 there's no
defense and bishop f5 is west
whoa one
you see
richard has played a wonderful game he
really has but one fast move can destroy
yeah bishop
efforts
they should simply be simply simply
cover the
block
yes the rank but he played queen e6
queen g and what's the
clock situation two minutes 52 for
wesley with plenty of time
and richie down to four
oh
and there's just no there's nothing
it's done
i mean the engine says you have to play
queen g8 and the game kind of continues
the problem is that the attack will play
itself because you go rook c1 rook c8
and roxy was sorry
yeah so you're saying queen g8 is
necessary to stop the rook from landing
on h7 well what else do what else do you
play at this point he played queen e5
which i think just straight up loses to
rook h7 which by 500 takes h6 i thought
well no it's ah you got it bishop g7
right okay queenie five on the board i
follow you peter so we give a check
sadly for us bishop f7 is not made very
beautiful
yeah so flavors by five bishop g7 and i
i think we just take on h6 here and
we're now in exchange up and the attack
continues
you know good enough
beatings will continue until morality
is one of my favorites
and i'm like
i'm assuming quintierette is not
stronger
i'm just amazed that
yeah
you you almost feel like you you start
to harvest everything with the tempo
yeah it doesn't feel like it's
which is apparently plus eight yeah yeah
plus it's actually stronger
plus eight plus eight yeah between the
eighth now without the check exactly
you're just hitting the bishop
because you can't defeat q7 the only way
to not to get made straight away and now
we're queen down and
now we we the meetings will continue
not sure about the morale but the
pitching's definitely will continue roxy
one played
now this rook that has been hanging
for the better part of five six seven
moves
suddenly makes a grand
entrance that's the thing about these
sharp positions right they can
change so quickly yeah and uh i've been
i've been kind of itching to reintroduce
this quote for for a number of days
because positions keep on keep on
showing up which make it relevant uh
there was a very interesting quote when
magnus was talking about his match
against fabi
and specifically the choice of playing
the sveshnikov on the black side that
that particular sweshnikov after 95
there yes the very sharp positions which
are very risky for black if you analyze
them with the engine you will come to
very quickly come to the conclusion that
you're fighting for equality and it's
unclear if you have it right but he said
basically
we came to the conclusion that those
positions are very interesting to play
and would be good for a match because
if it goes well for us
we give made exactly and if it goes well
for fabi he wins a pawn on the queen's
side
and it's just a technically good
position and the pressure of sort of the
stakes
makes it a lot easier to play for the
side that is playing to win the game as
opposed to
you know making make incremental
progress on the other side of the board
and we're watching this here as well
because like white's position is in is
in ruins yes but it's completely
irrelevant because he will give mate on
the other side of the board ah that's
the the connection there yeah
maydan's the game you know i mean it's
still
it's just so much easier it's so much
easier to play when uh yeah your goal is
the ultimate goal right your opponent
also knows that yeah you you uh richie's
got the past pawn that's going to make a
queen
uh i've got your king
and rook bishop e-8 was that necessary
at first i thought rook c7 was winning i
mean it probably was yeah i think it was
it's 67k66 i think it was made but push
p8 is also completely i mean it hits the
rook on a4 yeah among other things
i really did i really a shame on me i i
mean i'm looking for ponds you're you're
fishing for rooks i mean come on
what are these rook things that you
mentioned the rookies
oh
nice
okay guys this looks like it's done and
dusted yeah
i mean wesley will win this one easy
meanwhile let's go back to carol and uh
our whoa
that is another pond that is promoting
but i could like you said be taking your
king i don't think i don't think you
actually get there before check even
yeah i think we just got bishop g7 right
i think rook c1 check
uh
rook g4 check bishop g7 yeah maybe
king h2 right yeah the key h2 is the
only move actually that kind of makes
sense yeah
king aged so i'm guessing z1 d2 was a
very big mistake
yeah detail was a massive mistake really
we expected that from a while ago
the issue here is roxy one queen b2 and
the queen and
if you
win if you're queen you're deep on queen
she's kind of strong oh he's taken on
g7 also a mistake yeah and and 24 i
don't quite understand this i guess he
wants d1 queen queen g4
and then we have to run with the king
wow there's i don't know finish six is
not a legal move we have to run uh
okay so this is what he's done is i
don't think there's a choice here
actually i rook g7 was a bad move
according to the english i don't care
about the engines right i like this yeah
i mean it's understandable certainly i
mean you're taking this pawn you're
going to go queen d
g4 and if you have to promote queen g4
king f8 in 20 seconds you just hope you
have a perpetual yeah i mean whatever
right you throw you can throw your luck
to the wind and why shouldn't you just
play 5h6 somewhere
my king is very safe
and 20 seconds 20 seconds for gabrielle
it's going to be a great exciting finish
in this game
and for these juniors
giving up it's a queen sacrifice no no
no what's a queen sacrifice because
you're giving up d2 d2 was a queen
yeah oh i see what you mean right now it
actually starts running yeah right
yeah and h6 i think right yeah you go h6
h6
and like d1h7 is legitimately like black
has no no no meaningful checks right the
light on the three and the bishop on g2
protection
h6 yeah you have to take your h6 because
h7 is just such a humongous threat
oh for david this would be such a
turnaround he had this game
and this is about the pressure of the
junior game right exactly if you get a
winning position against chefchako you
feel now we're going to go and now we go
knight takes g2 if if he finds line
takes g2 he probably will end up winning
this game because queen takes loses the
queen to queen h8 queen g8 check and
queen takes g2 that's a pretty line
meaning that he gets to continue the
attack knight takes d2
excellent and he also and he also takes
the c6 square under control creating a
sort of i don't know because there's a
[ __ ] bishop c6 check that i but it does
take the
square the controller in some cases the
king the king comes from the other you
cannot run yeah okay it's actually
something the point is is that in case
you do take the time because you don't
pick up the queen check it's just mate
oh he's done it
so we can we can simply take on h6 now
if we want right exactly
yeah and continue europe material we're
now up material and now you have the
attack as well
oh okay turn around huge turn around
there yeah huge turnaround bye uh by the
uh the young ukrainian player but it's
not over 20 seconds for chef
championship good choice yeah trying to
trade some of the attackers look on c1
is hanging to the queen on h6 yeah 94
played with that in mind uh
blocking the attack and opening up an
attack
yeah it's just black has no real
contability uh hello no real counterplay
[Laughter]
there which is very relevant oh
and he's done yes queen f8 so now we're
going to question how we go queen g1
checking g3 rook c3 check i think
okay i think and then after f3 i'm not
sure what we're doing maybe queenie
wants or just take the night yeah it
just took a night
oh my god guys this is a great game
whatever happens this is a fantastic i
mean this is wonderful well you can't if
you take on before you get made it right
he's done it he took on it no i mean
like white if white takes something from
you made it okay now now you can
and weirdly because the bishop one f6
can't really connect with the king on b5
you you
probably don't have mate yet yeah you
have to take off the e5 pawn so you
can't get your king down to c3
once again guys what's the time
situation on the clock 14 14 seconds
seven 35 seconds or something
wesley won but we expected that yeah
actually it took forever
no i think the game has been over for a
while it's just look at this king we're
watching something very exciting so we
oh my gosh i mean
three
f2 is hanging not anymore
you know some semblance of control over
what's happening on the other side
you can even maybe play something like
yeah
[Music]
yeah just don't allow b7 check queen b6
check perhaps
that's actually kind of smart because
the end game is very unclear but yeah
queen f7 yeah maybe i'm not sure but
yeah this wasn't uh now you gave up the
the ideas of queen f2 and queen g1 he
snacked on the f seven pawn that's a big
pawn to smackdown too
he has to play queen
six six maybe but yeah you should yeah
queen before was probably a mistake no
quebecois is not a mistake he has to
find either queen d2 or rookie one
i don't know about rookie one i don't
understand that move but queen d2 i
understand and yeah i would like to play
bishop
yeah
i would like to play bishop to g5 as oh
no c3 very understandable e6's so no way
the thing i don't like about it is the
moment you get e6 in the bishop
there's a bishop
in the game yes right yeah exactly so
when you have five and then you just go
e6 next by the way queen f5 protecting
f2 so no
hits there no funnies no funnies yeah
and you're right
by the way because yeah if the bishop
goes somewhere queen h4 check becomes
kind of a token h4 is protected by the
bishop on episodes
sideways sideways chess is difficult
so we're expecting bishop to d3 just
sideways
we're watching it from the side
bishop d3 he's done it and now oh that's
all oh that's a threat i assume that's a
threat that's a big threat i actually
have no idea no counterfeit oh mate no
is it there's no where is it it's like
two checks
three checks three checks
yeah
show me show me the chat he's six go for
it make your threat e6 is such an insane
oh i love it my gosh i love you such
insane place
they are really challenging this is a
great game
uh with no time on the clocks but that
bishop on f6 is now alive what a great
piece in fact checking f3 second check
from each one i thought about this yeah
i think i think
how do you get out of this yeah it's a
well
i
i want to run run which way you're
actually supposed to run along the h
file it's impossible i think it's in
real life you can't like you're supposed
to like go king uh he's just gone king
h5 and have bishop h4 there i think
queen
check guys if this ends in a draw
somehow somehow quite fitting it really
is
wow yeah but
wow
can he crawl up the h file machine says
he can so kg4 here he's going for it of
course chefchango doesn't back out from
these things he like he calculates those
things very well impressive very very
very nice it reminds me of that game of
linears in the uh in in bucharest where
he went
bishpi seven right where the the against
the weird game where he got his king
stuck on a2 in the sicilian against
dayak
where yes yes yes yes yes because here
as well we're basically we're getting
line mated but we have bishops
and it actually is enough yeah sideways
bishop h4 check covers the uh check on
h1 not only yeah doing this on 20
seconds is
wow some very very impressive stuff but
first of all
rook h1 bishop h4 that at least releases
the the uh c3 pawn and where do you go
with the c3
it's covered on c2 it's under control
yeah this is the point it's comp
everything is completely under control
okay no i'm starting with check okay and
then
bishop h4
queen
eight eight i don't think queen h a
check is actually a legit threat
yeah the i'm not sure this
queen h7 might be good enough right
right
oh no way
really
wow this is remarkable yeah and this
will be and there you go
but creepy really doesn't have a threat
no
[Music]
such a turnaround will be heartbreaking
for
uh for david because he played that game
really well each time
up to a point he played that game really
really well but yeah this is now like
completely hopeless you don't have
checks c2 is never a threat exactly in
europe's stance just king h5 whatever
what a great fight seriously
i mean what a gladiator type of position
right it felt like both sides could have
won it could have been a draw i know and
this is the handshake
understandably disappointed is garvey
lesko because he had this game he just
let it go how entertaining it was right
it was incredible one game left we still
have another game wow a very important
game for our uh
and we looks like a repetition no he
went to b8 uh oh he did he went to b8
and now he gets i think to put the pawn
on a2
but even that doesn't really
and then we draw yeah
yeah yeah but
uh guys we already had one rook and
bishop versus rook
trading be five for before here is quite
difficult i don't think we're likely to
get another one in in this particular
position simply because the the pawns
are too locked in
king could somehow magically appear on
the b6 square king to b6 with mate
threats yes
yeah we don't have yeah we're not we're
not doing that yeah a2 oh i think it's
just now it's just you have rook h4
check yeah it's important oh yeah and a2
is defended by this bishop yes yes yes
yes
um
by the way by the way it's making great
progress in that case right
yeah how do you how do you hold on to
this uh i think i think i need to put my
rook on the first right like if i go
king e3 or whatever
a2
rook g1
it starts getting annoying right right
annoying actually like if
he's allowing bishop d3 rook b4 as well
which is fascinating
rook is on the third right it's on the
third for now but i assume that at some
point you have to move it because i
thought no for me
look at that i thought rook h1 was kind
of annoying for me the bigger issue is
that now the king will be sort of a good
move rook check you got to go to the g
file because you can't go to yeah like
e7 g5 is still sort of ready now but
yeah now we go rookie six
rookies this is a move
no i think he's going to go rookie okay
actually
forces her k3 yeah my biggest issue is
that yeah now you know the white king
might not be in time to you know uh
shoulder shoulder the black king and the
the working could you know appear on
somewhere like the e4 square once again
rook h6 checked though peter i very much
like 16g5 i think we there's no reason
to fiddle around anymore right yeah we
just go we get the king to e4 and then
the diagonal for the bishop on e5
becomes much much shorter and eventually
we cross over to d3 and c2 and somewhere
around then it becomes it becomes
hopeless exactly i think by this point
it probably is just lost i think it's
just lost right i think it's just lost
the king needed to be closer to
like with the king somewhere around i
don't know the b two c two squares maybe
and if we just don't find any plan rook
b one rook takes before rook b one b
four yeah this is how you play yeah
i think you found a good plan
uh and for duda by the way this will be
a
i mean it's not a victory over a fellow
candidate but
uh lavonne
at this point you can sacrifice the
exchange already even the start yeah
yeah like bishop f64 and give up the
exchanges winning
and then we should be three questions
yeah that's a very good point yeah yeah
this just yeah yeah rook f1 rook f6 i
think is now you can just do it straight
away yeah yes just ends the game
nice yep yep
and you take that yeah he has 59 seconds
so he will he will make sure he doesn't
miscalculate but yeah it's it's a very
short head there for lavon but he
recognizes that rook f6 bishop b3 king
c4
yeah and there you go
grand master professional trust right
seriously lazy man just get as many
pieces as you can off the board yeah and
you know king c4 takes before yeah and
there's bishop water as well so you can
you don't even need to get the king to
be so you just take them before and you
win the rook straight away because if it
goes to a7 which pay for queens the
opponent a24 gotcha
very nice keeping this tournament
interesting wow yeah yeah
closing up on richie yep
closing up on richie because well we
know
you know we know who's in first place
yeah fishy sitting there good effort
everybody good effort
good job good job
good efforts everybody well done and
that's a round eight wow
what a wrap up that was good that was
good after the rook and bishop man i was
feeling tired but the juniors the
juniors brought it brought in i mean the
juniors brought it inspiring chess there
by uh krill and david yeah it was kind
of a bit worse than this
win
he played d2 how could you not play d2
come on wait how can you play d2
yeah yeah dj was a bit of a miss i think
he just underestimated what was actually
happening to his position and he felt
that he had defenses right but it was
just not enough i think he must have
missed specifically
yeah i think king h2 specifically he
missed in this position after bishop g7
king issue is a great move because you
get out of these checks and it just
gives you enough time to play something
like what happened in the game rook g7
queen d4 even ideas of putting the queen
on b1 and going to b8 in certain
positions
he couldn't play d2 it was just not the
time to do so he had to prevent rook g4
or give his king a little bit of a
flight square knight h6 is a weird move
but once you realize that the main
only threat is rook g4 knight h6 just
deal so the easiest i think was the move
bishop h6 because it immediately
threatens rook c1 finishes the game and
if you put
this check on g4
yeah i think king fade is fun a king of
fate i think queen a3 is an issue but
king h7 because the bishop uh covers on
g5 i mean you can throw in the check but
so what and then i'll start running my
pawns and that was just completely
winning for the black side and i think
by this point david still had 49 seconds
so a lot of time pressure didn't
calculate the variations properly and
then was the huge mess we saw then
things from this position
went to v2 i mean this king went all the
way there like a lot of things happen in
this game yeah um
peter uh bring us up to date on the
current standings yeah let's take a very
eventful round eight i got to tell you
that
for the first time in this tournament
vishay actually this game was the least
eventful of the round right yeah but
he's still
he's still sitting very pretty there on
14 out of victory
16 uh we heard in clear second but yeah
two people are now within touching
distance of reheard at least yeah wesley
with the victory and young sisters with
that very very uh important win over
leonardo yeah for livonian that's a big
big step backwards uh again the rapids
have worth two points bobby oh no
two draws he's not going to be too
satisfied if we got one i need to i need
some massive human explain to him the
importance of my condition
yes exactly exactly and our final
pairings peter for our knight
final final rapid round uh youngsters of
who just won that game against the one
is white against korowa who is having a
kind of a non-event by his standards
david
white against iranian uh fabi white
against shivchenko and then we get the
clash of the two leaders in the last of
the day
richard rapport white against vichy
obviously very incentivized to try and
get a game there absolutely against the
rock solid repertoire that she has and
radica is playing white against wesley
so i mean if i had given you the the
pairings before the start of the
tournament and said okay in the ninth
round two of these players are going to
be playing for first place who are they
pick the game uh that would have been uh
that would have been prescient
difficult
exactly yeah very nice i don't know
which one you would have guessed out of
the night if you had to pick two that
are leading the tournament let me try
and take a look again of the the ninth
round yeah i don't think there's like a
hugely odd it's not like wesley's
playing five i'm actually picking it up
you're actually picking rockford vichy
right considering the pairings for the
last round i'm picking rapport with you
yeah yeah
wow uh once again if you yeah if if you
know nothing about the about the freezer
and you have to pick up a game here it's
probably i mean it's definitely rapport
against vichy and then probably uh uh
i'm guessing do the kore book actually
yeah
but let's jump to warsaw as we have
christian with wesley
thank you uh yasser wesley this was a
huge victory for you against richie
rapport who was just on fire he won four
games in a row but you stopped him in
this one and this was a crazy game yeah
what are your initial feelings
afterwards well first thanks for having
me christian it's good to see you again
and uh it's good to see your uplifting
spirit and application yes yes so he
played the king's indian as he played
before uh first of all i think this
tournament the level of play
by almost everyone is except bishop is
very low like i was looking at the games
yesterday there was a lot of one there's
mistakes also i
didn't feel
that i'm 100 percent also i'm not
playing at my hundred percent but when
you play
this maybe is due to the fact that a lot
of uh players are coming from a
classical competition
to a rapid and blitz competition that's
what my mother says about this uh but
last year it worked very well for me in
paris because i had opening preparation
all that so it's it's hard to say which
is better with blitz and rapid before
classical or classical first
but in any case and when you play the
kings indian i mean give us your uh
thoughts about this crazy game because
you felt like you had the advantage out
of the opening then he had the advantage
then you got the advantage and then some
mates came on the board yeah definitely
i want to get an interesting game i mean
if i lose i lose
but i think i mix up my preparation here
like bishop detour this usually is good
with the knight black knight on d7
but here wasn't exactly sure what was
happening given that
he himself and vichy were kind of
running away uh creating a big
separation
mostly
was this a must win game for you in your
mind uh probably but with the way i'm
playing i just wanted to survive
but probably like here for example just
to show you about my bad play like i
played roxy one but in fact i could have
saved the tempo maybe if i play rook a2
and then bishop c1 rook d2 but i say i
played rook c1 first and here i didn't
know what to do so i played roxy t2
and then bishop see once i basically
lost a tempo for and whole time before
nothing without even realizing it like
this tournament i was
missing a lot of opportunities against
the bank and fabi so it's
if you can't convert
great positions then it's not your
tournament but well sometimes that was
unlocked yeah this is seventh grade
like here i wasn't sure exactly what to
do but
i guess i thought my bishop on c1 is
passive so i gotta activate it but
somehow my queen got trapped
and after i played a4 i realized that he
has this g5 h5 idea my queen got trapped
but it didn't seem so bad because at
least it doesn't have an attack maybe
it's just a wild game maybe you should
play g4 first as the computer says but
anyway here
after rook to b8 i guess rook b2 is a
mistake maybe c5 and i'm okay
but like here everything's falling apart
it's upon up and as you can see the
board is full of black pawns here i
guess it's not so bad huh no no it was
still quite balanced and then it did
seem like you're getting an advantage
mostly because of this point right now
d3 seems to be a critical move
nevertheless even after c5 the computer
doesn't really understand exactly what
the assessment is e5 and then you have
to follow it but you see it jumps from
like plus one point five to plus three
doesn't understand much depth
and this was a normal move bishop to b2
right yeah bishop b2 was a mistake i
mean yeah it really is computer
but uh yeah like here i was just hoping
for some tactics i guess my a7 was a
mistake too and i don't want to keep you
for a very long wesley because you do
have a game coming up in in in five
minutes yeah sure and and i do hear some
applauses from the playing hall so they
might be starting without i don't want
them to start without you
yeah it's a funny game this was the
critical moment right now you saw rook
h7 and uh a big victory for you you're
playing
what's the strategy going in the final
game yeah
just want to play fast play solid start
to get invited in the club and try to
attack my point psychologically that's
the best i can do
excellent you have five minutes to get
ready for the final game we'll let you
go good luck in the last game
thank you thank you guys and we're
actually as we are getting ready uh to
start the final rapid game we're going
to go to a feature let's see what that
is all about
[Music]
how does it feel to be here in warsaw
for the first ever grand chess tour
health here in poland it feels great to
be back
i played here relatively recently
um for the world rapid and blitz
championship
and it was it was a lot colder during
the winter it was very hectic because
you know we played every day like
six plus hours a day
um but the city is beautiful and it's
good to be here and
hoping to improve a bit on
my last tournament which you know it was
nice to play in bucharest but my level
of play wasn't really there so i'm
hoping to improve a bit special feeling
is that i can play against vichy with
whom i was working for many many years
and now we are
let's say
arrivals is a strong word but let's say
that we'll play
[Music]
games very nice i played an event in
poland 22 years back this is a blitz
well blitz championship
but this is very nice i've come to visit
my my seconds here but to come and
compete here in this wonderful venue
it's going to be a very nice experience
it's a very nice feeling it's really a
dream come true for me i
i have been watching the the top players
for the last few years and uh i'm
thankful to have the opportunity to face
them on the chess board yeah it's a very
special feeling that actually
granchester is hiring warsaw in poland
you know i not quite used to play such
strong events in poland so it's a nice
thing
oh yeah it's very nice i i like to be
part of this uh debuting events
i think i haven't played an event before
which was the
first time organized but i have been to
warsaw just
quite recently for the
dragon blitz i was kind of sure that
it's going to be uh
well organized and i like rewards was
nice but this time at least it's a
little bit warmer than
winter right so it's uh it's nice yeah i
feel good i feel very privileged here
i'm very happy that they have uh they
decided to become part of grand chester
and they have a large tournament here
with some of the best players in the
world so
it's a it's a good audition my first
time poland never played there before
and i'm very excited warso is
a great place it's a place where i've
played a zillion times
but rarely in the summer or in the
spring
so it's absolutely wonderful i had a
long walk in the old town yesterday
and he
loves it so much and so
i really enjoyed being here it's very
amazing that i am invited in this
grandchild store
and
it's very big pleasure for me to play
against
such a top grand masters and i'm very
excited i'm afraid all the time yeah
when coming to the granchester my films
are the same they had in bucharest or in
zagreb more or less led you to
let you to be a victim in the tournament
and to be tortured until the very last
round
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
uh welcome back to the final round of
the final day of the rapid no more rapid
after this and this these are the
standings prior to this uh of
round nine and the key matchup
vishy versus richard or should i say
that
as white yeah there you have it on your
screen the the game are in progress and
it's uh
vichy even has an opinion about this
quite clearly which is quite funny in a
way uh but uh you you will notice
there's this pollen a4 there it looks
like a very normal uh
foreign but there is a poll on a4 and
this is uh
i will
sort of ironically say it's the recent
trend
people basically at some point tried
making every single move that exists in
the position after e4 e5 knight of three
knights knight of knight c6 knight c3
knight defense four
knights there i think currently grand
master games which feature the move rook
b1 in this position g3
oh g3 is a surprise that's not rugby
yeah yeah specifically like a3 a4
d3 i think maybe somewhere oh my gosh
that's really reaching but a4 yeah for
some reason it has maybe some advantages
well you basically what richard is
saying here is that i would like to play
this mission with black with a with a a7
a5 move included
and vishy says be my guess yeah and
rishi says i'm not interested in bishop
before not interested in d75 i'll just
play g6 and this is actually kind of
interesting to me because this is now a
pure affiliator but you threw in which
in which a4 is not useful it's not
necessarily the most useless move in the
position exactly many times you do see
the the
ideas of a6 and c5 and b5 appear
and a4
has i mean obviously it's probe not not
your first choice and you would like to
play rookie one let's say bishop one
first or four bishop f3 and the fact
that you were kind of forced to play for
there is is not not ideal ideal but
it definitely isn't the stupidest thing
in the position and a5 trying to make a
virtue out of necessity yeah look at
this
a4a5 clamping down yeah i wonder what
the reply to bishop fate is though
because black's play is very much based
on the idea that the pressure against
the e4 pawn forces white to make some
uncomfortable decisions
i thought maybe he wants rook a4 here
but bishop d7 is going to be very
awkward
uh
and by the way rook a4 is a very richy
move yeah it is but i mean
this actually chooses not to even play
this buffet it goes night before instead
which is wow
actually another facet to uh why you
perhaps don't want to play for this
early because now the knight has this
square and it cannot easily be chased
away by a2 a3 and it will get supported
by the 7c5 exactly but i did like the
the point you were about to make uh
which was like bishop f8
uh attacking the pawn on e4 opening up
and you can't actually protect it right
it's not a good move but you can
actually do this yeah exactly with this
kind of hidden defense of the pawn on e4
but knight before was in fact
vici's
reaction to a5
and again
this all-important game for first place
as tomorrow will go into uh the blitz
knight before what do you think about
this
you you actually are intending to play
c5 and maybe not even necessarily follow
it up with d65 i think you play c5 and
then you want to bring the bishop over
to the c6 square yeah i go c5 here you
probably play knight f3
let's say bishop d7 i see and put it on
c6 put the other one on the fade
exert as much pressure as possible
against the e4 pawn first and then and
then we'll ask ourselves do we want to
push the 65 do we want to keep it keep
it this way and it's not so easy with
the pawn on a5 to push the knight away
from
b4
wow i find that fascinating
and richie
well he has his own uh
approach he played a four f2 f4 really
he does have his own brand of chess
right a4 a5 f2 f4 right
it actually is kind of
weirdly it's a defensive move because
you you want to play bishop of three but
you want to do it with the bishop not in
front of your f2 pawn because that would
be awkward okay so you're playing you're
playing a four to meet bishop with
bishop f3
and that also gives you the e2 square
for the knight on g4 if it gets chased
away now so if you want to play c5 i
suggest you probably do it here okay
i i like it
but now yeah once maybe knight b3
because now the knight doesn't want to
go to f3 we will step on the bishop's
toes we want to continue preserving the
f3 square for the bishop so bishop f3
for instance
and
you know sometimes you can maybe even
launch into some g4 g5 ideas the knight
from b3 could go
in an ideal scenario d2c43 or something
that's a lot of highfalutin maneuvering
there very much so yeah i i i'm kind of
i've warmed up to your earlier
suggestion to just pound as much as you
can on the e-pawn
but one of the things
also maybe with the c540 by the way
move is that
maybe the desirable d5 before you put
your bishop on f3 right
how how would this
uh these are very sharp i think they're
very concrete i i'm not prepared without
sort of analyzing the engine and
everything move by move
it does seem like you've
white that is to say has put a lot of
time
in playing this move advance on the
queen side a4 a5 whether it shows a
return or not
it's a lot of
a lot of tempe for absolutely a
questionable
and of course bishop f5 is a
dream
scenario for
black this is maybe very playable um
if you don't play five then perhaps yeah
the previous play becomes less less
easy to justify right
exactly all right
we're going to keep our eye on this
absolutely absolutely key match up
alejandro uh turn it over to you what uh
what has caught your eye well we have a
couple of other great games fabi against
chef chenko i always like to see when
players use their pet line against one
of these top players i always like to
see what they come to the game with
because we have another chebanenko type
slav and chavchenko has been using this
kg move order which i also like to use
as well in this e3 slots instead of
going e6 like almost everybody does
allowing knight h4 trapping the bishop
and then theory just begins explodes
yeah you play them with a6 which
transposes to achabanenko slav with the
move e3 and bishop f5 this is a common
way of playing as well and ton of theory
here queen b3 has been tried we just saw
the move knight e5 in the game between
duda and chefchaenko i want to say yes
dude in chefcheko a couple of rounds ago
was 95 queen b3 merry main line bishop
e2 and then bishop d3 has been played
bishop d3 immediately has been played
tons of moves a4
not the most common move
but an idea the point is that after e6
you have to go a5 if you don't go a5
anytime soon black gets a5 in himself
and this semi slot structure with the
bishop out and this knight coming to b4
totally fine for the black side so you
need to prove some advantage and the way
that you can do it is by playing a5 and
look at what happens to the structure on
the kings on the queen side for black
completely controlled you play b6
fractured structure but is white fully
developed not so much right so black
takes advantage of that puts the pawn on
c5 takes two tempi to do so the knight
comes to c6 will hit the pawn on a5 will
also more comfortably hit the pawn on d4
so it challenges white to solve the
issues in the center currently we have
the move c takes d5 both sides taking a
little bit of time for their opening
moves because both pawn takes d5 and
knight 65 lead to significantly
different positions fascinating opening
struggle here between fabi and
chavchenko
thank you for that uh alejandro and uh
just looking at the game between reddick
and wesley so it's one of those catalans
which i really don't understand is
bishops of opposite color catalan it
just
looks to me like black's life is too
easy here but maybe i'm wrong but who
who knows about these positions
yes because had exactly this position
but with the black pieces
against kovalenko so he believes it for
black he listened for black let's see
what he does with white okay we'll keep
an eye on that but i'm just saying that
for wesley it feels like he's gotten out
of the opening scot-free
it's not entirely like this though
because uh
the the slight spatial advantage that
why hasn't my i started off thinking
this can never be anything at all right
uh but then the more you watch strong
players play these types of positions
the more you realize that it's actually
kind of trickier than you think because
white starts by trying to gain some
space on the king on the king side you
don't immediately play e4 but you do
play h4 and eventually i think the
ambitious plan here is to push e4 e5
eventually
maybe with the pawn on h5 and then you
go for you know if the bishop from g2
can be transferred over to b1 you get
this diagonal ideas with
creating a battery on the b1 h7 diagonal
knight knight if you play e3 here
playing h2 uh sorry h2h4 and then
perhaps uh knight h2 knight g4 if black
replies with g6 and h5 is
and the the point is
it's very unclear where black's counter
play is because if if white manages to
control both the c5 break and
specifically the e65 brake which
generally white manages not to allow or
at least not to allow in any kind of a
favorable setting
black's position is forever solid
but white does have those kind of creepy
creepy crawly ideas of improving uh
improving on the king side and
eventually pushing
and i've seen this position being
positions being lost with black and it
kind of surprises me every single time
about
any obvious mistake
you shuffle shuffle shuffle shuffle and
then suddenly something starts happening
and weirdly you're not entirely prepared
for it i i've seen this happen and yeah
as i mentioned it surprised me as
everything surprises me everything every
single time but
less so than
you're getting used to seeing these
accidents happening yeah queen v6
not necessarily tickling this pawn but
maybe uh prepping
a
quick assault if i could put it that way
against the pawn on t4 okay we'll keep
our eye on this game very important for
wesley so he wants wesley so this to say
he wants to enter the blitz as close as
he can to this man uh vishyana and by
the way the players are following
our lines bishop f8 uh a moment ago
before the move bishop f8 i thought
to ask about d5 e5 94. vishy said bishop
f8
and i like this
anything to be said for rook b8 maybe
playing to put the bishop on b7 it's
slow or i think i think getting the
bishop to the long diagonal is uh
imperative yeah the question is whether
e5 is playable here i think you the
reason you might pause before playing
bishop d7 is you might be worried this
works for white right d five fe five you
have to take with the rook because now
there are six guys squares and now
either the bishop before immediately or
bishop b7 followed by bishop f4 oh i
love d5
right yeah and he's gone he's going to
65 i i thought if
if maybe this is what he wanted to play
but i it took me a bit to realize what
he wants after e5 yeah e5 bishop f5 is
the point
e5 the five i like this
oh that's well spotted this is that is
nice i mean
your instant your instinct uh reaction
is hey he's hitting my knight where's my
knight going but bishop f5
uh before moving the knight makes all
the difference in the world bishop f5
yeah and then we move
and i think it's the same reply to
taking on d5 right yeah absolutely such
a strong threat i think you probably
want to get a pair of knights off the
board but i'm not even sure entirely
about that like if white has to take on
d5 previous move because this looks
borderline unplayable to me if i push by
five i don't like it all for white i
don't see what the next move is if you
have to play rook f2 it it gets hit very
very high i was
actually just on that note uh where i
was looking at is i wanted to make sure
that there was no um
how they say issues against black's king
because there is
there is a a
a missing pawn i want to say a missing
jeep i mean with this with this amount
of central control there is never going
to be any attack on the king's side
exactly that's that's what uh
the judgment cause and our
lifetime matchup between them uh once
again so
not not very many games and uh yes so
far clearly going in uh in richard's
favor uh
one two three two and
zero losses until today but uh yeah a
risky potentially risky position for why
strategically there and once again we
come back
yeah we we get back to the importance of
this match yes so it is it is our
outright leaders of the tournament
finally facing each other in round nine
of nine
does that mean in the blitz they'll be
playing i think so no i think there's
there's been a separate separate droid
there's cyber drawings for the blitz
gotcha thank you for that alejandro uh
we do have e5 on the board uh
interesting i guess he doesn't want to
play
i guess he does want to play rook after
it looks very awkward but
i don't imagine anything else
with the bishop i guess yeah and we play
play play bishop iii here and we claim
we've i'm not like i i get this but what
do you play against
knight like d4 yeah i was wondering
about throwing in g4 somewhere maybe
here yeah
uh right now yeah right now d4 efdc
yeah this looks strong yeah
q1 is a real issue
if i ever take on f6 and you take on c3
i don't want to see a rook landing on my
back ring
so that means you have to move the
knight and that's but that allows 94
with a very very heavy tempo right right
right
well okay just to see how life works
bobby fischer sometimes you to get
squares you got to give him
that's how
that's how it works
i mean even even queen d7 here i think
is very very you're being too fancy come
on i think i think yeah
it works i think it works i know
come on i i actually think maybe default
knight a4 is a better try weird it's
like it's such a horrible square but at
least we're attacking the opponents it's
all right there's a tickle
i and you got two units hanging yeah
but honestly even if i have to play
knight g7 here i'm not entirely unhappy
because i don't really care about the b7
pawn having made so much progress in the
center also put it on d5
yeah
first of all don't don't make yasser
happy nobody wants to make that happy
every day all i ask is that the two of
you when you wake up in the morning you
should ask yourself how can we make
yasser happy today that's that's all i
can ask you
he's like this is my every morning for
the past like three weeks
is the suggestion here that we don't
incredible good point 95 wait a minute
my spidey sense is tingling
i guess we can play knight e3 maybe
tonight
yeah this because it's getting a little
mess yeah this is a very very uh unclear
mess and this is what you're looking for
with white because at least here you
you're not
obviously behind we do have bishop f5
and rook f2 yeah
that's clearly clearly going to have
vishy's intention when he played d5 was
to
you know i mean but it feels like as
white
if you've allowed your opponent to put
the bishop on f5 in such a nice manner
that
this should be favorable for black i
mean yeah the big question here i think
knight e4 does allow white to stabilize
to a very large degree i don't think
white is worse after 94 bishop followed
by b3 so if you want to play for more
than than equality i think it has to be
d5 d4 and then it becomes massively
massively dependent on how these uh
these complications come out
just a little bit uh
so you go bishop e3 you hit my c5 pawn i
go b6
you stabilize rook d2 this kind of a
thing but i've got the queen two queenie
two maybe with the idea of g4 and just
picking up the pawn on e4 queen e2 the
bishop f8 is very restricted the pawn on
e4 is somewhat weak i'm not saying white
is necessarily doing very well but i can
see how this could be okay
i i don't know what the the evaluation
is but i can see how this is not that
bad any trades on tv
i'm probably picking black yeah but
i don't think it's it's horrible like i
will play i don't know
rook fg2 and then maybe knight d5 trade
a pair of knights i have a very nice
blocker on e3 all right we have a lot to
look at so i'll stop okay that 94 rookie
2 is really bad for what for black 94
rookie 2 yeah you can't play this as
black
knight e4 rook e2 stop right here yeah
wow and knight takes d5 is a threat i
guess yeah yeah yeah okay
fair
wow okay very fair
oh yeah and d4 is so strong that and uh
wesley fishy yeah well we're so used to
making first place
uh vichy did play uh the best move d5 d4
this is exciting what have you got for
us alejandro a little bit of a miss but
still a great position here well things
are really heating up in this king's
indian between duda and corvo kurobov
when he's on fire he is just
a beautiful player
active play just loves his positions
this tournament he's been a little bit
of a dud he hasn't really gotten his
positions he hasn't been able to
calculate properly and this one in
particular let's analyze what's going on
back here where the position was still
very interesting typical kings indian
you can see that white expanded we're
calling it off a zero style these days
with h4h5h6
and tombing this bishop on a chain it
doesn't have any moves but white hasn't
castled this pawn made it all the way to
a3 kind of a counter play on the other
side of the board and you could take on
b2 you can take on d5 the game counter
goes on and then he took on e4 which to
me is a tremendously weird uh
strategical decision to be able to
send this at all yeah especially because
you don't have to take it anytime soon
and here duda actually missed a chance
surprisingly to just finish the game
this configuration
is so awkward that the move c5
threatening bishop c4 just wins
bang that that's it that there's just
nothing you can do you go bishop before
next move and then you take on c6 and
you just can't save this king it's just
too awkward to move it out of g8 and you
can't interpose with a bishop on e6 on
time or comfortably instead the move b4
was played which is still very very
strong because you can just play c5 at
some point soon it's not like it's going
away and i think sensing danger korabov
put the rook on f4 sacrificing the
exchange of course nobody takes that and
opens the bishop
c5 instead now played bishop c4 coming
queen takes g5 on the board and simply d
takes c6 and i was mentioning this is
such a deadly threat it it doesn't it's
not a check it just wins the game
ponte's d6 can be thrown in you can
start with check king f8 c takes d6
you're threading d7 you have to play
right bishop d7 there's no other move
and now you could try to get the rook
with 92 or something like that but the
most precise d5 oh b5 sorry open more
things for your rook if you take on b5
you're gonna have to contend with queen
d5 very soon black's position is just
falling apart can't create any threat to
this dead bishop with this dead knight
yes you have two major pieces but this
bishop is just controlling both of them
as it defends the f2 square perfectly
white in a commanding position do the
favorite with this one to finish off the
rapid in poland for him
i'm sure he actually analyzed this when
he played the move b4 that he he wanted
to play v5 probably not realizing as you
were pointing out alejandro that uh the
immediate c5 was he uh
was even more effective but boy uh
yeah i mean you're just the king's
indian getting killed in this particular
moment
and there was a moment of like high
comedy there on the hundred screen for a
second if you if you go back to that
line after knight g4
uh specifically the moment where white
takes on e4 and stop there
look at the first line there i
disappeared okay it was saying c65 is
the best movement
so that you didn't have to face yeah for
first 35 for a second there it was it
was claiming now is so good it's
the best but back
kind of have to play c65 you still
resign obviously
but like the indication as an indication
of just how bad things have gotten right
yeah the engine is saying please please
please stop c45 i'm dying here
uh
yeah a lot of uh
things have gone wrong unfortunately
here for anton as
yeah
he hasn't really been himself in this
tournament you know one of the one of
the most fascinating
players
that over the years i've gotten to watch
was vladimir kramnik and vladimir
was furnishing a house
with his victories against the king's
indian he was just killing the king's
indian in so many ways gary kasparov
stopped playing the kings and hippie
kids scrambling then kramnik
he played it himself
and won an extraordinary game
was it against gusty no i'm trying to
remember i thought it was a dortmund
tournament where he ended up playing a5
and he he suddenly he was uh he was
playing the black side of the king's
indian like a connoisseur it was
there was a very specific line which
until that moment was considered to be
very safe and actually much better for
white and he had a novelty there which i
think he had very high expectation of
actually getting against uh against my
friend uh my friend gusty and uh
yeah gusty didn't react to it properly
and uh and lost with white i think i
know which game exactly
um what game do i have this is uh this
is another one we haven't looked at yet
this is the lavon
iranian game
where once again uh garlesko plays the
the same quiet uh scorch
like position yeah and levon instead of
what vishy has done the one i should
just play bishop d3d6 saying let's play
a kind of a let's play game of chess i
don't care about equalizing on the spot
right and yeah it's it's now an end game
which
uh you know white managed to trade off a
lot of pieces but yeah it's a very sharp
end game because the bomb d5 is weak and
black's entire structure on the queen
side is weak awesome
and uh normally this you know when you
start talking about a position in those
terms it normally ends up with
weaknesses kind of getting traded off
right and equalizing upset equalizing
each other but i'm not sure this is
happening here because i i can't find a
comfortable way for white to make a move
bishop g3 yeah the 53 is very annoying i
think knight e3 so you've got a little
uh tickles on the
that maybe rook of two works i wanted to
go rook b8 here and b3 c4 is definitely
not what e6 exists yeah so maybe i'm
blundering a lot ooh a6 exists
[Music]
properly timed yeah
okay i mean i wouldn't be surprised if
white were actually okay but oh
i would have never thought of this it
might be a good move but but i wouldn't
have thought of it bishop after was
played
ah
yeah i
would have been difficult for me to
make it yeah yeah that wasn't on my
radar either because of how weak e5 is
like in general i understand the idea of
solving the issues tactically by perhaps
luring the knight away from the e5
square by attacking c5 but he takes
takes and something like bishop c7 here
i think what he's claiming and maybe
this is correct is that if you just play
e6 here
fe put the knight on e4
this type of structure you probably hold
with wise in general in particular use
with this in particular if the
opponent's e5 doesn't immediately get
traded for the pawn on b exactly the c5
c4 here for instance but yeah i can
understand the idea of the move it's it
probably wouldn't have been my first
choice but i understand where where he's
coming from yeah he's running into a bit
of trouble though because i like the
engine continuation it's also the
aronian continuation
from the v8 and then rugby rugby 8 is a
little cleaner yeah you did that nicer
yeah a moment ago you were really
thumping the table because you wanted to
get rook v8 yeah we want to provoke b3
and play c4 in response precisely as and
and your plan of playing knight e4 and
protecting b2 with c3 was very clever
yeah by playing rook b8 uh
you really crossed me out yeah yeah i'm
not gonna give you time to do that and
this is very clean yeah this is very
clean that's a wow uh yeah high class
play going on here uh we'll keep an eye
on this one what about uh ooh and he
played he played b3 bc but he now he is
in trouble because he's suffering the
bishop is really bishop c7 coming in now
we still have even back rank issues here
meaning that on top of everything and
double everything else yeah rook before
rook b2 but rook before rook takes c4
looks like lavon lavon for choice there
let's continue our our uh walk around
the room here what have we got in this
one this is bobby versus
is this a london no
electric come on yes exactly
exactly a whole lecture correct
we were there we were there
i mean i recorded in my diary i was
there alejandro gave a lecture
h2h3 i think how's our body fabby doing
i mean this looks five for black right
yeah i think you know i'm actually
picking black here i think yeah the
bishop on c1 is such an
um
not helping it's not i mean the rook i
mean
castles long term a6 is a weakness but
that that's pretty good
right if i get to go castles rook on f8
to b8 and i shut down and not only not
allowing b2b3 no i don't i don't like
this for black for white no i don't like
this yeah
but i know what you're saying if the
bishop
maintains some connection to the pawn on
a6 it could be a long-term weakness i
don't know that fabi worse with white i
mean
after a dozen moves come on that's
really been his tournament right it
doesn't feel like he's on fire or he's
bringing all these ideas yeah
for some lackluster event so far yeah so
there's still two two more days and
eighteen more games to go yeah we keen
blitz games we should go back to this
game i want to go back to vishy
sorry uh just because
they actually been following our line d5
d4 when we left it the knight went to a4
look you've got two units hanging what
are you going to do
not the move knight d5 i think it wasn't
1995 was alejandro's
i was arguing for 97 saying that
i will admit that i was arguing for
knight d5 completely blundering the c5
[Laughter]
well we've got a we've got a confession
booth on site and peter anytime you need
to you know
absolve yourself
now you know how to do it
yes g3 is a very very logical move here
because you want to uh generate threats
against the y position while white
hasn't finished development precisely
yeah c takes knight takes d3 will very
much invite c5 c4 as a follow-up after
rook d2 here i'm even looking at the
idea of going knight takes e5 first d7
takes e5
wow f e and now c4 because i don't want
to allow knight g4 basically i'm only
doing this to stop 94 from happening but
if you ever do get your opportunity to
play queen d4 checkers
rubbing your hands and glee this is you
know like the old mustard like there's
so much material stuck on the queen side
doing nothing that i feel quite
confident just giving starting to give
away material just to generate uh as
much initiative as possible you can see
hd3 not forced you can you can make an
argument with c3 and say i like this
position for white let me just for white
yes
i'm a pawn up
but i don't like
giving up the
the initiative and you're going to crush
me
think you don't need to play bishop
three if you're right he's played c4
this is why
and i was ready to discuss it but
instead he played c2 c4 which is a whoa
an interesting take on the move c3 which
says
it's less about attacking the knight on
before and it's more about stopping c5
c4 and not allowing anything to happen
very interesting option
very very interesting option
uh that's quite the visual move for me
f6
i love f6 we need to open up some yes
you do here and yeah six is my first
impression i don't know if it's uh
the best move in the position there is
definitely other options as well but my
first idea here is with apollon g3
seemingly completely safe for the time
being i do want
i've won central files
opened up
you're dreaming
yeah
knight c2 would be combined with an open
e-file with rook
i like f6 i think f6 is a very logical
move there might be something stronger
but that's my that's my first impression
okay
a double capture will expose the bishops
yes uh
no you can whatever something like that
bishop b3 is once again a sacrifice
right because knight is very awkward
yeah i don't think he will like the
outcomes of those lines within the d3
pawn still surviving
absolutely not i'm not sure
the one drawback of f6
if i ever get to play bishop d5 yes yes
good things could happen
but i'm not sure i i actually this is
why i kind of like provoking bishop c2
with either bish b3 or bishop d2 but
yeah it's it's a mess vichy has 11
minutes against 13-ish for uh for
rehearse so he will take his time here
he understands the critical position
absolutely i suspect c4 would have come
as a bit of a surprise yeah it's not the
first
or you know the most obvious option
there's also bishop e6
weirdly maybe is not stupid instead of
f6 yeah well c4 is not
looks like he is looking at the option
of going physics i guess
kind of
that's how it the the motion of his hand
i just want to say
vichy is a great experience grand master
so i'm not going to
criticize him but for the young people
in our audience
don't
go to play a move and not play it be
certain of your move before you put your
hand over the board because all you're
doing is telegraphing your move to your
opponent and your opponent sitting there
saying well where can that knight move
and they immediately start looking at
knight b6 yeah
it's it's a reveal to yourself yeah it's
it's a good piece of general advice
slightly weakened by
us just having watched the you know a
five-time world champion
do it on our screen
exactly don't do that don't because all
you're doing is revealing your hand
essentially is what's going on there in
your don't ever do that or you might
become a five-time world champion yeah
exactly and
the nice part there is if you've got a
really a good zinger kind of move
you know you
don't go to play the zinger think for
three minutes now your phone is ready
for your zinger right so uh do it you
know like no calculate clear everything
otherwise yeah being a fighter who wants
that
five-time world champion come on yeah 96
is an interesting option because it sort
of revives the white pieces a little bit
by you know you can take on c5 here uh
and i think you probably should which
knight like ac5 i would say a take c500
okay and i'm not sure what he wants in
reply because yes you can win the c4
pawn back but i i think the trade of c5
or c4 maybe makes white's life a bit
easier i'm not sure because it brings it
brings the knight on a4 back into the
game i won't argue that but
in some ways uh the move c4 actually i
was thinking that the move c4 was
designed to keep this diagonal closed
yeah i agree with it right
so like when i saw the move knight b6 i
understood that fishy was thinking that
oh well maybe on a good day you know
like the queen might show up on d4
somehow get on that diagonal so knight
a4 takes c5 i agree this knight offsides
now in the game
um
but
can i take advantage of exploit this
moment just like this what if i take on
c4 what is the what is the problem with
taking this before i wasn't sure i
wasn't sure here i want to go knight b3
okay and kikio coming away from the most
important diagonal now i want to play
at a5 maybe bishop b3 if i can bishop e3
if you can knight c2 bishop takes b6
it's getting very messy yeah who knows
what this is
it's been a mess for success
if at the end of these lines you have to
take a b yes
i see this very gleeful i suddenly have
this passer on a6
yeah like you can take only one here my
plan is to play 92. here as well my plan
is to play 92 right
okay
it's a mess who knows alia asked a very
salient question what if i take on c4
yeah i have no idea what my move here is
to be honest rook a4 rook a4 maybe
bishop bishop e4 is something maybe i'm
not
it looks very bad which before actually
looks horrible yeah i don't want that
bishop e4 i do want to trade some pieces
i just think it kind of loses to bishop
c5 bishop take c4 and queen d4 right
that position i hate that position i
really really hate rk4 can i go d2
whoa g2 whoa
group before right before bishop g4
whoa
have you ever had that feeling that you
lost country i feel i feel i'm getting
too fancy
i think you're overdoing it here a
little bit no but it was fun it was fun
while it lasted yeah wow
wow ali honda's
you know throwing the patties there you
know rook
how did it work
but man you were so close on this he's
going he's got knight a5 instead of this
move
yeah best move by the way
whoa okay
yeah knight ac5 knight c4 was lost just
lost less loss a minus three or
something because i don't know things no
moves yeah just things i guess you just
kind of k4 queen b6 was important
holds the knight attacks your knight and
you don't have knight a4 gotcha yeah
knight a5 knight a5 on the other hand it
would be very difficult for me to make
this move because like you you you
continue sidetracking your pieces but
yeah it goes it gets to c6 and it's a
very good squad square yeah it's a very
good square
well it's honestly six yet missed an
item before
also true
my goodness chess is hard
yeah yes this is really this is really
but it's kind of one-dimensional too
though isn't it i mean if i sidestep
like
the the thread i don't know
but we've also protected the pawn on c4
and as we've been uh talking about
look i i just i'll i'll throw it down
there
i want to get rid of this bishop on b7 i
got rid of this night i think we go
knight c3
night back to sea
i think we're actually yeah i think
we're setting up this perimeter
and now we want to kind of slowly slowly
come out of the corner bishop d2 queen
f3
you know stabilize that way i don't know
i don't have the zen at the position i'm
going to rely upon vichy
knight takes a4
get rid of that knight
he's done it and do we recapture with
the rook
or the queen
um
[Laughter]
the sound of experts really really
willing to commit
committing wholeheartedly to the
appearance of
you
right i don't know uh no seriously this
isn't good
uh
confused that alejandro uh
have you been able to
keep your eye on something else than
this game absolutely we have the game
between gabriel lesko and aronian i'm
just going to point out what's going on
one minute for white
21 minutes for black and that's probably
the least of his worries materials equal
but this one only six not exactly an
acid a little bit more of yeah just
toast it's dead i will pick it up one
day and this recon c4 monster attacking
on a4 attacking on c2 this rook is stuck
defending e6 for now this bishop will do
whatever it wants in the position this
knight is completely controlled the game
is over right i mean it's just over
black is winning this end game no matter
how you see it and
the huge
huge time advantage here for levon
highly expect him to take this one home
and meanwhile somebody that's not
exactly doing that is favi if i with the
white pieces has gotten his rook stuck
on g3 he's not losing according to the
engine he does have some pressure with
the knight on b6 and there are hanging
pawns that you can think about long term
bishop c3 coming blah blah but his
position with the rook on g3 cannot be
objectively good no and nine minutes
against seven will means that this will
be a mess at some point
hugely fascinating fight i'm kind of
concerned about the fact that this game
is not over
this game is pretty much over queen b3
check i guess king f7 is forced he'll
play king d2 to defend this rook
and then
whatever rook f7s rook f7 is kicking
your feet i soon yeah i mean i think
you're playing king effect i mean if you
let this rook hang forever you're going
to let it go one day
yes it's just
it's very lost i mean black has no
activity
this is very lost five an interesting
position and the only only other game
remaining is erotic against wesley we
hyped this up as an interesting position
in which white has chances i don't think
that's changed very much but materials
even further reduced means that the
rooks are off the board i think wesley's
favorite to draw this one but still
plenty of chess ahead so let's go back
and focus on the mess the division
against richie queen a4 was played just
to show us what the correct answer was
the engines saying zero so it's just a
mess for them as well white curling up a
pawn but i don't even know what's
happening in this position rookie 6 is
the engine stop move but many other
moves that black can play keep the
evaluation around the same
uh just because it's such an important
part of the discussion f7 f6 yes f7 f6
in this particular position two all
night
yeah bishop d2 taking on b4 remember the
knight c6 is a problem
and if you play you can also play knight
c6 immediately the idea is that if you
take bishop takes hits the rook so you
don't really have the time to do
all that you want to do because taking
on e5 doesn't produce enough threats
and white is just much better in this
position so f6 not the correct move in
this position it really wants to play
rook e6 take control of that square
first maybe even transfer the rook
somewhere else as well so rookie 6 or
queen b6 in general
it's about the c6 get a little more
control over the c6 square doesn't
necessarily mean that you control it for
sure but that you don't allow such easy
access for the white pieces i think
that's what this couple of moves is
about because you are going to get ready
to put this knight on c2 i know that
it's a controversial decision to put the
knight on c2 or not but rook b1 d2 is
kind of an issue in so many different
positions when the queen is not getting
hit when rook takes d2 doesn't hit the
queen that it's worth it to put the
knight on c2 according to the end just
huge mass and this one is this one's
over as we predicted duda beat anton
korobov uh finishing up what i think is
a pretty good day for duda as he just
beat levon right correct yeah yeah i
think he drew first i think he'd do the
first one here let me let me check yeah
i draw a win-win uh that's certainly
very very nice more i look at look at
what you're suggesting their rookie six
really does i get my vote after all
controlling the c6 square
again the desirable f6 i mean you you
you you attract me
it's a it's a quiet i think i think it's
not that easy to play simply because uh
it doesn't really create a threat as far
as i can see it gives white time to play
perhaps bishop d2 which is something
that white pretty much always wants in
this position absolutely opening up the
rook on a1 controlling the g3 pawn
slightly better and so on perhaps
creating some ideas of bishop takes
before
although giving the c5 square for the
bishop on f8 is offline very very double
hdmi yeah uh so rookie six i i don't
think it's a very very natural move but
vishy is kind of good at chess he played
the 57 though which is i mean bishop
seven is a much more understandable yeah
i i think yeah right like it does
something it does something immediately
and you you do want to do something
takes control over the c6 square yeah
the queen very quickly goes back to d1
of course you write self pin on c6 and i
assume he wants to play something like
f6 here because you do want to open the
central files without the central files
to play
desperately yeah it
stalls a little bit because 92 alone
doesn't really win you win you very much
right but
again if black it successfully opens up
the e file
uh these pieces on the queen side the
knight on a5 the rook on a1 may not
return yeah this is what you're playing
for with black obviously yeah yeah
trying to uh demonstrate look e6 by the
way he played rookie six here hits a
pawn
yeah actually you know very precisely
wants to take on a6 i guess
i mean
i thought he was gonna go queen h4 rook
h6 and make some counter play
i'm not sure alejandro says hey why
don't you win a pawn
takes action
looks kind of strong against this yeah
this is actually the engines hate the
way that vichy has played but okay it
was a very complicated position very
comfortable um
yeah bishop should he have played f6
though no queen b6 was queen b6 yeah
they think f6 still needs a little bit
of preparation
it's not even that clear what f6
accomplishes for you in many cases
you'll take a pawn but by that point
white's caught in bishop d2 they've
gotten in queen f3 and the opening of
the central file specifically the f file
benefited who exactly
yeah i mean i can definitely imagine
this being the case like you play bishop
d2 here just as a kind of illustration
takes takes even if we disregard the
fact that rookie 5 runs into bishop
before potentially just go queen f3 here
no
it just becomes kind of anybody's game
right three results one question about
it okay if one following hour about to
come in and yeah
the pawn on a7 still makes every end
game kind of tricky for black to play
and so on well if you're not playing uh
f6 he's played rookie six because he
very quickly replied uh replied by by
richard understandably
if you take on a6 here i assume maybe
even something quiet like bishop c3 is
good you could think about f5 but the
five rookie b6 i don't know what that
does
well the
the d pawns hanging let me again try to
persuade you
uh to give up the darkness
i do love how computers play chess
nowadays it's such a yasser way of
playing chess
knight takes a6 rook f3
knight take with the bishop still on d2
yes yeah because that way you get an
extra tempo because night before i'll
take on before today
d3 you can't do that right
these computers are good yeah because
they like fonts they like but they like
they're gonna go give stock fish
an honorary membership
and this one is over
as predicted levon just
cruised through that end game
yeah david is is getting some very very
very valuable lessons
just
don't want to take too much out of the
sales i mean sometimes when you have a
really bad outing against these top
players you think to yourself
well
academia school
no he's actually going to mizzou no
kidding oh not this year but next year
uh we do have some moves in the vicious
game he did take on asics
on the board yeah also logical yep you
won the bishop on d5 but now oh yeah he
goes bishop c3 but after night before if
white takes on before
it still needs to deal with a very
annoying threat of bishop c5 which gives
black something be compared okay i'm i'm
i guess you go knight b3 here you do
want to stop bishop c5 kind of you know
as hard effects i really like knight b3
it does so many things yeah it does
bishop c3 played bishop kind of reached
one night before and i think he spotted
knight b3 now
there's no choice
yeah yeah that knight on a6 needs to
come back in the game i mean white's
taking over in the center not to mention
the fact that the pawn on d3 is a is an
issue certainly maybe he can recapture
on b4 with the rook i mean then after
b2b3 the opponent d3 is
gone right here is a funny move though
because you'll never move the knight
again
well i mean i will eventually i will
eventually get it out why c6 i think i
don't think you will black and forever
because bishop on d5 is so strong
but also i think you can probably afford
to just if we put this on the board
bishop before it before i think i can
probably afford to take on g3 allow your
takes b2 okay takes takes knight c6 for
instance
white is definitely better the question
is how much
96 with a kind of a little slide trick
there of bishop 6 bishop f7 wait does
bishop 7 work immediately and
uh king of seven e6 yeah
mighty i was wondering and then and then
queen if i king of the queen g5 picks up
the queen
very very cute
you're not you're not you you don't want
the rook
i don't know
i don't know
that was a famous comment by
by uh larry christensen he was doing a
commentary on the icc
and it was like no i don't want no
stinking rock i was going for the bait
and it became a meme um
yeah
is she in trouble as
richie is really um
driving home the fact that he's the one
and the driver
for a four in the four knights
not h
no no none of you none of your g4 or
bishop b5
yes
uh we do have knight b4 on the board at
bishop takes b4 and b3 ideas bishop
takes b4 queen takes place he's
considering really because bishop plays
before looks like a he's just gonna
fight
wow he also doesn't want your stinking
rotation exactly
nothing right
i love it richie the the moment you see
f5 by the way it's a very rich
ingredient it's a very issue it's a very
rich move you you go
you want to take my my bishop on d5
which is a great bishop to take right
but it gives you such a beautiful little
cen well little not very little that's a
monster that's a monster center yeah
queen takes d3 e6 i actually considered
going bishop and he's definitely in this
piece he's done it the monster center
but yeah a bishop b5 so he doesn't uh he
doesn't want to see any knight c4 ideas
he wants to but after d6 it's just going
to be so difficult to challenge the
setup you can start with queen of three
as well i'm not sure we need to even put
it on d6 just yet something about queen
f3 is attractive right just maintain
because maybe we want to play e6 later
right like rookie one e6 and just give
them eight on the kings all right or
even f6 e6
i'm guessing we should go c4
alejandro is warming up over here too
hey guys
let me in on the action man i'm a grand
master and i have an engine watch out
give me that f6 uh
yeah what a game
queen f3 and vichy's kind of on the back
foot here he is dreaming of c4
c4 is in c4 is it and now we have a
choice because we can play g6 and say
yeah your bishop's not coming that
bishop is never coming out really
because d6 i think i play i have sex and
i pray
well
but you your prayers are not going to be
answered right in 25 check and then the
eef and then there's going to be some
kind of a mate somewhere but yeah i
understand what you're saying but also
from the aesthetic perspective just
going like rookie king h1 and then e6
and then just giving made you were you
were telling me that about the sicilian
where you you play you know f4 but you
also play king h1 you just tuck your
king away
so uh there are no bishop c5 issues
i like that move uh yeah absolutely uh
absolutely
so it's a very solid option and you
don't even i was kind of in my mind
connecting the idea of not playing the
six with the idea of just sacrificing
this rook on f2 but you don't have to
you can just play rook f1 if you want
i mean
anyway yeah deep breath and he's played
f6 a move that you just hope
isn't going to cost you your king side i
wonder if he wants to take with the rook
after ef
i don't think i don't think ef is
happening but i wonder if he wants to go
rook f6 bishop six queen f6 because that
bishop is just so so valuable
i would say with a near certainty he is
ready to part with the exchange
gf i currently don't see how we get
mated but
i get i get the feeling you just don't
play gf
you might reject gf if you see knight
take c4 yeah yeah this is this is what
the conclusion of the actually knight c4
and rook a7 or no
check oh
yeah they just pick up everything yeah
you pick up black's center
yeah in the meantime the catalan will be
drawn so we don't have to go there yeah
again it's just a draw oh
yeah
there we go yeah
but even sort of
uh
by the way i just have a feeling
conceptually this is just kind of nice
even though this has been on the back
foot and there's so been so many
different ways for white
advantages to increase
he
he's still there he's throwing
the patties and it's not
no it's not clear at all actually the
engines objectively said ef was bad okay
and that you should play knight c6 first
but he's got 96 here and like i expected
him not to take on f6 yeah bishop takes
dc and you have to make it precise
because it looks like rook f7 is the
most natural move in the position right
protecting a7 moving the rook away but
after queen e4
you struggle protecting the opponent's
e4 you actually can't protect the
opponent's e4 oh no this was drawn as
expected
and we do have rook f7 wesley so he has
played rockefeller so what's what's the
reply to queen e4 queen e4 there's a
very clever rook b5
the idea is that if you take on c4 rook
c5 somehow ends up picking up your cc
okay yeah and and the game continues and
that's the kind of move that you're
desperate to play as black because
you're thinking to yourself if i can get
my rook behind the pawn yeah or or maybe
even get queen d5 and i thought the idea
was quincy for 25
yeah yeah
yeah
as long as this d3 pawn survives for the
next
dozen or so moves it's not great
definitely this definitely represents an
improvement right his fortunes yeah even
though
but the queen stays on the f3 square
terrified d2 rules
and takes f5 this is now
what does happen after rook b5 bishop c5
also known as bishop c5 is another i
don't know why we're pushing the rook to
f1 i don't really like i actually want
the background to be as unprotected as
possible i don't know if i
because i thought i was pinning the rook
many things that's what it was all about
so many things i think after rugby fight
ritchie will just play g4 knowing richie
he just kind of just blinks
without
no way no way you can take on c4 right
i think you can actually because you
lose the bishop but you're not worse
rook takes c4 bf5 we take on the five
twice you go g2 i go takes takes rook
ff1
white is definitely not worse there but
you're probably also not winning
wow the c the c pawn will cost you the
bishop
are you sure i'm pretty sure yeah you
can't play 28 queen c8 i'm that's not
playing for a win no i don't think
that's playing for a win i don't either
i was hoping that queenie too but then i
saw that you would not play rook
to see one which would allow bishop to
d6 fc you would play rule fc1
and that one uh but that kind of bails
like you get the feeling this is a draw
because two against two the the rooks
probably don't win against the queen
even if even if the entire queen side
disappears there is enough count to play
there potentially for that to be a draw
problem with the desirable gp it depends
on it depends on pawn configuration
but also it's a very very
committal decision to make on two
minutes you have other moves here you
can still play queen e4 uh which
is clearly worse here with the rook on
a4 than it was with the rook on a1 but
it's still a move you can make because
e1 is protected so you are never really
in danger of blundering some mates like
that
and a good thing too yeah i would never
say never goes f6 this move i kind of
discounted but yeah it protects the pawn
of the five by moving it to a safer
square yeah i can i can see the
reasoning behind this i want to play
queen g5 here as black
oh no he goes rook c5 he says i'm in no
hurry i don't need to commit to anything
just yet well he's defending his players
c6 as well not yet but he puts pressure
on it yeah eventually and fg is not
really a threat yet and it's difficult
to actually make it a threat and even if
you provoke or end or like quote-unquote
force black to play g7 g6 you're not
going to be there
foreign as well so the question is can
we well i don't like the idea of letting
you capture the pawn on g7 when you get
mated unfortunately do it right well if
i go rook takes c7
bishop goes to
oh shoot
yeah where
yeah
rook of seven queen of three check will
pick up a rook at the h h five
destabilizing the queen
yeah
he says he says g4 is a good square i
don't want it yeah yeah and just say
it's a massive blunder unfortunately oh
no queen g6 it looks like this is
threatening seven oh
yeah
queen f7
he goes queen e6 with similar ideas but
that's much weaker because queen d5 now
exists yeah which didn't exist in the
previous turn and no he didn't play
queen d6 d6 oh oh
he's done it no and he had to resign
instantly oh a one move blunder and an
unbelievable
in an unbelievably tense position yes
what would it what was that after 25 we
take take we take on c4 i assume white
is playing for a win but yeah maybe this
uh this is somehow holdable for black
i'm not sure it looks
kind of meh but the game continues here
you can play bishop c5 or bishop d6 or
something i mean the game starts the
game doesn't continue it actually starts
yeah yeah
it starts starts in you it doesn't
continue there's no flares in here oh
but for richie what a marvelous win as
he knocks his rival down and he
climbs to here's why he's one point
behind one point he's one point behind
the scene
with blitz to come yeah what is going on
here what
managed to make a mess
doing like he'll take on h5 take on d5
black will take on a5 at the end and
something like rook c6 will make a draw
that's my prediction
that was very bold prediction on like
two seconds
and more or less he kind of did it nice
you can keep pushing people the heavy
cases on the board you can go knight
takes d5 i don't know if it's stronger
or not than rook takes d5
well something to be said no king f7
sorry knight takes d5 bishop a5
oh this
now
can i see that again knight takes d5
bishop takes a5 he's taken with a knight
yeah
i can also throw in g6 i don't know if i
need no g696 check no no
i think i think that's helping me uh
rook
f5 ideas i can play i can play g6 now
after rook five i will play g6 i think i
think so too yeah i feel like wow
weakening the uh it's not really
weakening my king with the with the rook
on a7 controlling most of the important
square that's actually a dark square
bishop right yeah and the dark square
bishop which eventually yeah i'm very
curious about you you're on point with
rook five even rook f7 is actually
playable i don't like rook f5
well
i wonder why yeah why both of you are so
in love with this but what at the
american school of chess human funding
the american school of chess we we
went to the same summer camp
yes yeah
right and uh yeah 14 seconds against 20
as you can see on your screen which is
obviously a huge factor here by the way
a rook f7 i could take twice right i'd
take on f7 take on ac
f7 i think it's g6
rook f8 97 c7 is important but it works
wow
that is that is a move yeah that is yeah
obviously uh knight eastern entirely
unafraid yeah black is now better the
question is whether it's enough because
exactly white is very active
pawn down yeah rook c6 the kind of
forces bishop i mean force is a strong
word but heavily invites bishop before
he goes king g2 rupee i will just play
rupee seven here i i think we need to
shed the one on e6 yeah yeah yeah get
some activity as well right and yeah and
activate activate the rook still feels
like like in general
i think yeah i think white generally
holds these positions quite often
because of how active
is i don't know the rook and bishop
usually make a good combination
of i actually kind of like c4 because
rook c6 rook be savage yeah he wants to
play with seven next one do we play king
g3 here so that rook takes b2 is not a
check yes i think that's a very good guy
he wants d7 now yeah he wants from this
this is why he played i i like rookie
seven so because it kicks the knight out
because there's a bishop
it's a very clever sequence c4 because
now the rook takes d5 defends the bishop
on a5 rookie five right uh expected we
probably throw in king of seven question
mark
exclamation
just to kind of pass the move again
because we don't know i am more like
bishop d2 or you can go rogue b7 now if
you want to keep f7 king f7 is
understandable if three or four now i
like bishop d2 oh bishop d8 yeah he
wants to have access to the f6 square
also covers the seven so that there are
nothing like it it's fine
now we go
now is the time and now it looks like
white black is making a lot less
progress progress wow that's very good
no question about it he's a very strong
blitz player you know he's a very very
strong blitz player wow 93 yeah we can
take on biz2 give a check go rugby three
two yeah yeah we can go start with rugby
three but i guess c4 i don't know king
g4 i don't know what that i'm just
getting out of the pin i just don't know
how
um
bishop f6 i didn't like giving the a5
square to the rook i'm not sure i i
think this is great
i thought i thought preventing the rook
from landing on a5 was kind of important
yeah
agreed
because another holiday six actually is
i like the bishop on d8 yeah yeah i
thought i thought it was very well
placed on it we didn't need to commit to
a square just yet because we could have
just made a move but here we
but
go
think it's pretty good yeah rook before
we can even go back yeah that's the
problem with force moves yeah it's
sometimes uh this is clever but he was
gonna be two with the bishop
and the c4 pawn will not be hanging so
it survives on c3
this is clever by by kill yeah now he
goes bishop
okay
yeah i'm pretty sure yeah
from what we've seen of him in this
tournament and also in general he's not
in the business of repeating in the next
yeah i don't think so no i don't think
he's in the business of repeating here
well but he's definitely been going
about his business in a very admirable
way i yeah
yeah we can take on bitsun now
bishop takes b2 we haven't
ruptured because the forks on d6 make it
very very awkward to try and take with
the rook so i think the rook needs to
stay on before
and the opponent b2 needs to be off the
board by this point just just take it
the bishop is also hanging so yeah yeah
yeah also that yeah
i don't know why we could check why we
are
encouraging the king to go up even to g4
at this point at this point yeah you
just want your king out of the way this
is the first move i really disagreed
with i think weakening this and
especially because knight d6 check the
84 suddenly exists yes
yeah i think maybe he wants uh he has
like dreams of king g4 maybe
mating the guy yeah pushing the bishop
back on f6 go and g6 h5 mate but i think
that's a bit different well kimchi for
h5
maybe oh yeah
yeah
yeah but still like you're looking for
bishop b2 you go 96 you take on c4 you
take on a6 and that two against one on
one side you generally don't lose very
much i agree just a second
okay he has gotten king e4 but why did
king g4 lose h5 he takes h5
the ruckus
yeah you haven't played rook a6 yet
sorry there's not only six yet and he
has gotten in his knight d6 check yeah i
think and this is after the e6 after
king e6 you can even take on e6 first
and then perhaps discover that you're
taking it
pretty easy just taking on c4
immediately
yeah i think i think fabi holds now yeah
wow i don't know if he's worse anymore
well i mean it's it's two against one
yeah king is seven like you take you
take two but you lose h3 right
it takes two
like bishop f6 here and play sort of
continues but yeah the activity of the
pieces will be such like they can start
giving checks yeah yeah maybe knight e3
you
know
also 93 93 i wasn't actually preserving
actually preserves the pawns right what
was the pawn here but the king only
seven you can't actually keep the the
yeah you can't keep the pawn only six
alive very nicely spotted by five yeah
this will be a drum
yes
look before checking of three rugby
three king e4
i'm i'm i'm saying yeah
see
i'm very see i am a professional
[Laughter]
see
wow what an event for round nine i have
to say a little bit of an hour escape
there for favi he was under pressure the
entire game but kept it under control
it seems so
and for kiril it's like
once he won the junior
championship he's
he's really he's in he's in this
tournament uh now you could see i mean
he
literally outplayed fabi yeah with the
black pieces he had much the better of
this game with the black pieces against
which is
not easy more decisive uh
games three out of the five games were
decisive uh for this round nine
and uh boy did our leader board i want
to see the leaderboard i want to see
where we stand going into the
i love the applause from the audience
that's really really endearing uh
i i remember i went to riga
michael tall played in the interzonal
and it was packed packed back theaters
and you know whenever
michael won the the game they i i i it's
it's so incredible not only did the
audience applause they stood yeah
and it was like they had these silence
you know
things in russian
but they didn't help i mean the audience
could care less about the arbiter
hitting a silence but i have my own
favorite story on this topic but it's
kind of long-ish okay
but it's it's wonderful well i mean it
it for chess players that you you come
off the stage with a big and and mine
was like the point of the story wasn't
yeah this is this is what we have
remaining yeah the the rapid portion is
over bishop is still leading but his
lead was cut severely by uh the surging
richard rapport and right 18 rounds of
blitz await us in the next couple of
days
five plus two blitz with a normal
scoring system meaning that
the same 18 points are at stake
uh and uh yeah potential tie breaks
which look
more likely now than they perhaps did
when you shared it by five points or
something and look at that leaderboard
it's actually pretty cool it's funny
yeah 14 13.
yeah that was the first time
carol they're ruining it man
right right you needed that eight
but there it is uh
very nice uh vichy richard
duda wesley lavonne
all in the mix fabby
[Music]
that's a five five points eighteen a lot
fabi's got a lot of ground to make up
almost makes me wonder
about our predictions i had wesley so
you're doing fine you're doing i took
fabi and i'm
still on the outside with wesley how am
i doing
did you have duda did i have duda
i guess i did
look at that look at that guy
but the guys who had richard oh man
speaking of the man he's currently in
second place and in warsaw with
christian
thank you alejandro we are indeed with
the man of the hour here in warsaw
richard rapport richard a topsy-turvy
day for you you started off blazing hot
with this game against voitashek after
that you cooled off against wesley but
you finished strong against vichy anand
describe your feelings as well as the
way you approached today's rounds
oh well
hard to describe them actually i thought
plus one which i ended up making
before the the day it would be a decent
result
um yeah obviously if you look at the
tournament situation it was very
important to score against mishi
because he was just running away with it
but of course i feel a little bit uh
bitter about this yeah because uh
okay he's such a legend and what he's
done here i mean it's just incredible
even against me i think he had very good
winning chances okay
pretty much out of the opening but still
i mean
he should maybe he should have even had
more points than he did yeah which is
crazy
it's still competition in the end but
let's start with this moment in the
first round of today against voitasha
when you play this move bishop to d3
tell us about this one uh yeah this is a
nonsense move actually of course
um yeah i figured i played we should be
published of c4 already so we need to
play with you this you know i had
actually games here uh here in warsaw in
the european blitz i i think i beat
kiril
janko here in the last round and i think
i drew with uh locating this bishop dc3
so it's
pretty much aiming to to get kind of a
hybrid uh uh with the c3 ideas here c3
from rue lopez yeah yeah but maybe to
play castles uh first so just in case uh
you know uh
andrew kim not to show cars immediately
with c3 so this is the idea know how i
came to this is that 11 told me a story
uh about uh e4 c5 bishop d3 like that
this is the stupidest move and tell us
some game here with black and i thought
okay i can do better you can improve
yeah i can improve on that yes so like
knight f3 and then bishop g3 of course
i'm not
you know too proud of this but well this
is what i now over dinner last night you
told me that you have a lot of these
let's say nonsensical weapons in your
arsenal is it still the case and are you
going to employ more in the blitz even
more nonsensical ones in the blitz yeah
i hope so i mean at the end of the day
i'm trying to of course
partially hide some prep but also just
to have some fun
and i feel like you know getting some
big positions out of the way to to have
it at least for me
um yeah but actually this game against
radek turned out to be very classical so
quite smooth yeah
and and then after that i played a very
normal uh line yeah king's indian and
they
actually let's go through that one
because that one was just simply wild
yeah no i mean i think i was doing very
well okay this is a main line but i was
doing okay
really well um i think he kind of
tricked himself second try you're trying
uh yeah here uh the kings in the end did
you have any doubts about going for the
king no i play this very frequently in
shorter time control so i yeah and here
you just treat himself with a4 uh
basically that after a4 uh
when i do this g5 h5 i think if the pawn
was still on a3 he goes knight h2 and i
can resign but but here i have 94 and
his queen is kind of trapped yeah so i
ended up having a huge advantage i mean
look at this position yeah like if i
like just step upon amazing structure
yeah and then i ended up losing this of
course at the end i just blundered in
one even more time on the clock yeah you
know i had this position actually it's
completely winning probably um here yeah
it'll be seven
and then i felt like i have
visually seven is just a piece up but uh
i have okay
some kind of play but i also have for
bishop e6 is very good and then i played
queen e6 and just completely forgot
about queen g5 and it's immediately game
over like yeah there was no way back so
this was not such a presentation just
completely uh yeah i mean g5 was a blind
spot
yeah pretty much here i mean it's uh
something that i brought with me from
bucharest obviously so
um but you know bishop d7 was having
just an extra piece yeah and i have five
minutes so at this point i didn't feel
like i was you know kind of forced to
blunder but this is what happens so you
know you're winning then you lose in a
couple of moves how do you recover going
into the final game against uh
vishwanathan
yeah you know i've okay i've been in
this situation a couple of times already
where kind of winning is the only result
that uh matters yeah i mean of course uh
there is also second place in the
tournament but
uh still i invite and
this game
verse double guys so i i i should try
so i played this uh i decided to play uh
another nonsense movie four
um i don't even know what's the idea of
this one yeah i saw this fun forest
brother before he is uh
four i think oh all the way
back so i saw this farm forest brothers
for doing this a4 yeah but i just don't
really understand what's the point of it
but i thought okay why not and he ended
up responding relatively sloppy of
course he i mean he's perfectly fine but
he didn't like punish me for playing e4
so we got this position which is kind of
a classical um periodic thing here but
he's got a better version obviously
because of my early a4 right here
he's an ib4 jumps and everything but
overall the line is supposed to be bad
and then i did this what everyone is
doing and how they don't equalize it's
pretty impressive because i've seen many
games and i play as black so here of
course this f4 uh
it shouldn't be played exactly for what
uh the reason for what happened in the
game but i know many games with the f4
have ideas so i went for it navy and
then i was thinking okay i'm already
worth great
and then he treated me with this great
idea bishop f5
in terms though it's very nice because
he played by fate first to to go out of
he takes f6 uh tempo
and then rook f2 and here was critical
moment knight a4
and he should have played this three
area i clearly i think so he should have
sucked the piece and i don't know what i
would have done because if i uh do
something with the c pawn he will go
knight e4 and if i take the piece well
dc2
takes and c4 is coming it just looks
enormous compensation did you guys get
to discuss this uh position after the
game yeah he just calculated 94 okay two
i think uh but i mean i i told him i
think this is very strong but okay it's
not an easy move to make because at this
point it doesn't seem like he's in you
know any kind of danger you're changing
the yeah yeah and this way is kind of an
all-in-one right because you can just
lose so it's uh i understand that maybe
he didn't feel like it was the situation
was calling for us anyway afterwards i
feel like um yeah it was of course a
completely strange position as you can
see with this knight's uh absolutely on
the rim and bishop on b7 uh very strange
but i felt like okay i am
i'm not maybe worse anymore and then
later on okay i'm pawn up and i have
great structure right so i consolidated
and i i i mean i think i missed the win
which i couldn't believe at this point
it was indeed completely winning and
yeah yeah yeah maybe a five was a little
no yeah i wanted to take on before and i
didn't see after queen d3 i mean look
before queen d3
was happening with something to a4 like
okay for maybe i think i didn't see
exactly it but and maybe seven foot can
be six it's not so clear but it's
worried about the knight yeah i mean i'd
be seven i can play yeah because rugby
seven is bishop f7 check so like this
ico actually but
yeah like but i thought that you know
like the pawn on d6 might not uh
survive but obviously yeah yeah it does
so anyway but after f6 it was an
incredible moment 96 just finishes the
game
and bishop takes this ndc and i get the
same as in the game just his rook is
completely cut
and then i uh for some reason i i
discovered this 96 after i took ef6 like
immediately and then of course it's not
winning that much anymore it's not the
same anymore yeah and then i was just
about to misplay in the time scramble
here and okay queen g6 was winning i
guess yes
and i played queen to e6 and now yeah
i was very happy about this end game
obviously this is what
bothered him but we didn't we stopped
here like c7 but bishop c5 is extremely
strong and i can't
maintain
the europe on f2 yeah it has to move and
i will give something about this
b6 yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly so
it's just a bishop c5 was just uh
blunder but okay we were short on time
and luckily for me and kate's really
unpleasant but he just blundered queen
takes f7
which i suppose surprisingly richie i
would say quite a successful uh trip so
far in the first three days uh one point
behind they're going into the blitz
section how would you assess your
chances i think last time i was here in
warsaw i lost 160 points in blitz so
that speaks for itself uh maybe i'll
make it to 200 or
or hopefully not yeah i will try my best
but i don't have
high expectations at this point i will
just uh you know it's blitz and
for me you know like even five minutes
on the clock i can lose from peace up
yeah but uh when it comes to blitz and
you start with five minutes okay what
kind of expectations can i have
always entertaining always a pleasure to
watch your games we'll see you tomorrow
richie yeah guys back to you thank you
christian thank you uh
richie uh
did he miss any opportunity to insult
himself the last time i was in warsaw
i'd lost 150 points dudes in second
place he just beat his closest rifle
one draw in this tournament wow wow
i mean talk about uh swinging for the
fences richie uh comeback kid yeah after
and here we have a very nice moment uh a
lot of the children were invited on
stage
to
actually uh do selfies with their heroes
peter and you can see uh a lot of them
are shy though one
one person but that might be lavon
that's levon
the guy with a really bright shirt who
do you think that is he's crowding out
the children from getting close i mean
this is terrible get out of here
come on
uh but that's very very nice i like that
it's always
when i see a lot of children at a chess
tournament i'm very
very happy i think that chess has a
bright future
thanks to the children being there
and one more time let's take a look at
the predictions after uh the rapids are
finished
nobody got first and second so we're
really bad at this
but um
nasty and i we got we got our boy duda
there
on third two points behind the leader so
he has everything to play for going into
the last 18 rounds of blitz plenty of
tournament to play for the last 18
minutes
and let's go to warsaw for final
thoughts with anastasia and christian
well uh guys another fantastic day of
chess here in warsaw uh poland a lot of
topsy-turvy games but in the end it is
the tiger of madras that's going into
the blitz section with a one point lead
and we know as the times get faster he
gets better so we're definitely going to
have to wait and see what he's going to
be bringing tomorrow to the tables and
of course richie rapport wesley so
always within striking distance always
in contention to win the whole event is
going to be a fantastic two days of
blitz action anastasia how about
yourself yeah it was great day and uh
actually impressed by richard ruppert
and his victory on in the last round we
all know that richard is going to play a
marathon he's he played in bucharest he
continues in war so he'll go to norwich
so of course we have to root for him we
have to admit that he will have a really
tough period um a lot of chess lately so
i was also impressed by player of kiril
shevchenko today because who scored two
out of three by the way didn't lose any
game today so he showed his strengths
finally i think he feels more confident
today so let's see what he will do in
the blitz section because he's known to
be as a good blitz player so looking
forward for the day for tomorrow he's a
fantastic blitz player actually we have
so many great bliss players in this
competition we're going to have a lot of
fun in the next couple of days guys back
to you in the studio in st louis yes we
are indeed thank you anastasia thank you
christian
final thoughts uh of this very eventful
day alejandro well i am glad that vichy
finished at the top there in the rapid
of course we combined scores so there's
no particular price for winning the
rapid the tournament continues but
in some ways as a commentator also happy
that there is a
little bit less of a gap there and we
have everything to play for starting
tomorrow it's a brand new time control
five plus two none of this rapid stuff
they're going to be fast and furious no
time to recover from losses tilt abound
i'm excited for the blitz i always love
calling it and i'm gonna have a lot of
fun calling it with you guys tomorrow
same time thank you alejandro indeed
that's going to happen all tomorrow at
the same time same channel thank you for
joining us goodbye from st louis see you
then
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited